I'm here rather than just rock up and
only play the game. I'm currently
undefeated seven over Teemo, so doing
pretty well.
I'll be I'll be honest, I'm playing
Teemo, so I don't think I'll be the
champion, but it'll be a fun run for day
two. I'd love to give a shout out to my
Cheers Squad Discord testing server,
Anzac Cabal, and uh after that, my local
store, Zen Collective, best store in
Melbourne. Vibes are immaculate. And
also big shout out to my other Sydney
friends uh Brendan Shei and Carl Aiden
Keto.
>> Have you been feeling moody lately? Are
you also tired of conquering for your
points all the time? Do you not want to
play a normie deck like the others? Then
we got the deck just for you. Vex
Gloomist appears in Unleashed, a legend
that massively profits from holding
battlefields. Stop your opponent from
ambushing or accelerating consistently
as early as turn two with Vex apathetic
as your chosen champion unit. Tell your
opponents to back off by stunning their
units when they try to conquer. Play
your shadow ready into battlefields to
immediately use its ability on the
opposing turn. Vex can rely on so many
different defensive tools that the calm
and chaos domain already have. Use
guardian angel and zona's hourglass to
protect your units from dying. Not so
fast and defy to counter opposing spells
and deny their tempo, but also new
defensive cards can be found in unleash
like existential dread or the mutated
mouser. But in the shadow isles, a
monster lurks supporting Vex, giving her
near unlimited defensive and offensive
possibilities. Enter Vmore. The spider
god has ambush, meaning it can be played
offensive and defensively. with this
powerful eight mighty jumps into a
battlefield that you are attacking and
crushes any unit smaller than it without
taking a single hit. If your opponents
doesn't manage to push it out of a
battlefield, an additional draw for
holding is a free bonus. With these
cards in your deck, you're going to be
able to keep all the others away from
your battlefields. Keep holding, rift
bounders.
A key component of playing League of
Legends is gathering XP and leveling up.
Now you can do that in Riftbound 2 with
the newest additions in Unleashed. Every
XP you get will add to your level as a
player and will benefit you in different
forms. So far, three legends have been
released that directly benefit from XP
gain. Ka'Zix Void Reva, Poppy, Keeper of
the Hammer, and Master Yi Wu Master.
Notice that all of these have the body
domain in common. Master Yi uses XP
passively. With higher level, he finds
stronger passive effects. At level six,
your units are permanently boosted. And
at level 11, your units always enter
ready. Of course, in the main deck, most
masteries will rely on the champion
unit, Master Yi, unstoppable as a win
condition. This one gets cheaper the
more XP you have, and at level 16, it
even becomes unargetable. Combined with
Master Yu Master's ability to enter
ready, he can really swing gains.
Kha'Zix and Poppy have the unique
ability to gain XP through their own
legend abilities and otherwise use it
like a resource. While Poppy generates
card advantage by spending XP, Kha'Zix
gains utility by either buffing his
units or moving exhausted units away
from their battlefields back to base.
Since all of these three legends have
the body domain in common, there's a
huge variety of body cards that can get
you the XP you need through the hunt
keyword, for example. Hunt cards grant
you an XP whenever you conquer or hold.
So winning combats for those decks is of
utmost importance. Cards like Gemand
Hunter, Voracious Gromp, and Master Heat
Tempered can be found in all three
decks, but XP can also be splashed into
other decks. Grim Resolve, for example,
is a strong combat trick that gives the
unit free might on action speed. If the
unit wins a combat, it grants you two
XP. This card might find its way into
other decks as well. Fiora players have
already played around with the
Shepherd's Heirloom, which works like a
Dorance Blade, but does not equip for
power cost, but for XP. There are plenty
of ways to integrate some XP gain into
your deck, so get those level in and
scale into the late game, Riftbounders.
Welcome to Riftbound Basics. This time
we are talking about legends, chosen
champions, and signature spells. The
heart of your deck is your legend. This
determines which domains you are allowed
to play in your deck. Let's take Kaisa,
Daughter of the Void, as an example.
With her as your legend, you can play
cards from the Fury and Mind domains and
consequently Fury and Mind runes. You
also have the option to play a chosen
champion unit, Kaiser Survivor, or
Kaiser Evolutionary. At the start of the
game, you can take this unit from your
main deck and place it in the chosen
champion unit zone right next to your
legend. You can play this card from this
zone at any time as if it were a normal
card from your hand. If it dies, it does
not return to the zone, but goes to the
trash. Another important factor in
deciding which legend to play is the
signature card. Even if the domains
match, you can only play this card in
the main deck of the corresponding
legend. For Kaiser, this would be
Atheian Rain, which you couldn't play in
a rumble deck, even though it's also
Fury and Mind. Which legend do you like
best? And is there one you only play
because their signature spell is so
good? Let us know in the comments.
We're here at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifiers in Sydney 2026 and we're
going to take you for a tour of the
showgrounds. Let's go.
So, the first step on our journey to the
Sydney Showgrounds is here. This is the
badge collection, where you will start
your rift down journey in Sydney 2026.
Make sure you get all of your promo
cards and your playmats.
Enough you've got your badges. Don't
forget to get your merch here. We have a
full merch wall as well as statues,
playmats, and more for your riffbound
enjoyment.
So, you've got your badge, you've found
your way past the merch wall, and you
are inside the showgrounds. Now, don't
forget to come to registration where the
friendly and helpful staff will make
sure you are signed up for all of the
events that you want to play.
So, now that you've registered, you'll
be wanting to earn tickets for the prize
wall. Don't forget there are some unique
prizes you can earn here which include
the metal prize wall tickets. But we
also have some oversized battlefields as
well as the Riftbound regional qualifier
Sydney pin.
But it's not all about competitive
events here at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifiers in Sydney. We also have some
free play areas where you and some
friends can just get together and play
some games. We also have cosplayers
roaming the halls to bring the magic of
League of Legends and Riftbound to life
here today. And we also have some
creator activations where you'll find
some content creators putting forward
their best content for you to enjoy.
for your competitive viewing pleasure.
If you're knocked out early or side
events for your jam, we also have a
schedule where you can come and enjoy
the competitive scene here with the big
screen and the chairs behind me as well.
It's a viewing platform for everyone to
enjoy. And if you've forgotten any cards
you need for your decks at the regional
Riftbound qualifiers in Sydney, the
vendors have you sorted. With more than
six different vendors, they'll have you
covered, including signed overn numbers.
A new addition at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifier Sydney is the signature wall.
Don't forget to get down here and check
it out and maybe sign it just like I
have.
At the Riftbound Regional Qualifier
Sydney 2026, you'll also find side
events. We have a little something for
everyone from 2v2s, trios, sealed, and
preconstructed fights. You'll find it
all here in the side of event area here
at the Riftbound regional qualifiers in
Sydney. We even have the featured
tables. This is where we will see the
best of the best Riftbound players in
the world come together to fight it out
for the regional championship. And on to
Worlds. And here we find ourselves at
the main event. This is where all of the
action happens. These players will be
fighting for best of cards. They'll be
vying for the second day gameplay and to
hit those featured tables. But more
importantly, they've come here to win it
all. And for all of you hungry gamers,
do not forget we also have three food
trucks parked out the back, including
some of our personal favorites, the
pizza. Make sure you check that out on
your breaks between games.
So, that's the Riftbound regional
qualifiers for Sydney 2026. You've seen
it all. You've got the tour. If you're
not here, then where the bloody hell are
you?
We are here at the Aru in Sydney. I am
joined by Brismat, fresh off a win in
Atlanta. How are you feeling about
Sydney?
>> I really enjoy it here. The weather's
been really nice. I like the wildlife
and so far it's been going all right. I
think maybe a bit jet-lagged. I think
I'm not playing amazingly 3 and one so
far in the PRQ, but it's all right. Got
to get the losses out of the way today
and then do well in the main event. as
long as you get them over and done with
now. And you do still have the jet lag
to contend with. So, how recently did
you get in?
>> I got in yesterday morning. So, Thursday
morning, today's Friday, and it it
hasn't been I haven't felt bad, but
gameplay is has felt bad. So,
>> well, there's a whole weekend ahead and
there's plenty to see how it's going.
How are you feeling with everybody here?
>> Oh, it's nice. Yeah, everyone traveling
out from different parts of the world.
Allan coming from Europe. Randy, I mean,
he's kind of living in China at this
point, so it's a bit easier of a trip
for him. Uh, but yeah, seeing everyone
again, and then we'll see each other all
in Vancouver as well.
>> And obviously, we've just had Unleashed
release. How does that change how you're
approaching Sydney compared to how your
decks have been in the past?
>> Uh, honestly, it feels for me similar to
Le where I settled on Annie. I feel like
the deck is good. I know that I'm not
going to have any really bad matchups,
so I can always play my way out of any
match to be able to win. Um, but it's
not like I'm super confident. I think
when I was going into Atlanta, I was
thinking, "Okay, my my deck's the best
deck." And Allan saying, "Yeah, your
deck's still the best deck." And maybe
starting to believe him over time, I
think Diana's also really strong. Um,
but it is really interesting cuz there's
a limit to how much you can prepare for
each matchup. Like you can say, "Okay,
we expect these decks to be the the top
percentage, top meta decks coming in."
Like Aurora is a big one. Um, I think
today there's a lot of Master Yi and
Aurelia, which is a bit surprising
because they don't have very good Aurora
matchups. Um, but you know, prepare
against the the expected matchups and
then the rest of them you just have to
go on the fly.
>> Well, we will see what happens. Uh,
we'll see whether it comes down to Annie
and Diana. Who knows? Maybe we'll see
how it goes. We've got a whole weekend
ahead of us. Thank you so much and good
luck.
>> I'm here at the Sydney Ripbound Regional
Qualifier. Right before the weekend
kicks off, I have the one and only Alan
TQ. Alan, how are you doing in the preq?
>> Uh, wonderful. Lack of sleep doesn't
stop me from just winning back to back
so far the runs and hopefully it follows
up until tomorrow.
>> So, how you feeling about your deck? You
have changed legends but not uh domains
and we kind of knew this was coming.
How's Diana treating you?
>> Uh very good deck is so good. I think
it's like the second best deck in the
format right now.
>> What's the best deck then?
>> Ani
better than any player on your team
maybe that we'll be seeing around. most
certainly he will he will swap
eventually to the same domains in
different champion but for this event
there was a bit short of time on the for
the practice because uh we just finished
Atlanta and then we had to travel so and
we had literally one week to practice
and we just stick to what we know uh but
for the next events we'll definitely be
mixing up
>> how have we been feeling about unleash
then obviously set very close to release
kind of with this event how have you
been feeling about the shifts as set 3
joins Riftbound
>> oh it's amazing there is such a
widespread meta you get to play around
so so many things against so many things
and like it just diff so many different
play styles. It makes hard with the
current sideboard side to make a deck
that's going to be all around deep
decent into everything. You have to
sacrifice the some matchups uh because
how like low on the cards you have in
just the cyber slots.
>> Of course, expecting a pretty diverse
metag game over the weekend. There are
40 legends now and obviously you're
chasing Diana. You went pretty well on
the Ezreal hunt. How's Diana going to go
in this season? Uh, I like I like the
deck to the extent where I think I could
go for four out of four on Diana. We'll
see how it goes on the event. I might
get humbled and the deck might actually
fall apart and like it might run out of
just the value in general and maybe too
much tempo. We'll see. But, uh, as solid
set as well, so worst case, it's a
fallback. Best of luck. Have a great
tournament. Thank you so much.
Heat.
Welcome to Riftbond Basics featuring the
ground rules. Riftbond is a trading card
game based on the League of Legends
universe in which the aim is to score
eight victory points across two
different battlefields. Points are
scored by moving your own units onto one
of the battlefields and conquering it or
by holding it for more than one turn.
The different car types in Riftbound are
units, gears, and spells. To play these,
you must pay an energy cost, which is
shown in the top left corner of the
card, as well as a power cost. Energy is
obtained by exhausting runes. These come
from the 12 card rune deck from which
the top two cards are played for free at
the beginning of each turn. If you
exhaust your runes to pay energy, you
must also pay a power cost for some
cards. To do this, you simply place one
of your runes bearing the symbol shown
on the card under your rune deck. You
can also use runes that are already
exhausted for this.
The domains of the runes and the cards
you play in your main and sight deck are
determined by your legend. Units that
you play enter the board exhausted. This
means they cannot move until they are
readied at the start of the next turn.
Just like all other exhausted cards on
your side, you initially play your units
and gears into your base. There they are
protected from combat. Gears can't get
into combat. If you already control a
battlefield, you also have the option to
play your units directly from your hand
onto it. This is where your units might
comes into play. This is the number
shown on the top right hand corner of
the units. Might represents both the
attack power and the defensive stat of
your units. If a player moves units into
an already occupied battlefield, combat
stunts. Here, spells with action and
reaction speed can be activated to deal
damage or modify might. When combat
occurs, and no player wishes to activate
any more spells or abilities, the total
might of all units is added together and
distributed amongst the opposing units.
Players may decide for themselves which
opposing unit they wish to damage. Once
combat is over, any damage is healed by
units that were involved and did not
die. The game ends when a player reaches
eight victory points. Though this is not
quite so easy to achieve, whilst every
other point simply requires conquering a
battlefield to earn the eighth point,
you must either have held a battlefield
for one round or you score two points in
the same round. Now you've got all the
information you need to know to start
enjoying a game of Riftbound.
Uh my name is Josh and I'm from Berat
Victoria. Um what got me into Riftbound
was the mana system. Um because in Magic
I've come from a Magic Gathering
background that is a bit different to
this obviously, but I really enjoyed
Riftbound. The rune system was probably
the best thing I've known about it and
the player base is fantastic in Berat.
Uh champion deck I'm running is Azir.
He's he's really good cuz he's very
consistent, low to the ground, gets on
the points real quick. Um it's very fun.
The deck is definitely suited to my play
style. Um I'm a very aggressive person.
Um but it also has some few things um
that tricks up its sleeve. I do have
experience playing other TCGs like Magic
Gathering um as well as uh a little bit
of like Hearthstone online. Sydney RQ
was probably my first major event for I
think about 15 years. So it's good. a
family trip up here with the kids and
the wife. So, I was lucky to come here.
So, it was really fun. My wife and my
wife is pretty happy that I'm competing,
doing something fun. Um, but yeah, the
she's not the she she's not really into
it, per se, but my tournament runs
really good. I'm 4-1 at the moment on
this year. Um, and we're about to start
the next round, so it's going to be good
fun. Definitely will see me at the next
Riftbound event in Australia. I'd like
to shout out Guff Berat um for
supporting us while we're here. Um, and
Good Games Berat as well.
Welcome to Riftbound Basics featuring
runes. In the Riftbound TCG, your energy
to play cards comes automatically. Each
player brings their own rune deck
consisting of 12 cards. This consists of
runes in the domains of your legend. A
Draven deck, for example, can play Chaos
and Fury runes. At the start of your
turn, immediately after you have readied
all your cards and received points for
holding a battlefield, you may play the
top two cards from your rune deck.
You need runes to pay the energy and
power costs on your cards. For example,
for victor leader, you must pay four
energy, which means exhausting four
runes of any color and then pay a power
cost. You do this by placing a rune of
the color shown under the energy cost at
the bottom of your rune deck. This
process is also called recycling.
Some cards, such as Seal of Insight,
have no energy cost, but do have a power
cost. However, to ensure your energy
isn't lost, you may float the energy.
That is, exhaust your runes, place them
under your rune deck, and later use the
energy gained to play another card.
Consequently, power costs have no effect
on the current turn in which you play
the cards, but can have a significant
impact on subsequent turns as you are
constantly playing with fewer runes. How
do you like your runes best in
Riftbound? Do you prefer them furious
and chaotic, or rather calm and orderly?
My name is Melanie Bracewell and I um am
from New Zealand but I live in
Melbourne. I'm a very competitive person
and I love sport. My fiance plays played
Yu-Gi-Oh and I said I would never play
that game because I hate being bad at
things. And then when Brickbound came
out, everyone was bad at it because it
was new to everyone. and that's how he
got me in. The element about Riffound I
like the most is I'm a League of Legends
player as well. And so I like that a lot
of the cards match their champions in
the game. Like it makes sense. The deck
I'm running is Lilia. I think she's fun.
I have ADHD and so I like doing things.
I like being busy and an aggro deck
suits me because you're always doing
things. You're not just waiting to ramp.
You're just you're playing the game. I
run Lilia because it's it suits me
because I can just swing in things and
they die and that's fine. My last deck I
would always leave two drops on the
battlefield and my boyfriend was like,
you know, that's kind of bad and I was
like, well, what if they just die anyway
and that's good. I don't have a ton of
experience in any other TCGs. This is my
first TCG. For the reasons I specified,
which is just I don't like being bad and
and games that have been around for a
long time. I couldn't stand the idea of
playing the game and everyone's like
that's not how you do it and everyone
knows that you're wrong. Um I think this
is nice that everyone's kind of learning
together. I've gone 311. So three wins,
one loss, one draw. So kind of fine. I
can still make it to day two maybe. I
think I'll be going good. I've been
loving this this Riftbound regional
qualifier. It's been awesome. I've never
been to anything like it before. I think
the closest I could think is like going
to PAX in Melbourne, which is more of
like a convention, and there's there's a
competitive element, but uh the
competition isn't the main thing. The
the the main thing is just hanging out
with people. I quite like that this is
all competitive, and you go see your
friends and you're like, "How are you
doing?" And some of them are happy and
some of them are depressed. It's just it
swings and balances, you know. I will
absolutely be at the next Rebound event
for sure. I'd love to shout out Rengar
Bot. He's a friend of ours and he was on
the exhibition match before playing the
most diabolical Rengar that anyone has
ever seen and I think people should
watch that game if they get the chance.
I'm going to be asking the regional
qualifier Sydney attendees who they
think is a red flag or a green flag. My
legend is Mari Bladesman. Let's see what
they have to say about it. They play
Mari Wu Bladesman. Red flag or green
flag?
>> Green flag.
>> Yeah, green. What are your legends you
play?
>> I play Le Poppy.
>> They play Le. Red flag or green flag?
>> Green flag always. Chill as dudes.
>> What do you play?
>> I play Victor.
>> They play Victor. Is that a red flag or
a green flag?
>> Oh, I'm going to say a red flag. I don't
like those kill spells at all.
>> And what do you play?
>> I would play Masi.
>> Which one?
>> Oo. OG.
>> They play Masa from Proven Grounds. Red
flag or green flag?
>> Red flag.
>> Oo. What do you play?
>> Uh, I play Rex Eye.
>> They play Rex Eye. Red flag or green
flag?
>> Red flag. Definitely red flag.
>> What do you play?
>> Pike.
>> They play pike. Red flag or green flag
>> or green flag post miracle.
>> And what do you play?
>> I play Leblanc.
>> They play Leblanc. Red flag or green
flag?
>> Ooh, yellow flag.
>> I'll accept. I'll accept. And what do
you play?
>> I play. But I'm building Leblanc. But I
hear is a red flag. So they play
Ireelia. Red flag or green flag?
>> Green flag.
>> And what do you play?
>> Ireelia.
>> They play Ireelia. Red flag or green
flag?
>> Oo, Ireelia is a red flag, isn't it?
>> Okay. one guy and walking over and over
to like different battlefields.
>> And what do you play?
>> Uh, I'm playing Lux right now, but
usually I play Ronaldo.
>> But now we know what Sydney thinks about
all the legends in the game, but on the
down low, I think Rex's a red flag.
>> So, I'm here at the Sydney Riftbound
original qualifier. I'm trying to talk
to the dealers and see what has been
selling out to see if we can't have a
bit of a prediction about what people
are playing in the main event. I'm here
with Paul of Best Forge. What's been
selling out?
>> What's been selling out? The Ruination.
Uh, last rights. I reckon we got asked
like 40 times in the last couple hours
last night. So, that one everyone's
looking for that one. And all art runes.
They have been going crazy. You reckon
there's a bunch of purple Aurora players
going around? You think?
>> Could be a lot of purple Aurora players
and looking for a bit of an edge in the
mirror to shuffle their dragons back in.
I get the feeling with that one.
>> All right. Now, I'm here with Solomon
from Good Games. What's been selling
out? You know what? Elder dragons and
Dazzling Auroras are going in pretty
heavy quantities at the moment. So, some
orange decks potentially showing up. Uh,
also all of our runes. All of our runes
constantly. All right. Maybe some Aurora
in the main then
>> potentially. Yeah. Now I'm here with
Jamie of Mana Market. Uh, what have you
been selling out of today?
>> We have only been selling porros. We
can't get enough porros. They come in
the cabinet. They go out the cabinet. I
don't know how that helps you, but I
can't find blue porros.
>> Wondering porro then. Maybe a lot of
mind decks running around.
>> Maybe, maybe, maybe.
>> All right. And who with the heart at
Plenty of Games. What have you guys been
selling out of? Oh, hey. Uh, so we've
been selling a bunch of sacrifices this
week. defies, disciplines, just a bunch
of the commons and uncommons. That's
what we decided to bring up all the
playables. So that uh if people had to
do last minute changes or I think the uh
deck list submission got changed to this
morning. So we noticed a bunch of people
just wanting to make last minute changes
probably after playing yesterday and
deciding what the meta game is or seeing
what the meta game is and wanting to
adjust to that. So yeah, we sold a bunch
of commons and uncommons which was
really really good.
>> That's so funny. How busy did you get
before the the deck list deadline?
>> Yeah, both mornings the first hour was
insane. There's just a bunch of people
and they are chasing one $2 cards. But
it's good. It's good. We were able to
service a bunch of people and they all
seem happy and now the tournament's
running. So yeah.
>> All right. Who are John from Fluke and
Box? We're trying to figure out what
people have been uh maybe playing in the
main event based on what you've all been
selling. What have we been uh doing a
lot of volume of? I don't know what
anyone's playing cuz we had a lot of
last minute very last minute.
We sold every overnumbered porro but I
don't think that's a hint of anything.
Um Elder Dragons. Elder dragons. We had
no auroras, but elder dragons were
probably our quickest, highest selling.
So,
hello Rift Bonders. Are you wondering
how the game developed with Unleashed?
Let me give you a little introduction.
The calm domain has reinvented its
defensive capabilities. With powerful
pump spells and counter spells, calm
decks were already good at contesting
their battlefields. But with unleashed,
holding the fields becomes a whole lot
stronger. A standout example for this is
back off. Three energy, no power. This
card on action speed stuns a unit and
draws a card if played from hand.
Incredible. But leaving three runes open
isn't always an option. Luckily, you can
also hide this card if your runes are
exhausted or you want to keep them open
for another card. Fury, on the other
hand, brings plenty of new ways to
assert pressure onto your opponent.
Every jungler's dream is coming true
with smite, finding a new way to remove
units. It simply deals three damage to a
unit at a battlefield for two energy and
one power. While those stats are not too
impressive, the unit will also be
banished when it would die. This takes
powerful death nail effects out of the
equation and can also remove follow-up
if your opponent relies on resources
from their trash like Fiora worthy that
can't be played through spectral matron
anymore. Order has been known for its
hard removal and kill spells. Now, what
if I told you that you can remove your
opponent's hand as well? Ash Pocus gives
you full information about your
opponent's hand and lets you banish a
card of choice for five energy and one
power. They will get it back as soon as
they hold a battlefield. But with full
information in one card less in the
opponent's hand, it's now on you to not
let that happen. Chaos has been
chaotically bouncing cards left and
right, pushing them front and center,
and now you will also be able to reach
the opponent's units in base. Starcross
reaction speed removal is revolutionary,
especially when it hits the base as
well. For three energy and one power,
you can return a friendly and an
opposing unit back to the owner's hand.
While this can give you an incredible
advantage with play effects, it also
disturbs your opponent. It slows them
down massively and can sometimes deny
powerful effects like Elder Drankren's
passive kill ability. While this domain
has already been good at controlling the
opponent's units, the mind is now
finally greater than the sword. The mind
domain receives a fantastic gear removal
card. Turn to dust will turn any gear
into a temporary problem for two energy
and no power cost. While it does not
immediately help you remove units that
are boosted by equipment gear, you can
easily take care of seals, dazzling
aurora, or other great gear that stands
in your way. Now, what's scarier than
body units that are standing on your
opponent's side of the field just
waiting to overwhelm you with their
physical prowess, the ones you didn't
see coming.
>> Renga Trophy Hunter has to be on your
opponent's mind at all times. Every time
your opponent feels secure about the
board states, the Apex Predator could be
played on a battlefield where they have
units for five energy and one power.
Either as an ambush or reaction speed to
support your other attacking or
defending units, or as a lonely attacker
straight from hand with its powerful six
might. What cards do you think are going
to see the most play? And which domain
do you like the most after unleashed?
Show us at your next tournament. Welcome
to Riftbound Basics featuring actions
and reactions. There are three different
types of spells in Riftbounds. Normal
spells, which you can use to start a
chain during your own turn from a
neutral game state. Actions, which can
be used in exactly the same way, but can
also be used in combat to start a chain,
and reactions, which have all the
advantages of the other two, but can
also be used to react to triggered
abilities or spells. Reactions are super
fast and can lead to lots of exciting
interactions as they resolve before all
other spells. For example, if you have a
stupify in your hand and your opponent
activates a spell that really bothers
you, you can use stupify as a reaction
and draw a card before your opponent's
spell is resolved. This might allow you
to draw another reaction that saves you
from their situation, like a defy.
Another exciting example is dealing
damage to a unit with a spell before
combat. If you go into combat with a
unit that's already damaged, you should
make sure you win the fight. Otherwise,
the units will heal after the combat.
Let's say you have dealt six damage to
your opponent's mind splitter with
Falling Star, and you go into combat
against it with your watchful sentry.
Your opponent might want to activate an
action in response, such as Grim
Resolve, to generate extra might and win
the combat. You can still respond to
that with a stupify. You reduced the
mind spplitter's mic to six. And because
it still has six damage counters on it,
it will die before the grim resolve can
save it. Which one is your favorite
reaction card in Rift Bomb? Let us know.
>> We are down here at the Sydney AQ. I am
joined by the incomparable Dave Guskin.
How has it been being in Sydney so far?
>> Uh, good. I arrived yesterday morning.
Uh, it was very long flights and then I
had to work all day, but it's been
really great. All the people are really
friendly. Um, got to go out to a game
store last night. It was really fun.
>> Awesome. And how is the reception been
like in Sydney? Obviously, this is a
huge event. So many people here.
>> Yeah, I heard there's maybe 1,600ish
people in the main event. Very exciting.
Um, yeah, everyone seems really excited.
A lot of high energy around Riftbound,
around Unleash. So, really cool to see.
Yeah.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And are you going to
do a little bit of exploring around
Sydney while you are here?
>> I don't know if I have time this trip.
It's kind of a quick turnaround. and I'm
here at the event for most of the time,
but um I want to come back. So hopefully
we'll do more events in the future here
and I'll be able to come back. So yeah.
>> And obviously we are so close to just
having Unleash release. How has that
changed the game for you guys at the
moment?
>> Yeah. So Unleash has been really really
good reception. I think um set over set
there's like more players, there's more
people buying product. It's really
great. Um I think Unleash is a little
bit of a shakeup. You know, there's a
lot of new mechanics. Um we'll see if it
kind of like disrupts the metag game in
significant ways. Um, obviously a lot of
power to the Aurora decks. Um, some
interesting kind of new builds with XP,
so we'll see. Yeah, it's kind of
exciting to see.
>> So, with the main event coming tomorrow,
do you have a gut instinct on what we're
likely to see a lot of given the
release?
>> Um, I would guess the most prevalent
deck is our Dazzling Aurora decks. Um,
you know, Elder Dragons really, really
strong. Um, I think that there's a lot
of interesting kind of like purple X
builds. Um, I think a lot of interesting
Leblanc builds. So, I probably expect
those to be uh lots of people playing
them. What what will win, I don't know.
Um but that's kind of what I think the
field's going to look like.
>> Awesome. Well, at this point, it is
still anyone's game. We'll see how it
goes, but thank you so much, and we'll
uh we'll see what happens.
>> Sydney, the moment is here. We
officially have our top eight here at
the regional qualifier. Sydney, I'm Rice
joined by the wonderful Logan. We are so
excited to start breaking down the top
eight.
>> That's so right, Ricey. We are in the
quarterfinals. We've made that top cut
of eight here at the Ripbound Regional
Qualifier Sydney 2026. And oh boy, have
we got some good games in store.
>> I have seen our bracket. I have seen
those top eight. And let me tell you,
Chad, we have a show for you guys. Yeah,
look, uh, it's also a show, but we have
a great show here. It's, uh, part of
what we're presenting to you, the
amazing community, the crowd that loves
a little bit of ripound. And boy, do we
have a diverse top eight. I love how
many legends we are seeing. There's only
one or two repeaters.
Oh, we get a peek here. Icy, take us
through it. We have Stiver with sold out
in that first seed spot with an EQ also
on that Diana.
>> Yeah, absolutely. That's going to be a
heck of a match up. That Civiver Aurora
into Diana there. That was my prediction
as well as Jeff's. But next we have
Ghost Driver on that Aurelia Blade
Dancer into Eat Bonk Repeat. What a
hecking good name on that Vex Gloomist.
>> Love that name. Eat bunk repeat is
actually from New Zealand. So that's a
really exciting little piece of
information. Our brothers across the
ocean. And next we have EDJ Rico and
Ashen Oce Ireelia and a Teemo.
>> Yeah, Teemo represent Ashen O. One of
the Aussies here. Much beloved with the
Riftbound community. Has a lot of the
locals barracking for Ashen O to get up
here. But that will be a banger of a
match in a rally versus team and not
something you see all too often. And in
that fourth slot down the bottom there,
we have nice boy on Diana. So a second
Diana in this bracket against CTG Ziden
on Leblanc Deceiver.
>> Yeah, there is that one Leblanc here in
that top eight. So I'm sure pastry time
is quite happy about his prediction.
Unfortunately for me, we don't see that
Annie prediction um my Annie prediction
coming true, but that's okay because I
am very excited as you mentioned about
this variety. We got seven, Diana,
Ireelia, Vex, Teemo, and Leblanc. That's
six different legends here in the top
eight.
>> Six unique in the top eight tells me we
have such a healthy meta here in this
unleashed regional qualifier. We've got
some OGs, we've got some Spirit Forge,
and we've got some Unleashed. And I mean
we are looking at a fantastic
finals run here as we take a quick look
at the most played decks
>> day two metag game. So these are the
players that made it to day two. Of
course Master was not the most played in
day one but here's the most played in
day two. A massive conversion rate total
of 24 in day two. But key note, no mazes
made top cut.
>> Not only that and a great call, no Ye,
no Poppies, no Fioras made it into that
top eight. But we do see that Aurelia,
that Leblanc, that Diana, Vex, and Civer
as we covered off here. But the surprise
is the Teemo. Not even in the top eight
most played decks, but in the top eight
in the finals.
>> I have a lot of I have a feeling that a
lot of Teemo players are going to be
looking at Ashen O's deck list. How on
earth did this team with uh not much
representation make it to this top
eight? What is his tech? What is his
secrets? And when we watched it, when we
were having a look at Ashen OC's on
broadcast before, it was so full of
surprises and I think surprises for the
enemy opponent as well.
>> Yeah, absolutely. That Teemo deck loves
playing those hidden cards and got some
support here in Unleashed enough for
Ashen O to look at that and go, you know
what, that one's for me. making the top
eight here, which is just something
special. Each one of these players will
remember that they've made that top cut
of eight here at the original qualifiers
in Sydney Icy. And I cannot wait to get
into these games. I think I'm personally
excited to see that Aurora matchup
because my wife is on Civ Aurora, so I
kind of have a good idea how that one
plays out. And it's into Diana, which is
the one I predicted. So, it's like, no,
my two loves. They're going to fight it
out here. Yeah, it's great to see um you
know, everybody worried about Aurora or
thinking Aurora is super strong. So,
both sides of the the the boat the the
argument here have a chance to win it
out. Is this Aurora going to win it out
here? Or is Aurora not that broken? Is
it actually beatable? Yeah, I definitely
think Aurora is very, very beatable.
Every single domain has multiple
effective answers into that Aurora, but
Sold Out has the answers. sold out. Made
it as our first seed 12 and one to
secure their top eight position here,
Icy. So, there's some tech that we need
to see because all Aurora players are
going to be eyes on sold out deck list
when we do finally get that reveal.
>> I think it's so great to see. Also, we
have confirmed that the some of these
players, I mean, the Aurelia and Diana,
obviously, we don't know just yet, but
the other players, these are the best of
their legend. But of course, Teemo Ashen
is going to be the best of Teemo. Um,
Civer sold out is going to be the best
of CBO as well. And I need that list
again because who is the third Leblanc?
>> Leblanc is there as well. CTCG Ziden has
locked that one away. But there is still
competition for that Diana. Still
competition there for that Aurelia as
well in that sort of top eight bracket.
So, if if Allan's able to get up on that
Diana over nice boy, he might be able to
take that best off of. But nice boy is
still very much in contention for that
one, too.
>> Yeah, it's going to be exciting to see
who is going to be getting that best off
between Diana and I because not only of
course these players are fighting for
that championship spot or champion of
the entire event. They also still are
fighting out for those bests. So much
excitement and so much expertise and
talent in these top eight. Yeah, and
that's right. So much talent here in
this regional qualifier in Sydney. Some
international and some local, which I'm
so excited about. Obviously, we're
Aussie and you know, we're not supposed
to be biased, but I'm kind of so I'm
proud here.
>> I mean, also you saying Aussie, but I
would like to claim as well our New
Zealander E Bon repeat. I think he is
also local. I mean Perth to Sydney to um
to Oakland is kind of similar distances
anyway.
>> Same thing.
>> I love the play on words, right? Eat,
bonk, repeat. The sleep, eat, repeat.
It's like and then you could put it to
that rave music. It's like d but a
fantastic name nonetheless. And as you
say, claiming our good friends from New
Zealand and we also have someone from
Perth here too. You do love to build up
that story with these players in these
top eight, but so many of them have
struggled against adversity here. No
player undefeated in this top cut of
eight.
>> That is a good point. So, everyone has
at least lost one match. And I really
think that's amazing. It shows also the
variety of play style, the variety of
how skilled everybody is. And I think it
also speaks to how balanced I think
Riftbound is. It's kind of not maybe not
like a rock, paper, scissors situation.
Yeah. So, of course, obviously these
players, they have fantastic scores, 12
and ones, 11s and twos or, you know,
that kind of thing. They've dropped a
game here and there, which tells me that
no one legend is unbeatable. Exactly.
>> At this point of the game, it's down to
pilot diff, right? It's that nuanced
skill of knowing when to cast something.
sometimes even more importantly knowing
when not to cast something to dramp or
lose that tempo in the face of one of
the best eight players here in Sydney
right now.
>> Yeah, eight players now in this top cut.
Every single one of them are here for a
reason and I am so excited to see all
these six different types of legends as
well. How are they going to play these
amazing decks? Because these are the
masters of their craft.
>> Yeah, absolutely. masters of their craft
and they've deserved it. They've earned
it. They've pushed it right to the limit
here as we are waiting for these players
to take to the stage before we can get
you some of this quality gameplay. But
speaking of quality, look how many
judges there are out on that main event
floor. We have so many judges to make
sure that these games go smoothly. We
have behind the scene judges who are
checking, re-checking, and triple
checking every one of these calls. So, a
big shout out to all of the judges here
who have helped make this run so
smoothly, as well as all of the support
and event staff that have helped us get
to this position and have so many happy
faces out in the crowds. Rice,
>> not sure what we're clapping for, but I
it looks like everyone out there is
super excited because I'm excited, too.
The top eight is going to be starting
very shortly. We're going to be having
these quarterfinals.
>> Yeah. And one thing I do love about this
top eight, right, obviously set one was
dominated by Kaiser. Fury was insanely
strong in set one, but Fury is notably
absent here in this top cut of eight
before we, you know, get into it.
There's about seven with Chaos in there.
Strong representation. We have a decent
amount of calm and mind and a sneaky
order and a sneaky body as well. So, a
nice rounding of most of those domains,
but unfortunately, Fury missing from
this one.
We have a show match. While we are
preparing the top eight for you, let's
have a look at the return of Barrett and
Pastry Time.
>> The rematch of the century here, I see.
Barrett did take that first best of one
between these production level
champions. Pastry time looking for
redemption here with that Poppy baited
hook build. He is a baited hook believer
and CTCG Ziden is proving him right.
>> Wondering if he's going to be playing
Poppy once more. I think I saw calm and
order there. So definitely want to see
what pastry time is going to be playing
and what of course Barrett is going to
play. We saw Jin last time um in the
hands of Barrett and he did take that
game in a pretty convincing fashion.
>> Yeah, he did stomp pastry if I'm going
to be honest there. This is, as you
called, a body and an order matchup
rather than the gin fury mind as we get
the respectful GG's. You love to see it.
And uh we're having a little bit of a
listen in here. We're actually getting
some players as they kick this game off.
>> We love player coms. Of course, they're
being very respectful amongst each
other.
>> They are going to be starting to play
out
>> resist folk, huh?
>> Fay folk once more. And it's going to be
set in the hands of Barrett this time.
And is that
Yeah, that overnumbered Leona is
spectacular. One of the most gorgeous
origins overnumbered in my opinion. A
really good sort of contrast of her
colors with that darker background. We
see that alt art Leona champion unit
there too. We see that Triarian war camp
battlefield and that monastery of Herana
which is such a classic for set.
>> It really is. I mean, are you really
going to be playing set without that
monastery because it's such a vital part
of their play style? In goes that
irresistible fa folk,
>> but not going to be tempting anyone up
just yet.
>> Yeah, obviously Patry Time was ready for
that maneuver and Barrett there decided
to decline that irresistible fay folk
temptation. But one of your favorites
cards has just been played. Saraka.
>> Wait, really?
>> Yes. Sarraka has entered the battlefield
with irresistible fa. Oh my goodness, I
love Saraka. It's very sad to see that
Soraka isn't really played in most meta,
but it is in the overnumbered Saraka,
but it is a beautiful card still.
Saraka, we don't see her very often, so
we might have to refresh everyone. What
does she actually do?
>> Yeah, so Saraka Wanderer is a four might
champion unit that I must be assigned
combat damage last, which as you said,
back line. If another unit you control
here would die if it has less might than
me instead heal it, exhaust it, and
recall it.
>> So that means that Saraka here will be
backline. We'll be taking damage last,
but also we'll be able to keep that
irresistible fa folk alive. We'll be
able to return it back to base kind of
like a
>> Yeah. But one thing that has hit the
board on pastry time side is that seal
of unity.
>> We do love a good seal. Obviously, it
costs one recycled rune, one power to be
able to get that out onto your side of
the board. But, uh, we're ready for a
listen in here, Icy. Let's, uh, go to
the players,
>> man. Does it just go there, huh?
>> So much stuff on there.
>> Yeah, probably.
>> All right.
>> I'll pass.
>> Oh, set. Hold to two. Boom. Boom. All
right. Nami trigger for later, maybe. Oh
my goodness. Whoa, you got this.
>> Yeah, good thing to
backline.
>> Yeah, backline and has le has less power
or might than this or the same, I guess.
>> Oh, it's if another unit you control.
>> Yeah.
>> Hey,
>> control here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay.
Next thing I get gets huge.
Don't know if that matters.
I'll get your buff ready.
>> Thank you. I
>> think I might get two ready for you.
>> Yeah, I may have to.
>> A billion of these are buffs.
>> Yeah, maybe. Where we go? Okie dokie.
Oh, the chokei. I don't really want to
trade though.
Why? Noo-Noo. Why?
Why is it so big?
>> Yeah, but Oh, that's true. It's even
worse, actually.
>> 56. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Five,
six, seven. All righty.
>> Unsung hero. Oh, no. Unzero. Wrong one.
Honest broker.
>> It gets a buff.
>> It gets a buff. All right. I'm in.
>> Uh, you're in.
>> Huh?
>> One, two, three, four. To my five.
>> Now, this one.
>> All right. I'll rock it.
>> Sure. I'll get a gold.
>> You will get a gold.
>> Trust. It's worth it. It's worth it.
It's worth it.
>> I believe you. I believe you.
>> It's worth it. Hiya. done. Set
>> set is
>> buff my Leona
>> stunned.
>> All right.
>> Um
>> my 605. That's my rune deck.
>> Uh yeah,
I'll still bounce you back. BUT
>> YOU BACKLINE. SO YOU HAVE TO assign your
six here.
>> That's the worst. Yeah, I do. All right.
>> And then I will just set
>> Oh. Oh, it's Oh, right. It was Okay,
that's fine. Actually, that works
>> cuz it had a buff.
>> That works. That works. That works. That
works. That works.
We're good. We're good. He's still
stunned.
>> Still stunned.
>> This got used. Uh, we're actually so
back.
>> You're right.
>> Ooh.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Goodbye.
Dragon one time. Kill the set forever.
No.
No. Oh, wait. We're so Why am I good at
this game? Sorry, Chief.
>> He is stunned. When you if the unit is
uh when you when this when you play me,
choose an enemy unit. If it is stunned,
kill it. Otherwise, stun it.
>> It was stunned. Uh
do I? No, I'll call. It's fine. Go
ahead. I'm not afraid. I should be, but
I'm not.
>> I'm holding to three.
>> Yeah. My sick my sweet auto runes.
Bless the seal.
>> You have a solari.
>> Oh, I forgot how many cool new cards are
in this deck. I haven't actually haven't
played it since I updated it for
Unleash.
>> I mean, it's kind of fun because like
the deck is doing what I designed it to
do. Um, okay. So,
you have a four over there.
>> Three. This is a four. Four and a three.
Oh, yeah. Pay, I guess. Yeah, this is a
four.
>> I guess it doesn't matter retreating
because of the stupid.
>> Yeah. So, I'm going to play the pit
rookie here and I'm going to give the
buff to Saraka.
>> Uhhuh.
And then
I want to I'm going to move my faithfolk
in and I'm going to drag Nami to it.
>> Ah
>> yeah,
>> this is annoying.
>> So you have four.
>> Yeah, you stupid backline unit.
>> Yeah. So you can only
>> That's lost. Oh, so I can kill something
else.
>> You have to kill one. This or this?
>> This.
>> You'll kill this and then I'll Soraka
replace.
Yeah,
>> that's pretty good.
>> It's fun. It's fun.
>> It is fun.
>> Um, and then I think I'm going to pay
two
>> and I'll play a monkey here.
>> Okay.
>> And I'm going to pass.
>> One up. Huh. The old oneup buddy player
could be anything. Could even be a
All righty.
Saraka is uh problematic
as it was.
Why you in my territory, man? Get out of
my stuff.
It keeps happening.
>> Well, now she's a six.
>> I know.
>> So, now she can save like
>> happens. It's not like set where it only
happens once. It happens every time.
>> Anytime something would die there.
>> Oh my goodness.
Monk,
>> what do I literally What do I
>> It's only going well cuz you picked
this. I just don't even care.
>> Oh, yeah. That's true.
>> This one anymore.
>> That's pretty good for me.
>> Yeah. Look, I like my mites. My might
break points matter, right?
>> No, you're right. It does matter.
>> Except right now where it feels kind of
badge. Uh, literally, how do I beat the
Soraka? Guess I need a unit that's big
enough. The fave folk still there.
Oh boy. All right. Well, then we got to
make the play of the century, I guess.
Not how we drew it up, but how it's
going to work. I would like to kill your
favorite.
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
>> I don't I don't think that one works.
>> It doesn't. Good.
All right. I guess I'll go over here cuz
nobody wants to either. Go.
>> No one was Oh, you pass. Yeah. All
right. I'll hold and go to four.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I got like two. That's pretty good.
>> I will eventually win holding this
battlefield.
>> I know. I'm trying to figure it out.
>> Um I think I'll start with a fulk.
>> Yep.
>> That's bad. I literally spent an I
played a dragon to literally kill that
thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, you did. Um,
>> it's alive again. Sagge.
>> And I think the new hot tech is I'm
going to hide a card.
>> Oh no.
>> And we'll just pass back and forth
forever.
>> Oh no.
Ult to four
Mona.
Oh my goodness.
All these units are not the units I'm
looking for.
What do I do?
Can find a I can't even conquer this cuz
I already scored it.
Everything sucks.
this gigantic Saraka
just going to get saved by set.
All right. Well, I think we got to do it
this way. Let's start by cracking this
thing. Yeah. Look for a five.
>> Okay, let's five we expected to hit.
>> Nice.
>> Seems fine.
Then we got to just say,
"Wow."
Uh,
>> actually, you know what? I'm never using
this one anymore. That's fine.
>> Go ahead.
>> Play them all.
>> Play all my units. Not doing anything
else, I don't think.
I'll hold the five.
>> Yep.
>> I'll draw.
>> Set Saraka. Huh.
>> Yeah.
>> It's pretty sweet.
>> Yeah. I think I just think it's more
fun, you know.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
>> I I see the vision.
>> Yeah,
>> I see the vision.
>> I'm out. I
>> got to deal with that drag.
>> Nope.
>> It will eventually become something I
don't want to deal with.
>> Nope. Just leave it there. It's chill.
>> It's definitely not.
>> You're tapped out.
>> Oh, yeah. I got I'm I'm out. Out. I got
no runes and no cards.
>> Sure. Let's
folk and I'll bring in the dragon. All
right, over I go.
>> And then
>> I'm ready. Let's go
>> with my priority. It's your favorite
card.
>> Oh,
>> uh, VI. And because I am the attacker.
>> Oh, that's crazy.
>> I will stun it.
>> All right. Stunned.
>> It's six to six.
>> Yep. That's bad.
>> And then I'll go to six points.
>> Well, well, well.
>> And with my three up,
>> Facebook's messed up.
>> I will pass.
Now I have this stuff and Saraka to deal
with.
I was spending so much energy on dealing
with the one problem. Now I have two
problems.
>> I think this is a pretty easy one. I
guess
>> that was an Yeah. What do I do with
this?
>> The backline is crazy.
>> All right. Oh, that doesn't even work.
Interesting.
Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Maybe
maybe we are cooking and cooking.
Kind of need That sucks. Okay. I think I
just need this unit to
This unit's not going to do anything
other than
Yeah. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. All
right. Math. 2 three four.
That's six. If I stun the Saraka, these
are all the same size. Could bring one
more. That would seem fine. All right.
Probably leave this at home then. I
think that means
I really wish I could go over here.
Maybe I can. Okay, I think I should
probably do it in that order then.
That's fine. All right, we'll start
here.
Dragon your
think.
How are you going to stun me? Can glass
get me?
N.
>> Yeah, glass. Popping glass getting
numbummy is the is the line. Um,
I think the response I'm going to make
is
just to sacrifice it
>> to get the benefit, right? So,
>> yep.
>> Kill this sense.
>> Channel this way, too.
>> Yep. I'm going to walk in here.
>> Yeah. Um,
tier five.
>> Yeah.
>> And then hook it. So, if I kill this,
it's a big deal.
>> Yeah. It's bad for me.
>> It's a really big deal if I kill this.
>> Although I do get my Nummy back, I
guess, regardless. So,
>> yeah. Yeah. Uh, it's gone.
>> All right. Point to five. No buff to
spend. SGE time. All right. Let's hook
this thing.
>> Goodbye, Glassist. I guess I can
technically play here, so I suppose that
is a thing to consider. Resolve the
hook. Ooh,
spicy.
on this thing. Going to think about
where I want to play that.
I guess
this can
hold on here.
This dice
stun Soraka.
I'll respond
with a rebuke.
>> Ooh.
>> Counter an enemy spell or ability that
chooses it and no other friendly unit.
Yikes.
Big yikes.
>> So, yeah, we're picking that.
>> Yeah. So, this fizzles don't get the
buff from Leona. My unit was not
stunned.
>> 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 12. These are
>> 12.
>> Uh 12 also.
>> Yep.
12. All right. Blow it up, I guess. Uh
yeah.
>> 12.
>> Yes. 12 and 12. Three. Six. Yeah, you're
right. They're all twos. Um, and you
have two in hand. You have no cards.
>> I'm out again. Don't do it to me.
>> Then I'll call the
>> Which means you'll have to kill these
and I'll
>> Oh my god.
Make a go. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. I'll hold
seven.
>> Oh no. Wait. It's fine. We're not dead
yet.
>> You are not dead yet. Uh, I'll drop her
turn. That's crazy.
Set saved this, right?
>> What?
>> Set saved this, right?
>> No, I had backline and I I gave it more.
>> Oh, you played this, right? Oh, you
spent the buff to buff. I got it.
>> So, you gave it plus two.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Good enough.
>> I have a hidden card here.
>> Oh, yeah. True.
>> I just hoped it wasn't good.
>> So,
>> seven up here.
It's all face up.
>> Seven over there.
>> Seven over there. It's the only thing
that matters. already scored camp.
>> Tapped out. You have no cards.
>> Yep. Same old stuff.
>> Sending four in.
>> Passing and showing. You passing?
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
>> I'll kill this guy.
>> All right. Goodbye.
>> And then I will bring Saraka home and I
will show you the sh
>> after this goes away. And there it is.
>> Saraka.
>> Wild.
What? Oh, perfect. Oh, yeah. That's
good. I ch my draw to center double
show. Oh,
>> what a show that show match showed us
with our showstopper,
Logan. I absolutely loved watching, of
course, Barrett and Pastry Time fight it
out once more. And I mean, it's kind of
a two-0 in favor of Barrett.
>> That's it. Pastry time's got to step up
his game. He has been beaten by Barrett
two different times with two different
decks here. That baited hook tech is
just not working for him.
>> He's so into this baited hook. He showed
us Poppy. Now he's showed us a different
legend. Maybe it's all about that
Leblanc. I mean, I'd love to see that
LeBlanc baited hook more and more
because it it seems like such fun,
exciting tech.
>> I mean, we potentially possibly I was
trying to get the the right P word out
there. We could possibly see that later
on through this top eight bracket
because CTCG Zidan is on that hook.
LeBlanc has made it into that allimp
important top eight at the end of our
championship Sunday here. Icy, I'm so
excited. I'm so keen and just passionate
about this right now.
>> Well, our top cut eight players are
nearly ready to be seated down and start
playing. Of course, they have a few
things to do as they are the top eight
players right now of regional Sydney
regional qualifier Sydney. And it's so
great to see these players take their
moment to take it all in and be prepared
for these semiquarter finals.
>> That's it. That's it. The quarterfinals
as we get a recap of the brackets. You
do love to see this sold out on that
Civer Battle Mistress Aurora against CTG
Allen's Q that previous RQ winner in
that top match up there.
>> Yes, we did have of course TSS sold out
as that number one seed going into that
next match up is going to be between
Gaster Driver Ireelia and Ebon Repeat
Vex. Eon Repeat, one of our
representatives from New Zealand. Love
to see that here in our first ever
Southern Hemisphere regional qualifier.
>> Yeah, that's it. Such an international
matchup as well. Ghoster driver from
Sweden. I was talking to him on the
floor a little bit earlier. He has
traveled far to be here. This is his
second top eight at regional qualifiers
as well. So, he will be absolutely
looking for that win here. He did get
that on Victor previously. So, quite the
switch up to go to Aurelia. But EDG Rico
1997 into Ash and O on that Teemo and
Aurelia duo. Both with that chaos
domain, but a small difference. Calm
versus mind. Got to shout out Ash and OC
as well being our only Australian player
in this top eight. All the hopes and
dreams of us Australian fans are riding
on Ashen OC's shoulders. But not just us
Australians. All the Teemo fans out
there too. I don't know how many people
predicted that Teemo's going to make top
eight. I don't think even Asher
predicted he was going to make top
eight. So great to see this team here.
>> I actually did have a chat with Ash on
the way back to the hotel on Saturday
night and he was saying he was just
stoked to already have such fantastic
results. He's like, "Oh, but I don't
think I'll get there." And I said, "Make
believe." And here he is. It was
definitely the caster buff that got him
here
>> of course,
>> but I would say it's all the pilot
skill. But we take a look at that last
match up there. It is nice boy on that
Diana into CTG Ziden's Leblanc Deceiver.
We love to see that love long. We were
just talking about of course his tech uh
mechanics that he is bringing into this
top eight. He is learning that baited
hook that I mean we know Patri time
absolutely loves but I think DZen also
loves that baited hook especially on
that Leblanc. And you know what else you
and I both Logan like about these top
eight? The variety. Six different
legends.
>> Oh please. I could wax lyrical about
this all day. Six different legends,
Ricey, from each set so far. Teemo from
Origins, Aurelia from Spirit Forge,
Leblanc, and others from Unleashed. It's
such a diverse range of legends. It's
such a spectacular representation, and
it just goes to show that every single
legend can compete with the best. I
think another thing you pointed out
earlier and I'd like to bring it up
again because I think it's a fantastic
point is there are no fury domains in
that top eight but of course chaos is
well and truly represented. Only one of
those decks don't have chaos.
>> That's it. That is that Lebanon
deceiver. She is in that mind order
domain combination and Daniel will be
showing us how it is done. What tech he
has brought. We do know it is that
baited hook. We have seen him switch up
that champion unit before from the
yellow to the blue, vice versa. So, it's
those sideboard techs that are starting
to really matter here. I see. We did see
earlier as well ad came with three Vex
apathetics. I believe it was Dewali's
Diana and then sideboarded in three Vex
cheerless.
>> Yeah, it was really exciting to see
those cheerless come out because Vex
isn't just one champion unit. She has so
many options as well. And the
sideboarding I thought was a really
surprise to us as well as the opponent
as well. And I think it's also really
interesting the fact that Leblanc isn't
chaos domain. But when you play her, she
seems very chaotic as well with the play
style bringing out all those temporary
tokens, those reflection units.
>> Yeah, that all important reflection unit
there as well. And mirror image being
such a powerful powerful signature
spell. And it does play fantastically
into the elder dragon. and you're able
to copy it and then it's ready and swing
in with basically your own elder able to
clear out that board and remove those
big threats that Aurora will be looking
to put down onto the base.
>> Yes, enough talk about that Blanc. Let's
talk about Aurora because our featured
match is going to be Alan's EQ playing
the Diana versus sold out on the Civer
Aurora.
>> Yeah, that's it. We were talking about
that Aurora. We were talking about the
elder dragons and tech from the mirror
image here. But as you say that Diana
here as well in the hands of Allen's EQ.
Now I feel like this has to be comfort
for him as well. He's very familiar with
that chaos mind combo. We did see him on
that Ezreal winning that regional. We
did actually have an interview with
Allan earlier where he said Diana is at
least the second best deck in format and
he will be out here to show that it is
in fact the best.
>> Yeah, I think we can see that Diana
being two of them in the top eight is
quite a strong contender for being the
best legend here at the regional
qualifier. Sydney, let's look have a
look. Let's have a look at TSS soldout's
deck list. Yeah, I really really love
this deck. My wife plays Aurora, so I'm
kind of familiar with this one. We've
got the triple flurry of blades and
triple Elder Dragon. They'll be looking
to clear the entire board that
effectively becomes a fantastic sweeper
here, that mobilize for that ramp and
card draw. That catalyst of Aons for
that ramp and card draw sabotage to pull
apart your opposition's hand here in
that big scary monster that I called
meta changing the Elder Dragon. Elder
Dragon does feel quite meta changing cuz
when you play Elder, any amount of your
damage is enough to kill enemy units.
And on top of that, when you play the
Elder Dragon, you can choose a unit at
each location, including the base,
including any amount of battlefields on
the the play at the moment, and you may
deal one damage to them.
>> I do want to talk about the other
unleash tech here, though. disposal
order as a one drop though able to draw
one at reaction speed for two energy is
a good call but it has a second mode
where you can choose up to three cards
from your opponent's trash and then
recycle them to the bottom of the deck
so really nice to mess with other
opponent's trash there that Luna boon
discard one draw two at reaction speed
able to filter through draw the cards
you need and triple scriers blooms so
much card draw here from this new
unleash deck
>> I don't know if you mentioned this deck
deck too. I mean, it is such a beloved
card for Chaos. It has existed for so
long, and it feels like it's not quite a
must card, but I mean, it's one of the
most played cards. Stack deck. Three of
them for sold out. But of course, Sold
Out is not the only player playing in
this matchup. We're going to have a look
at Alan's EQ's deckless in a bit, but
that in fact is sold out. Our Civiver
Aurora, our Civer best of
>> That's it. That's it. And we did take a
quick peek at their battlefields.
Aspirin's climb. Such a classic Aurora.
It extends that game by that one
critical point. Here we got the sigil of
the storm. When you conquer here,
recycle one of your runes. So that's
meant to be a deterrent for your
opposition. But here is a peek at Alan's
EQ's Diana list.
>> Well, Diana is of course one of the
strongest. Well, I mean Alan says second
strongest, but we sometimes think like
you and of course Steph think this is
the strongest deck right now in the
meta. We of course see the Vex. Oh,
that's Vex cheerless over there. And
Beex apathetic, three apathetics, two
cheerless. Of course, either Quay, you
have to play Quay with Diana and two
star crush as well. We can see how this
deck is building. Look, I definitely
feel vindicated putting the Vex Sheilus
in my own Diana decks because when I see
multiple pros playing it, surely I'm on
to a good thing here. That Vex
apathetic, as we know, so oppressive,
stunning those units so they can't enter
ready, then they're stunned as well.
effects. Cheerless turns those fights
around in combat, reducing your own
cost, increasing your opponents here.
But we do take a quick look at those
battlefields, Star Tipped Peak, Targon's
Peak, and Abandoned Hall. We we're very
peaky here with these battlefields.
>> Yeah, Star Tipped Peak and Targon's
Peak, but of course, Abandoned Hoe is
quite commonly played in spellheavy
decks like Diana. We can see of course
with the Vex Chilus, those spells will
become cheaper when Chilus is in a con
in a um combat at the at the time. And
of course, we see Eclipse, we see
Starburst, we see abandon. We see so
many spells in this deck as well. Right.
The wind becomes nearly free with only
one energy cost
>> for sure. But also that staple Hay that
five energy, one power that even Nice
Boy in the interview was saying. He was
like, "I just started testing with Hay."
And I was like, "Oh my god, this deck
works." He went as far to say that Hay
is significantly better than Celicorn
Herder here as well. But my favorite
card is that Moonfall, that new
signature spell for Diana, Scorn of the
Moon, able to sort of turn these fights
around, drag the opposition into
combats, into fights they do not want to
have. But interestingly, one thousand
tail watcher that powerful closer not
having a strong presence here.
>> Yeah, just one. Alan ZQ doesn't seem to
want to end this game in the late game,
opting for only one. But if they do get
to the late game, Alan EQ does have that
option. That thousand tired watcher is
in the deck if he needs it. And I'm
wondering whether or not it shows to how
Alan ZQ is going to be playing Diana.
Maybe not going late game, maybe aiming
for that mid game.
>> Yeah, I really do like the star tip pe
pick up here for these battlefields.
When you hold here, you may channel one
rune exhausted, which is exactly the
opposite of that sigil of the storms
that that Aurora player is going to be
wanting to play, which is when you um
hold here, you may you recycle one rune,
right? So, one is a ramp, one is a
counter ramp. So, that could be an
interesting matchup if both of those
battlefields are drawn. as we get some
quick cuts back and forth. The judges
just checking out that these notes are
all legal as we fantastic work there by
the production team to bring us into
this game one of our best of three
matchup for our quarterfinals here. Icy,
>> I just realized they're not their own
notes. They are looking at of course
each other's deck list. That is what we
see is RQ Sydney Civ deck list there. Um
that sold out is playing. I'm trying to
have a little sneak peek, but we already
saw the deck list.
>> Yeah, we saw the deck list. We know the
tech, but both of these players, you
know, typically they'll have some people
out there who are kind of, you know,
you've played them before. We've seen
the deck list before on the broadcast as
well. So, there shouldn't be any sort of
surprises. These pros, they've been
practicing, they've been playing,
they've been scrimming for days, for
weeks at a time. They've certainly come
up with solutions. They certainly know
what to expect at what point breaks here
as well, at what runes you're holding
up. And I frankly love though that we're
getting this particular insight. As you
say, they've swapped those deck lists.
So both of them have a good idea of what
they can expect to play into here. RC,
>> I must also say that these two legends
are not uncommon legends. There are a
lot of Diana's. So I'm sure Soldout is
used to versing Diana's. hitting on this
particular Allen ZQ Diana with this deck
list, but knows how Diana's love to
play. On the other hand, I'm sure Alan
ZQ has definitely played against Civers
before as well and Civer has been around
for a while with now that roar is
getting really strong though it has a
new gameplay.
>> Yeah. So, Civer Spirit Forge legend into
Diana being that unleash legend. So,
Diana is more of that unknown but still
has a lot of that mind chaos play style.
has a lot of that. We saw the tech
earlier there. We've got the ride the
winds. We've got the stack decks, the
tide turners. Critically, there are
three flashes in here.
>> And we were saying before in the
interview with Sold Out, he's expecting
all of this. He's played into all of
this before and at 12-1, he's beaten
pretty much all of it as well.
>> Yeah, only losing one matchup. And looks
like they're nearly happy with the deck
list. They've had a look. They've
understood what is in the opponent's
hands. Well, potentially in their hand.
>> They've definitely had a look at the
deck lists that are being presented
here. And this is so critical. This is
so important, right? Every little thing
here could mean victory or loss. So, it
is important that these players take
their time. Allen's been here before.
Sold out. is looking to repeat his
performance here in the top eight at
minimum in Vancouver, which we did again
cover in that interview. He was like,
"Yep, I'm flying out immediately. I'm
going to try and start scrimming and
practicing there for the RQ in
Vancouver, which is in 2 weeks time."
We're just writing some notes down as
well. Some thoughts here from both of
the players going, what's this deck?
What should be some critical break
points? some critical plays that I need
to worry myself with concern and and
have answers into here. I see.
>> Yeah, this is of course a very pivotal
moment for both of these two players.
They have to understand what's going on
in their deck. How am I going to counter
it, especially when they go into the
next game when they want to sideboard?
It's it's a lot of tech. These are the
top eight players here in regional
qualifier Sydney. So, there's a lot of
thought that comes into it. There's a
lot on the line as well.
>> Yeah. Sold out is our number one seed.
So, he is definitely coming into this as
the favored into this matchup. We do get
the fist bumps. So, that fist bump sort
of unofficially there confirming that
yep, we're happy. We're ready to play.
We do see that abandoned hall and sigil
of the storms here in this game one,
which is a bit of a surprise. Typically,
you would see that aspirants climb for a
game one uh on that aurora
>> sigil of the storm. When you cook it
here, recycle one of your runes. As you
mentioned earlier, it is a d ramping
battlefield. Maybe sold out as trying to
force Allen's EQ onto that battlefield
and force him to use less of his heavy
hitting spells. Less runes means less
options.
>> Yeah, but Rusty, we are on the play.
Sold out has channeled his two runes. He
is ready to go here and uh plays out a
quick stack deck.
>> Stack deck. First one on the board. I
mean, you want to do these types of uh
actions or these spells, of course, to
be able to get your best uh
hand.
>> Yeah. Your options, right? So, this deck
filtering that stack deck provides is so
important. It's so critical. You look at
the three and you put one into your hand
and recycle the rest. So, you can
shuffle the bad cards. You can shuffle
the big units in an Aurora deck down to
the bottom. And as we see that Diana
Lunari played signed by Diana Domingo,
the global influencer manager for
Ripbound. You love to see that sort of
embellishment, that flare because it's
also on that overnumber Diana.
>> It is. That Diana is also out now in
play. When a showdown begins, don't
forget this Diana has predict and of
course able to draw if it is a spell.
So, it's very very strong card for that
card draw as well and is the first unit
to be played by Alan.
>> This is a really good start here from
Sold Out as well. He hit that stack
deck. He's got that scribes bloom out.
It enters exhausted, but he values that
more over a stack deck and then hitting
that mobilize, so he's channeling those
extra runes as well. Sold out is finding
the cards he needs. He is ramping up and
should be playing that Aurora very, very
soon. Allen though,
>> Alan is going in onto Abandoned Hole,
getting himself up to that one point of
I don't think Sonat is going to answer
this, but three might presenting
actually he does. I like the Goss comes
out. Alanq not able to get that point.
>> Yeah, really great gust there from sold
out and that is why it is in these
decks. It is the early tempo. It wants
to keep Allen from scoring points in
this early game to buy more time for
this Aurora deck to come online and to
start playing those oppressive units.
Like we saw in that main deck, there are
three elder dragons and one mine
spplitter in main. However, we didn't
get a peek at the side. There could be
some more splitters. There might even be
that Baron, but we have to wait for that
Aurora to be able to see those options
in front of us.
>> Yeah, that Aurora is still not available
just yet. 1 2 3 4 5 6 seven runes in
sold out hands. Well, Alan ZQ, it's his
turn right now. He wants to of course
conquer. Hasn't got that one point just
yet. Out goes that Vex on to abandon
hole for might. Will Sodal be able to do
anything about it? This is of course vex
apathetic which ifsq is able to stay on
this battlefield. That means every unit
soda comes out with will be stunned on
play.
>> Yeah, right now that vex apathetic will
be safe on that battlefield. Gust only
able to target units of three might or
less as a cheeky overnumbered plundering
porro comes out there.
>> I love those overnumbered um porros.
They're absolutely gorgeous. But we're
not done just yet. also going to be
playing that tie turner which is not
going to be using the play effect just
yet.
>> Yeah, but being on seven runes as well
for sold out here. He's now on Aurora
with that nine. It's whether he has it
in his hand. It's whether he wants to
play it right here. Right now he does
have that sabotage. So he will be able
to remove any answers before Oh, he's
just getting the Aurora.
>> He does in fact have that aurora. Out it
comes. Going to have to use of course
all the runes. going to be able to get
that gold as well. And looking through
the deck, let's see what the first unit
is going to be played
>> with three elders and one mind
spplitter. I have to imagine it's an
elder. He's digging deep here. Ricey,
he's gone through more than half of his.
There it is. Elder dragon.
>> Elder dragon does get used, which means
Vex Apathetic is going to be likely
targeted by that damage. However, Allan
has getting he's getting some
information there on the cards in Sold
Out's deck. Having a quick look because
you have to reveal these cards, right?
So, this is public information and Allan
is allowed to write and take notes.
He'll doubtlessly be counting out how
many of what has kind of been cycled and
gone to the bottom there and has a
better understanding of the top half of
what's left of Sold Out's deck. So, I
really like this play from Allan just
getting as much information as he
possibly can before he has to deal with
this Elder Dragon and the Aurora on
board. It feels like Soda went through
half of his deck though, trying to find
that Elder Dragon. So, I am very curious
to see what is going to be at that top
half of the deck for the next trigger of
Aurora. Unless Allan has something to
answer with this Aurora.
>> Well, we know the two elders and the
mind spitter will be in that top half.
Unless there was some sideboard changes
that he didn't get through sorry they'll
be in that bottom half that is now at
that top half just for that point of
clarity. So that elder dragon is very
imminent here off the next Aurora
trigger and it's up to Allen who is now
on the play has held to two victory
points to find some response and the
star cross does land on the elder.
>> It does land on the elder of course had
to star one of his own units in return
to but that was a tie turner which does
have that onplay effect. Getting to that
two conquer points is going to be worth
it for him as well. And getting rid of
that elder absolutely important.
>> Absolutely worth at 12 and four. And
elder is not something that you want to
be hard casting. And I really like the
choice of star crossing that tide
turner. As you say, it has that play
effect. So being back in the hand means
Allen can play that again at a later
point in the game and potentially turn
one of these combats around here. Icy,
he's just considering his options. There
is that flash. He will be able to save.
has that star crossed and there's an
abandon in hand as well. I really like
the options that Allan has in hand with
all of those runes up as well.
>> Plundering power will go on to Sigil of
the Storm. Now remember when you conquer
when you hold when when you're on Sigil
of the Storm, you have to recycle one of
your runes.
>> Yeah, absolutely. That is a D ramp. But
he has the plundering porro which
generates that gold gear token
exhausted. So, Sigil of the Storm when
you conquer here, recycle one of your
runes.
>> So, so Allan will have to, of course,
recycle one of those runes, but out
comes that Diana on Two S of the Storm
as well. As you mentioned, does have
that gold as well. So, it's not the
worst play for Allen. He has got a lot
of runes to work with now, now that it's
mid of the game.
>> Yeah, can definitely afford to sacrifice
one of those runes. Just recycle that
one away. He does have that gold gear
token as we were talking about exhausted
which will be able to uh prevent that D
ramp if you will. Allen finds himself on
three victory points to sold out zero.
But this is an Aurora game. Aurora has
been here before. It can be seven and
zero and still come back. So Allan knows
he's got it ahead of him. He needs to
stay ahead here. But the turn of play is
back over to sold out right now. Ricey,
>> important thing to know. Alan ZQ is
going to be ending his turn with two
runes up.
>> A lot more than two up, actually.
>> Oh, I'm sorry. I looked the wrong one.
Two exhausted.
>> F five up. Five up.
>> Here comes that sabotage.
>> We saw that in Sold Out's hand before.
So, Alan is going to have to present his
hand to sold out. And Sold out is going
to be able to remove one nonunit card
from it. There is a lot of spells that I
am seeing and I saw of course right the
wind and uh what else do we see?
>> There's also an eclipse. There's an
abandon here as well. Sold out has made
his choice. There's a flash. So we're
just taking the information that we're
allowed to take when the hand is
revealed. These players, they're writing
every single card down on their notepad
as Allen is going to take a look at the
trash of Sold Out, which is also
publicly available information. But
Sabotage is such an allstar card here.
Ricey. It's from Origins and it is such
a powerful piece to pull apart your
opponent's hands that every order deck I
dare say runs sorry body deck runs that
one.
>> Yeah, I ran as well on Master Gear and
uh I loved using it too. Maybe not as
effectively as sold out right here. able
to get so much information of from
Allen's EQ, but it is still sold out
turn right now and we know he has that
one Aurora gear out and not sure yet
what he's going to be doing now for the
rest of the turn.
>> We do see that the Civer is unexhausted.
The Aurora is there. The trigger wet.
There it is. The mindsitter.
>> Mind splitter means Alan Sigi has to
show his hand once more. And he did also
use that mobilize earlier to try and get
some more ramping going on.
Mindsplitter. When you play Mind
Splitter to choose an opponent, they
reveal their hands and choose a card
from it and they discard it. There is no
restriction on this. Mindsplitter can
choose a unit, but will in fact be
choosing I think the flash.
>> That's what happens because I do believe
that Alan when he revealed that
information didn't actually have any
units in there. So that Vex apathetic
Diana Lunarian Plundering Porro
extremely valuable to Allen right now.
He is at five victory points is closing
in on that win. But Aurora is able to
kind of go the distance here. So it's
not over just yet. Allan considering his
options. He knows now that Elder has
been hit. Starcross that Mines Skinner
has splitter has been hit. So that means
there's two elders minimum to go. That
is true. There are two more elders in
that deck that Aurora could bring out.
Alex, you mentioned doesn't have any
many units, but he's going to be using
Stupify to try and get more card draw
and see what he can cook up.
>> Yep, sold out. Let that one go. He just
went, "Yep, not a problem." gets that
card draw and the abandoned hall
attributes out one additional might to
Vex apathetic and he's going to recall
to base here I think and plays out
another vex apathetic vex apathetic we
know what she does if she is at a
battlefield all units will enter stunned
and cannot move that turn doesn't matter
for that mind spplitter matters for a
few other units as well but not this
mind spplitter he's just chilling in
base right now he's not trying to move
he's not trying to do any damage on
play, but it is once again sold out. I'm
sold out's turn. Up goes all the runes.
There's the card draw. Not sure yet what
he's going to do because he hasn't got
any points just yet. Alan's here on
five. Sold out on zero.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Allan's with that five
victory points. Does have those four
runes up here as well. Five tapped with
that gold gear token tapped here, but
does have that sort of board presence
with four there. When the Elder lands,
it can only take one of them out and
presenting multiple options for Vex.
Sold out. It's going to have a tough
choice. And there's another sabotage.
>> Another sabotage. Trying to limit the
plays that Alan's EQ can have. He knows
what was in his hand except for one
previously. Cannot remove that Titan is
going to be removing that ride the wind.
Getting rid of as many spells and as
much as possible.
>> Yeah, Ride the Wind really that Allstar
from those previous games we were
covering there. All right. As Mind
Splitter moves in to abandon hall, a
seven might unit and it has conquered.
So sold out on the board with one
victory point right now.
Runes are being exhausted and recycled.
And out comes Civer Mercenary herself to
be played. Now of course Aurora trigger
is going to happen. As you mentioned
before, there is potentially an elder
dragon. It was right off the top. is
going to be used and out comes the
onplay effect. Going to be targeting I
believe Diana.
>> Yeah, Diana Lunari is the target there
for that elder dragon that lands. I
really like this choice from sold out.
Diana Linari when she goes in, you are
able to predict, right? So you can look
at the top card of your deck and then
you can recycle it to the bottom or you
can reveal it like you once you finish
your predict you then reveal it if it's
a spell you put in the hand. So it
allows that extra element of control and
card draw for Allen.
>> Vex goes into the battlefield abandon
hole and Helen's EQ is going to use the
legend Scorn of the Moon and play
Eclipse.
>> Eclipse a fantastic spell here. Minus
four might a unit as well as predict at
reaction speed here. for Icy
>> that does get rid of the mind spplitter
and though does have to trade that vex
for it but of course there is another
vex and the plundering parro ghast is
going to be used by sold out returning
plundering pearl to hand so
not yet able to get that conquer point
still sitting at five does let that gas
go through and in goes that vex now
>> sold out might have another answer to
this
>> is it another
>> it's
flurry
>> oh flurry of blades and with that combo
from Elder Dragon completely takes Vex
off the board.
>> Ah, but a new Vex has entered the board
on the side of Allen's here. Vex
cheerless.
>> Cheerless, which does different things
to Vex apathetic and plundering pearl
also comes out as well. That was the one
that got returned to hand earlier. But
Vex tierless. Remember, when Vex is in a
combat, friendly spells cost less. One
power, one energy less. So, a minimum of
one energy. And enemy spells cost one
power and one energy more.
>> Yeah, could be quite significant in the
upcoming contests over these
battlefields. That abandoned hall, that
sigil of the storms here, but sold out
is thinking through his turn. He does
have that elder on base. We know he has
that elder in hand as well that was star
crossed a little earlier. So if he
wants, he's currently at full runes. He
could just let rip with this elder and
start to clear out those units in the
base of Allen's.
>> In goes the elder dragon onto abandoned
hoe. Allan has no answer. In goes the
civiver that was taken from the champion
chosen champion section. Gets two
conquers. Alen ZQ not going to be
answering anything just yet. Now on
three points. Yeah, a double conquer
must feel good as he hard casts that
elder dragon ricey. That is 12 energy
and four power.
>> Wait,
the runes.
>> It looks like they happy to go to game
two.
>> There's a scoop.
>> Which way did it go?
I think I think it was the server. I
think uh Alan Zaku said can't go into
this.
>> We'll have to find out.
>> We're waiting for confirmation. I'm I'm
just as surprised as you are here as
that second elder. It did hit the base
and it was able to actually take out one
of Allen's units there. So Allan unable
to kind of keep his board going, keep
putting units down. I have to imagine
that this first game went over to sold
out there presenting two of these elder
dragons and Allan he just knows when the
game is up and conceds this one over I
think Ricey but again we are waiting for
confirmation on how this one turned out
did in fact win knew when the cards were
in the hand of sold out and is happy to
go for game two looking forward to the
next game and bringing this potentially
his way after getting the sideboard.
>> What I think was critical there for Sold
out is those early game plays. He had
those gusts to be able to bounce units
back to hand, slow him down, prevent him
from scoring those early victory points.
Allen did get up to those five, but if
those gusts hadn't have been there,
Allen would have likely been on around
seven victory points, which could have
been far more contestable. You know that
turn where he flurried and the flurry of
blades plus the gust to repel Allen and
force him to send even more units in. I
think that was the backbreaking moment.
Lots of abilities and cards in
particular in the hands of sold out
being able to keep control of the game
even when Alan was on five points and he
was still on zero. But now of course
that sideboard tech is coming in play.
Allen who is going to be bringing in as
much anti- Aurora tech as possible.
>> Definitely wants to have some answers to
the Auroras or at least the big units
that will be coming down here off the
back of that Aurora. We did get to see
that mind spplitter. We did get to see
two of those elder dragons which just do
so much damage when they are played and
it prevents you again from developing
that board state getting any units to be
able to conquer battlefields. And if you
have no units and you can't conquer, you
cannot win this game. I also love the
fact that he was able to use two
sabotages as well, diminishing Alan
Zik's hand so much. That mind spplitter,
the two sabotage. When you have no cards
in hand, you have no cards to play.
>> Yeah, and he absolutely correctly
identified ride the wind as that target
for one of those sabotages. We've seen
it used so effectively before because if
you can ride the wind your unit off of a
location, that elder trigger will miss
that particular unit. So, it is a nice
ability, a spell to save that unit
there. As we do see Allan, he's doing a
full stack shuffle here just to make
sure that the sideboard is fairly
shuffled in. That game one over pretty
quick here. I see.
>> Yeah, if that timer on the bottom left
is correct. It was like a 15-minute
game. Very, very quick. Of course, these
are professional players. They know when
the game is done and you
starting to get away a little bit. Of
course, when you're versing Aurora, you
want to try and win faster and have
things in your deck to deal with the
ramp, to deal with the Aurora.
>> Yeah, it feels like a really hard
matchup when the sold out in on this
Aurora deck plays these ramp spells.
Sometimes it's actually very important
to counter that ramp to slow down that
Aurora coming online, especially if you
see a catalyst of Aons. That is
definitely a very, very valuable counter
target. And we do know that Allen did
have in his main board two of those
abandons. So if he had have hit that
abandon, he might have been able to slow
sold out down, but the gusts from sold
out were I feel like the nails in the
coffin for that game one. I feel like
slowing Allen down that much just gave
him the win as we see the new
battlefields here for game two. Targon's
Peak and Forgotten Monument.
>> Forgotten Monument is going to be sold
out. It's battlefield of choice. Players
can't sto sorry players can't score here
until their third turn. This is of
course very much an Aurora styled or at
least a late game styled battlefield. It
means there's no point for Alan ZQ to
try and conquer that battlefield.
And uh it means Alan ZQ is only going to
be able to get one conquer point or one
hold point until his third turn.
>> That's it. That's it. But on the
opposite side, Targon's Peak when you
conquer here already two runes at the
end of this turn. So Allan has opted for
that one. and he wants to play hard. He
wants to play fast. He wants to play
aggressive as we see that all respectful
GG's fist bump that I love that the
Riftbound community has adopted here.
>> Going to be mulliganing.
>> Of course, Aurora has many cards that
they want to play at first. Going to be
mulliganing on one though. And now
Alan's Q's first turn going to be
playing both runes. And it's going to be
the Plundering Poor coming out first
turn.
>> Nice and consistent here having those
one drops for Alan as well. All that
plundering Porro will be able to sort of
start moving towards that Targon Peak.
Mobilize though played by Sold out. A
great ramp piece.
>> Great ramp. Sold out I'm sure is very
happy that was in his hand because I
mean Annie Aurora deck player will know
you want to ramp as fast as possible.
But Plundering Pro is going to go in as
well onto targets peak. Going to be also
using stacked deck as well to look at
the top three cards in his deck. Zenq
wants to create that deck as fast as
possible. And what this play tells me so
far,
>> yes,
>> as a stack deck trigger is on and he's
having a look at the three and we can
see a flash. I think potentially a tide
turner there.
>> It looks like he may have opted for that
tide turner.
>> Okay,
>> but there is the gust. I was going to
say he's holding the one. He's holding
the cards. I'm expecting that gust to
come out. And again, it's slowing Allen
down. It's reducing the rate at which he
gets these victory points. And it just
buys sold out more time again and again.
Consistently hitting those gusts ricey.
He does run three in his main deck.
>> He does in fact run three gusts and
that's one of them now used as uh well
plenty power is going to be returned to
hand. That deck is going to come out
from sold out as well. Wanting to of
course get as many cards as possible.
the cards that an Aurora deck needs
which as we mentioned before would be
mobilize would be other ones as well.
>> Absolutely. There that forgotten
monument and Targon's peak being the
battlefields but catalyst of aons played
out Ricey
>> and that is another ramp
ramp card as well. Out comes even more
uh runes for this sold out for this
civer and getting close to that Aurora
territory. We do love a good Aurora here
has how many is that? That's seven.
That's eight runes on the side of sold
out as Titer played.
>> Tit Turner was played. And now on Alan's
EQ's turn. He's going in to try and
conquer targets peak once more. Out
comes that gold that Plundering Power
does get of course. And Titan now going
to the other forgotten monument. This
does from memory this should be after
turn three. So that conquer point does
come through.
>> Yeah, absolutely. It was only a turn
three sort of, you know, fence there and
it's the shields are down. Forgotten
Monument can start to be conquered here.
And Allen taking full advantage of that.
Conquers both battlefields getting those
points. And right now, you can tell that
Sold Out doesn't have that gust or at
least holding it deep reserve here. He
could have bounced either of these
because they're both under that three
might threshold. But Allan will finish
up playing that way. Quay comes out and
will be able to ready up his runes. Has
three runes available for this next
fight. If Sonet wants to do anything,
but if he wants to do anything, it is
going to be that Aurora. He has the
runes for it. And he also probably
searched for it with that stack deck too
in hand in play and going to be getting
on gold.
>> Sold out is playing these Auroras
fearlessly. He has played Aurora the
moment he has had enough runes to play
them both times. He's not worried about
Allan having that gear removal or taking
it away. He wants that first allimp
important trigger and he hits the mind
spplitter.
>> Mindsplitter is going to be fantastic
against Alan's EQ because he hasn't seen
his hand just yet. We can now see it as
well.
Four cards in hand now going to be
three.
>> We do see a sprite fountain actually
over on the side. No, it can't be.
Sorry. I was like, is that a sprite
fountain? We do see starrust. Well,
Starross is going to be a really big
card against a Aurora deck and
unfortunately Alicq is going to have to
put that into the trash.
>> That's it. That's it. Having a look
through the cards before he reveals
them. We get a look. There's a last
rights in there. Saw a Luna boon as
well. So, we could be looking to dig
through his trash there with that last
rights. Playing from there, he holds up
to four now.
a bit I would say a bit faster tempo
than previous but we got to be careful
of that mindspplitter because that mind
spplitter is still a unit for sold out
to push onto next turn but Alanq it's
his turn right now let's see how he can
hold how he can defend going into this
next phase yeah definitely with that
mindslitter on the board we do see sold
out presenting seven might that can
swing into either of those battlefields
and conquer unless Allen is able to do
something and he's going to play that
hay Hey,
>> when I move, draw one, then discard one,
then do the following based on the card
discarded. Now, looks like Alan is
thinking about what do you want to
discard here. I am not surprised it was
the spell. So, we can draw again.
Thousand tailed Watcher drawn.
>> Thousand tail is definitely one of the
most powerful mind finishes here. But
tie turner played.
>> That does mean it's another move. So,
now another draw one and discard one and
then do the following. Not sure if he
wants to do that same thing. Another
spell. It's going to be I think he did
call it Sprite Fountain.
>> Yeah, there is a Sprite Fountain in that
hand. Plundering Por to base.
We're tense with anticipation here as we
wait. That thousand tail watcher looming
ominous in the hand of Alan
>> and able to play another Hay. I mean, we
love Diana and Huay. That combination is
very, very strong. still has two runes
up and of course not many cards in hand
but one of them is that thousand tailed
watcher importantly.
>> Yeah, thousand tail watcher and a sprite
fountain. So he's got some aggressive
ability and he's also got some late game
finisher ability. That thousand tail
actually able to knock that elder dragon
down quite significantly into obtainable
territory if you will. It is only 10
might, so that can bring it down to the
seven and a thousand tail can trade with
that. So an option there for Allen once
the Elder lands, he could be holding
that in reserve. Sold out on the play
here, though. He does have 10 runes
available to him. And considering his
options right now, Icy, I have to think
that he's going to be wanting to start
to conquer here. Moving. There it is.
>> You kind of called it there, Logan. In
it goes that my splitter onto Taran's
Peak. Now remember when you conquer on a
target's peak you do get that benefit of
readying runes. So sold out could spend
a lot of runes here including one to
bring out that pack of wonders from
memory. I don't think I can't read it
from here.
>> Yeah, pack of wonders is a fantastic
piece of gear though as well. It enters
and you're able to exhaust it to return
I believe a unit or a gear back to your
hand. We'll have to double check that
one really quickly.
unit or hidden card to its owner's hand.
>> Yeah, which means that he could play
Mindsplitter again. But out comes that
Elder Dragon, which is of course a
ferocious card.
>> Yeah, Elder Dragon has been played off
of that Aurora trigger.
We do see, Yep, there it is. The tide
turner as well being picked up. One of
the ways, one of the tide turners has
been pinged out by that elder dragon
landing. Bang bang. Two units gone. As
simple as that. Here, Icy. The play is
on Allen though.
>> He does have the Thousand Tailed Watcher
in hand. Maybe that's the play. What
does he want to use to try and get this
Mindsplitter off the pointer? But that
elder dragon in base is something you
really need to keep a mind your eye on
because remember when elder is in play
at any point of the game. It will let
any damage that sold out deals deal
lethal damage.
>> Yeah, but I kind of want to see Allan
playing these sprite fountains. I want
to see him start to overwhelm his side
of the board with these units, right?
Because the sprite fountains, they're
gear. And when you play this, you get a
ready three might sprite unit with
temporary. If you flood the board with
too many units and an elder comes down,
it's almost overwhelming. It's a
decision analysis paralysis there. So, I
would be interested to see that one come
down. It's that two energy, one power
gear that is so popular in Lilia.
In goes that way. It looks like he's
also potentially floating those two
runes right now. As Hay goes in, of
course, you get to draw a card. Have to
discard as well. When you go in, of
course, you get those benefits. You
could discard the unit, you could
discard gear, you could discard a spell.
At least here, considering which options
I don't know what he he's choosing.
>> These moments matter so much, Ry.
>> Kha'Zix plus three trying to compete
against that mind spplitter eight to
seven.
So that is enough might to go over the
top of this mindspplitter. But
mindsplitter has that effect from the
elder as well. It literally only needs
to put one point of damage back on that
way and that would be enough to kill
that way.
>> It's all about whether or not sold out
is able to stay alive. That might
splitter is able to stay alive. How much
might can an pump into this way?
>> It doesn't really matter. It's enough to
kill the mind spplitter though, which is
exactly what he wanted to do. He wanted
to clear that mind spplitter off of
Targon's Peak. He wanted to slow sold
outs advance
>> and in goes those sprites you were
talking about to get that conquer onto
targets peak and don't forget you can
also ready after you conquer on target's
peak two runes.
>> Yeah, reading those two runes is very
very important. It means Allan will have
answers.
>> Moras that's another spot found and able
to conquer as well for God monument. And
now Alan is on six points. Only needs
two more to be able to take this game
too. I'm so glad. I was like, he needs
to be playing these sprite bands. And
then there it is as the Diana Lunari
also enters the base on the side of
Allen. And he passes the turn over to
sold out Allen. Six victory points. He's
one possible turn away from winning this
game two here. Icy Sold out on the one
victory point. He has to do a lot of
work. But we saw that flurry of blades
in hand. He may not want to use that
though because these sprites, they only
have temporary. They disappear before
hold occurs.
>> I also noticed he does have another
Elder Dragon in his actual hand as well.
And he's got a lot of runes. If he wants
to bite the cost of it, he can afford it
to do so and bring out that other Elder
Dragon. But this Elder Dragon, he's
quite mighty and he is ready. He's going
to go in and just get rid of that
sprite. Yeah, that 10 might unit easily
clears a three might sprite, but he gets
critically that conquer. So, he goes to
two victory points and will ready those
two runes at the end of his turn and
hard cast another elder dragon. 12 and
four. Well, that will be able to of
course trigger that when you play me
ability get to deal one damage to
everyone at one location, which means
one person, one unit in that base is
going to go into the trash.
>> Yeah, that sprite will get pinged. One
of those base units will also get pinged
down. We're waiting to see the
selection. It is that Diana Lunari.
These elder dragons are coming in and
clearing up Allen's board. He does still
have those two sprite fountains though,
so next turn he will get those sprites
and be able to sort of build that board
presence albeit temporarily. Sold out
though. Still has an Aurora trigger as
well. Of course, triggering the targets
peak first, readying those terrains. Now
Aurora comes out. Let's see what unit is
going to be another mind spplitter. The
cards of Allen's EQ will be revealed. He
only has two. He can't choose either of
those to get rid of. I have to imagine
the response is going to be that
thousand tail watcher. He does not want
to let Allan have any answer into
anything he's presenting. And there it
goes. The thousand tail watcher into the
trash. Allen's up against it. Only flash
in hand right now.
>> He has to top deck something incredible
to try and stay in this game. He does
have some units in base of course, but
against a mind spplitter, sorry, against
an elder dragon in Target's Peak, he's
going to have to have something
incredible.
Yeah, he's almost going to have to get
his own elder dragon to get that sort of
effect there. That point of damage is
considered lethal. Allan, considering
his options,
>> he's got around nine runes up.
Plundering Porro, Tide Turner in the
base, two sprites as well. There is an
open battlefield in Forgotten Monument,
but he still has to have an answer for
this elder sitting on Targon's Peak.
Well, he will be able to conquer, of
course, Forgotten Monument with that
Sprite from that second trigger of
Sprite Fountain. Able to go on to seven,
but how is he going to deal with his
Elder Dragon? How is he going to be able
to conquer
Peak? That's a really good question
there, Ricy. With only flash in hand
that we had that information on and he's
top deck something there that we do not
know of, he just doesn't have enough
might here to be able to move into
Targon's Peak and push that elder off.
And even if he did, that elder still has
10 points of might to be able to
allocate to up to 10 different units of
Allens and kill each and every single
one of them. So, he's either going to
have to find one massive unit, which
potentially was that thousand tail
watcher that's now in the trash or he's
going to have to overwhelm it with a lot
of smaller units here. I see Allen's
he's up against it once again despite
only being one victory point away from
taking this game too. He really wants to
get that game too. Of course, because
right now sold out, he's sitting on one
win already. If Alan ZQ is not able to
close out this game, it does mean that
that's it. It's top eight. Once you're
out, you're out. Yeah, there are no more
second chances here. This is it. It's
all or nothing. It's do or die as that
second sprite did go into that forgotten
monument. The turn of play has gone over
to sold out. The action is on him now.
Ricey, he's in a commanding position.
He's got two elders and the mind
spplitter.
>> In goes that mind splitter into these
three might sprites and uh not much he
can do about it. So sold out. Able to
get that conquer point onto forgotten
monument as well. Bringing him now up to
four.
>> Four is halfway to eight. He's
definitely racing through these victory
points. That catalyst of Veilance
played, he's ramping, but if you can't
actually channel the two, so he gets the
one. He's also able to draw one of that.
So that's a great value play at this
late stage of the game, drawing into
hopefully for him some answers.
Last right comes out and this is a card
that's quite unique. It is very fun to
watch and play as well. Recycle two
cards from your trash.
>> Yes.
>> When it's equipped.
>> Yeah. Equipped. So, you recycle one
Chaos Rune, recycle two cards from your
trash. So, you basically pull them out
of the trash and you put them back on
the bottom of your deck, which gives you
that opportunity to be able to get them
again with this Aurora. It is a common
piece of tech because it works. It's
strong. And then when I conquer a hold,
you may play a unit from your trash. You
do have to pay. It's full cost though.
But I mean Soda does have a lot of range
to do that. Of course, if he is going to
be doing that when he conquers or holds
out comes the Aurora trigger. It's once
again another mind spplitter. We see
what he talk. It was a tie turner and
there was a flash and Alan Zu knows he
has absolutely nothing to play and it is
going to be sold out game.
>> Sold out wins game two in our best of
three quarterfinals match against
Allens. Congratulations. A clean 200
here. Civer Aurora will move up to the
top four at the Riftbound regional
qualifiers in Sydney. Ricey,
>> those Aurora believers, I'm sure, are
very much still believing that Aurora is
very strong, especially in the hands of
SA. We also know that with this, as you
said, so that is going to that top four.
He did drop one game in the uh the
Swiss, but apart from that, he's still
not undefeated, but he's getting he's
one of the best in this um in this
qualifiers.
>> He is cementing himself in that number
one seed position. Rice, you are so so
right. He is 13 and one right now. He
must be riding so high. He has beat the
previous regional qualifier winner
Allens on that Ezreal if you do recall
here. What a tough opponent. And
frankly, that Aurora just if it's left
to be able to come online, those gusts
providing their value, slowing your
victory points down, it almost feels
like that Elder is, dare I say,
unanswerable for some of these uh decks
that we're seeing. And um it sold out,
made that deck look so strong. And
Alan's EQ just didn't have the answers.
We didn't see any gear removal pop up in
his hand. And it just felt like Hansen Q
was just racing against the clock trying
to get as many points as possible. He
got to that six but was not able to get
to that eight.
>> Yeah, even in one game he got to seven.
He was one victory point away from
taking that game two there. But
unfortunately that elder dragon got two
of them onto the base and battlefield. A
couple of mind spplitters to tear
Allen's hand apart and sure he just
didn't have any responses. taking away
that thousand tail watcher I have to
imagine was absolutely critical there.
>> Yeah, those mind spplitters were
absolutely key. We saw two of them in
this second game. In the first game, we
saw two sabotages and one mind
spplitter. And those card removal, those
hand removal is so important and so
detrimental to the enemy.
>> Oh, absolutely. To be able to mess with
your opponent's game plan is so so
important, right? Because obviously you
put together this deck, you build these
lines into it and you build it to be
able to answer what you expect to come
up against and you a lot of chatter was
around Aurora coming into unleashed and
proving its value here, proving its
worth. But I had to believe that Allan
would have built some answers and maybe
he just didn't hit them. Ricey.
>> Yeah. And we are going to hear what
Sodat is going to say about his civet
deck and how he felt about that matchup.
Let's listen to the interview.
Thank you so much team. Now first of all
congratulations on the win. I will have
to admit to you though you've put me in
two minds because on the one hand you
have made my prediction a little less
likely but as an Aurora enjoyer I'm also
really happy to see that this has gone
well. How did you feel going into this
matchup?
>> Uh I think the matchup itself is kind of
you know not any harder than any other
matchup. Obviously, you're playing
against a really a good player, you
know, and I would not I like to joke
around uh about how good I am, but I
wouldn't consider myself a better player
than Allan. Uh my deck uh just sometimes
it just wins, you know, and whether or
not I had anything to do with that, I I
really can't say to be honest.
>> Yeah, look, it is definitely a little
bit more daunting going up against
somebody who is so experienced and who
is taking those painstaking notes about
every single time that you were
flipping. Does that add to the pressure
in the moment? Uh, not really. Uh,
there's part of the reason why I don't
take that many notes about my flips is
because it doesn't really matter. Like,
he's trying to figure out what to what
to play around and what he doesn't have
to play around. Uh, which is completely
fair,
but, uh, it doesn't, you know, you can
only get so much of an idea based on the
few flips, you know, and the decks get
shuffled. And so, no, to answer your
question, no, it doesn't add pressure.
>> That's very fair. You did say earlier on
today that you were very very confident
and how much of that is carrying on
through as you go through in this top
eight.
>> Um well now that I'm first seed and I
get to go first uh at the beginning of
game one I feel very I mean that's still
to true. You know going first is very
very good. Any rip player will tell you
that there is a an advantage to going
first. Uh and that's true for Aurora as
well. I would say that um I feel now
that I've kind of gotten to top four, I
think that I'm probably just going to
win.
>> Okay. So, still very very confident, I
would say. So, you also said before that
you were an unstoppable force against
immovable objects. Now, you do still
have some immovable objects in your way.
How are you feeling about the other
potential matchups that you might have?
>> Uh to be honest with you, I have no idea
what the other uh top eight decks are.
So, whatever it is, you know, I'll play
into it. I'll win and then uh that'll be
that. I mean, quite frankly.
>> Okay. So, have you drilled and prepared
against all of the decks or are you just
kind of going I know my engine. I know
what I want to do.
>> Oh, no. No, no. Any deck that The reason
why it's not a big deal what I play into
is because I've prepared for all of
these matchups, right? Uh I don't think
that you will make it to top cut if you
just like go. Uh you know, that seems
very unlikely to me. Even with a deck as
like high rolly as Aurora, you do need
to like know how to play into matchups.
Uh that's very very important. There's I
cannot stress that enough.
>> Absolutely. And you did also say that
the luck of the draw sometimes works in
your favor. Sometimes it doesn't. So far
it seems like you have had a reasonable
amount of favor go your way with that.
>> I would argue I had I've had an
unreasonable amount of favor. Uh yeah,
I've drawn extremely well every single
game. Uh, I mean, arguably as well as I
need to have to have won, but any Aurora
player that makes Top Cut will say the
same thing because to make Top Cut with
Aurora, you have to have the exact same
experience that I have this tournament,
which is that you just have to draw
well. And then you have to have Aurora
on on turn three, turn four, any later
than that and you're dead. Um, you have
to have your interaction pieces when uh,
right after Aurora comes out. You need
to have your sabotage and your mind
spplitter come out to take their hate
pieces away from them. Uh, and I've been
fortunate enough to have all of those
things in the sequence that I needed
them to happen.
>> Look, when it works, it works. One last
thing that I want to just check in on
you with is we did see that you were
replenishing some energy over the course
of that match. How are your endurance
levels going at the moment?
>> Uh, I feel great. I drank like six
Monsters today. Uh probably drink like
two more by the end of it to be honest.
Uh some people say that I'm developing a
caffeine addiction and I would say that
I am not developing. I have developed.
So yeah, I feel I feel honestly I feel
great. I feel great.
>> Great to hear that you are feeling so
good, so confident. We'll see how this
goes for the rest of the day. Thank you
so much and take it back to our
wonderful team.
>> Thank you so much Steph. It's so
wonderful to hear sold out's perspective
and his inner thoughts. He is so
confident, Logan. He thinks he's going
to win the entire tournament. But of
course, he's not the only one in
contention to winning everything. We
have eight six other players currently
in this top eight and we get to have a
look at another set. Yeah, that's it. We
will be going to another featured
matchup. But if you looked in the
dictionary the word confidence, it would
be a picture of sold out because that
man oozes confidence here, securing
himself a position in that top four.
Meanwhile, we do have another featured
match to get to where we will see them
vying to secure their spot in the top
four as well. Ricey,
>> exactly. We're going to be having a look
at E Bonk Repeat versus Ghost of Driver
and we're going to be starting right
from the beginning. We get to watch the
entire match. I think that's a great
thing that the first feature match did
go quite quickly. I mean, some people
will be sure disappointed about that,
but now we get to watch the entire of
the second feature match.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And we get to see Vex
versus Aurelia. This is Calm and Chaos
versus Calm and Chaos. Both of these
players 1111,
which is why they are matched up against
each other. And it looks like we've seen
Ebonk Repeat draw his four. Meanwhile,
Ghost Driver still doing a little bit of
prep work. But those battlefields,
Targon's Peak, we know it. We love it.
When you conquer here, ready two runes
at the end of your turn. And that's Star
Spring. When you play that first
non-token unit to this battlefield, you
may move a unit here to base. You
control to base.
>> You Yes, exactly. M. You got to clarify
those little bits and those little text
because if you don't, it could be of
course misplayed. Now, Eon Repeat is
from New Zealand. And Ghost Driver is
also from an international place. Nor
>> Sweden.
>> Sweden. I knew you knew. I didn't want
to get it wrong. So, this is a fantastic
match between two of our international
guests. Epographed, we see his deck list
here. We know he's playing, of course,
Vex. And it's great to see Vexes do so
well. One of the new legends in
Unleashed.
>> That's it. Set three. Unleashed.
Introduced Vex, the mid laner from
League of Legends and quickly becoming a
fan favorite. That champion unit Vex
apathetic there too. Very, very high
representation in a lot of these Chaos
decks. But the game has started here. I
see game one of the best of three
matchup in this top eight game.
>> Ghost driver did go first and he's going
to bring that Titan onto Taran's Peak to
be able to get that conquer point. Is
able to of course play some more cards.
Remember targets peak when you conquer
get ready two runes.
>> Yeah, very very valuable. But also
>> that sneaky deck head. What a sneaky
play. Ghost of Driver a three mind sorry
three cost unit but can be played to an
open battlefield meaning ghost driver is
already on two points in their second
turn and gets ready up those two runes
has a three ready runes for this for
whatever it bunk repeat is going to do
to him
>> yeah repeat only having Evelyn but has
decided to move that in towards that
target speak valuing that rune ready
>> I love this coming out with the Kha'Zix
as well going in with quite a mighty
force coming through Kha'Zix has that
ambush tagline. When I attack or defend
as well if the enemy unit is alone, give
him plus two and gain some experience.
So, of course, Kha'Zix who is fighting a
lonely tide turner will get that plus
two.
>> Yep. But over to Ghost to Driver to
respond.
>> Defant Dance is going to be used and is
going to be of course quite useful here.
Defian Dance is going to give a unit
plus two and another unit minus two. Is
going to be that classic. So, he's back
to just being himself.
>> That's it. So 4 + 2 equals 6. And that
tide turner has gone up to four. So E
bonk repeat still has more might on this
Hon's Peak than that Tide Turner has for
Ghostaster Driver.
>> I think though Ghoster Driver is wanting
to potentially trade at least one unit
here. Uh probably the Kha'Zix pretty
happy to get rid of that. And also
Evelyn has backline.
>> Yeah. So Evelyn obviously is able to
drag a unit in I believe when it has
been revealed from hidden here but
valuing that Kha'Zix Evelyn entrancing
has hidden and backline and when you
play me from face down on your turn you
may move an enemy unit at a different
location to my battlefield but she's not
face down anymore so she can't even do
that she can't but there is a face down
hidden card currently on target speak
maybe that's another Evelyn could be
exciting but sneaky deck head is still
on that star spring. So, Ghost of Driver
will be able to hold on to that
battlefield and get themselves to three
victory points. Has of course ready up
the runes ready for his turn to play.
>> Yeah, Ghost of Driver sitting on five
runes right now when compared to Eat
Bonk repeats three. So, he's in a good
position from the count of the runes, if
you will, right now. Both players just
thinking, considering their options.
Eat, bonk, repeat. Taking a look at that
hidden card goes to driver. Three
victory points to eat bonk repeats one.
Just having a quick chat with the judges
right now as we do find ourselves in
this top eight match between the 11 and1
of ghost to driver the 11 and one vex of
e bonk repeat. Every minute, every
decision, every moment matters here. No
misplays, otherwise you could be knocked
out.
>> Exactly. This is the top cuts, the top
eight. It's no longer a Swiss stage. It
is single elimination bracket. Once you
lose, you are eliminated. But if you
win, you head towards that top four.
>> If you win, you move towards all of that
glory. at $6,000
championship prize for first that alt
art exclusive champion Poppy the playmat
the works the invite to the regionals
even more so there is a lot on the line
here for these players you do love to
see it as we're just taking it all in
that sneaky deck hand currently sitting
on that star spring that targon's peak
currently held by Evelyn and trancing
with that hidden card too
Just taking a moment.
>> Take it all in.
This is important.
>> The crowds are gathering. They're
watching from outside as well. And one
of my favorite things actually about
these regional qualifies is they
actually have a viewing platform, too.
Yeah.
>> As some of the best players in the
world, they're here now competing for
that championship. We do see 2 XP here
for the Vex.
And I can't imagine that there's too
much in this Vex list that wants to
benefit from XP. We do have that edge of
night as well, which is equipment, the
swiftness boots. We see some new unleash
tech here with that back off as well as
the your favorite
>> star cross. I mean, you say my favorite,
but I think I want to call it my least
favorite. Like, it was my most meta
pick, but I wouldn't call it my favorite
card. You know what my favorite card is?
It's that Lilia Fayorn from Unleash. She
gets to produce a lot of sprites, but of
course this deck um has that star cross
and of course the Vex apathetic.
>> Yeah, one piece of tech that I really do
like here, she's kind of been on the
resurgence is that Sona harmonious as
well. So Sona loves to hold
battlefields. We do take a quick look.
Sona harmonious while I'm at a
battlefield ready for friendly runes at
the end of your turn. So, if you're able
to get Sona onto a battlefield and hold
it, uh, you'll be able to ready up those
runes and have more responses into
whatever it is your opponent intends to
do here. I see.
>> I also love, as you mentioned earlier,
that both of these uh, legends are both
um, you know, chaos and calm. So, they
will be very intimate with each other's
hands or potential hands at the very
least. You probably have a star roast in
both of these decks. probably have that
Vex Apathetic in both of these decks.
You might even have maybe other ones. We
actually can have a look as well and
figure it out ourselves as well. We have
some information. We'll double check
what it is, too.
>> Yeah, we do love to double check our
information and try and make sure we are
providing the most accurate information
we possibly can. Here, they do both have
that star cross as you correctly
identified there, I see. So, you can
expect some of these units to not stick
to these battlefields. They're both
running one in their main decks here.
>> One thing I'd like to point out is Ghost
of Driver only runs one sneaky deck
hand, but to be able to get that on turn
one, turn two or so and be able to play
that to the open battlefield really set
that tempo for Ghost of Driver.
>> Yeah, it's always nice to hit that early
sneaky deck hand. He was able to play
that out on that turn two there, I
believe. and he has secured three of
those victory points here as we're just
really thinking this one through. I have
to think it was maybe a sequencing or a
trigger that we're talking about. But as
you said, a lot of familiarity here.
They're both in that calm. They're both
in those chaos domains. Karm a lot of
counters. Chaos. No stranger to counters
as well. So, I think a lot of control is
going to be exerted over this game. I
think we'll see some of these defiant
dances countered. We might see a couple
of these star cross counted as well. But
that superstar ride the wind is still
around.
>> Ride the wind is still around and of
course is still quite popular. There are
two ride the winds in that Ireelia deck
of Ghost to Driver. On the other hand,
Ebon repeat, I don't believe he's
running any ride the winds in his main
deck. On the other hand though, Defy is
still a mainstay. Ireelia is running
three in the main deck. Bonk repeat has
two in the main deck, but still one in
that sideboard. That's it. But if you
take a second from these games, if you
have a look at what's happening here, it
all starts at your local Nexus Knights,
which you can find using that UVS events
tool there. Nexus Knights is where the
community begins to build. That's where
you start to hone your craft and
practice your decks against other
players who enjoy Riftbound. And then
Ricey, the next step,
>> the summoner skirmishes. Those are
really important, especially if you're
striving to get into these regional
qualifiers because if you win your
summoner skirmish, you'll be able to get
a buy in round one. And you and I,
Logan, we both know how long day one is.
It's eight rounds in a row and
technically there's no lunch break so
you have to try and win your games fast
so you can have breaks for yourself as
well. But if you have that round one
buy, you get that round one by
>> but it also gives you the time, right?
You can uh mingle with the crowds a
little bit before you go into your round
two matchup. But that's one of my
favorite things. There's a clearly
defined path here within the Riftbound
community. You can play at your home.
You can play with your friends and your
family. you can move to those nexus
knights and then you can step up to
those summoner skirmishes which start to
be in that sort of higher OPL bracket
where the rules really matter. You need
to understand the game that you're
playing and the deck that you are
bringing to bear and then you secure
that buy. You go to those regional
qualifiers which as a reminder the
regional qualifier here in Sydney 2026
is the first in the southern hemisphere
and if you are able to secure top 64 at
your regional qualifier you get the
invite to the regionals before worlds.
I'm very excited to see the game the as
Rift Bounce Fight develops with all
these leagues being developed as well,
these regional qualifiers. We still have
many more to go as well. Oh,
>> so many
>> so many. And of course, we've got more
sets being released. Very excited to see
how everything goes. But here we go. We
are heading now into the game. Back into
the game.
>> Oh, we're back in the game. And Aurelia
Fervent is back in the game. We have
seen her time and time again. Ghoster
Driver has exhausted all runes to get
her straight out onto that void spring.
Taking full advantage of what that sorry
star spring has to offer. Bouncing that
sneaky deck hand back to base.
>> Yeah, that sneaky deck hand is in fact
back in base and saved by the Aurelia.
The queen is in play now on Starring
which is a really good strong
battlefield of course for Ireelas. Yeah,
definitely wanting to move in, conquer,
and bounce the other units because
really Ireelia is, as we've said before
and we'll say a million times more, all
about protecting the queen. That said,
Ghost to Driver did play Aurelia with
the only runes he had up. So, he will
have no response here for what it is E
bonk repeat wants to do against her. If
he does have that answer, he opts for
the Vex apathetic. Vex apathetic gets
played onto targets peak and we know how
vex apathetic works because this unit if
vex is on a battlefield every unit that
goes to driver will play will arrive in
stunned and cannot move full stop very
strong against Ireelia's legend what I
really like here though is e bonk repeat
is really shoring up this targon's peak
he does not want to let ghostaster
driver get onto it that vex apathetic
that evelyn that edge of knight also
equipped to Vex and by flipping that
hidden card lets himself put another
hidden card onto that. So I have to
imagine that we are going to see that
Evelyn revealed from hidden and drag
that Aurelia over to Taran's peak and
force her into a fight she does not want
which is how Ghost Driver lost his only
game earlier.
>> Good point. Don't you definitely want to
take favored combats here. Um especially
as I you want to keep that queen safe
but also build her up. She has been
readied of course on go to driver's turn
and has that plus one because Ireelia
has been readied. Now go to driver
considering his options. Do I go on to
target peak? Are we happy with Starring?
Not sure what's in his hand. He's not
giving us any information.
>> Yeah, we are lacking in the information
department, but he does look like he has
seven ready runes and he is recalling.
Sorry, moving. I can't say recalling cuz
that is also a mechanic. moved Aurelia
back to base but do
>> Dean has Sneaky Dean has gone into
targets peak now contesting it against
Ebunk repeat but it is a very very
mighty battlefield right now and yes
Sneaky Dean is going to have to go into
the trash
>> interesting so Sneaky Dean moved in
three energy to M
>> but because of Evelyn's backline I think
Ghostaster Driver forgot about the
backline mechanic on Evelyn. I must be
assigned combat damage last. So, he had
to put it into the Vex. Nothing
happened. Sneaky deckhand is just sent
to the trash.
>> Now, out comes that ride the wind, which
does of course target Ireelia, giving
her a bit more might. Za has also been
used as well. So, at the very least,
Ireelia will stay alive, but can deal a
lot of damage. Can get through this vex.
I mean, it's quite a mighty vex.
Four, five, six might on that Vex and
two on the Aurelia. Oh, sorry, two on
two on the Evelyn. But of course,
Airelia will have to come back, use that
Zas. And now still Ebon repeat has
control of Tens Peak. It still goes to
driver's turn though that Aurelia is
currently seven might ride the wind
ricey
>> once more and that's going to be a very
mighty Ireelia because once again being
targeted going to be ready now on five
might additionally meaning nine in
total. Evelyn is just two. Out comes the
ex existential dread. Love a good
existential dread that will stun
Aurelia, preventing that combat damage
being applied to those units that EP
bonk repeat has on Targon's Peak,
repelling Aurelia, unfortunately able to
have that impact and knock E bonk repeat
off of Targon's Peak. I really do like
that existential dread. That is a
fantastic stun card.
>> He did he repeat it? No, he didn't
repeat it. Okay. I wasn't sure if uh he
repeated it because if you repeat ex
existential dread, it will stun it twice
which means it will return to hand. He
chose not to repeat it and so Ireelia is
back in base. Still safe but of course
so is that Evelyn.
>> Yeah, but look at that Aurelia currently
with that eight might and Epon repeat
finds himself on two runes only having
to pay that deflect cost to target that
Aurelia. So that was a one energy, two
power existential dread here and ghost
driver just going to send her in to the
star spring here. We will see if Ebon
Repeat has any responses to this.
>> Doesn't look like Ebon Repeat does have
any responses to it. So now going to be
his turn of play. Gets to draw one from
the of course Vex Legend Gloomist
holding. Gets to draw. Has to of course
exhaust the legend for it. and now gets
a draw again for turn. Out comes that
mutated mouser. He is getting quite
defensive here on this target's pig. But
that was another Evelyn Hidden which
does drag the Ireelia over onto Taran's
Peak.
>> As I predicted that Evelyn Hidden
revealed drags the Aurelia in. And there
goes Aurelia. Fervent Ricey. No response
coming out of Ghost to Driver even
though he had that rune up
>> and that Mouser is tank and shield. So a
very chunky little kitty cat on that
point on that battlefield which means
ghost driver is not able to respond and
take anything out but now it's his turn
and he has a lot of runs a lot more than
a bunk repeat which means my thriller
comes out repeat is going to show all
his cards.
>> Yeah we do see an emperor's divide a
discipline a teemo and a what's that?
That's the um
>> switcheroo
>> switcheroo. I was why was I thinking sid
spplitter because we've got the mind
spplitter and aside that switch aroo
which was so very popular in that Draven
from spirit forged.
>> What do you rip out here? Because
obviously mind spplitter is able to take
anything.
>> Yeah.
>> So it could be the tee, it could be that
switcheroo, the pump spell of the
discipline and the card draw advantage
it provides. Emperor's divide though
quite tempting and he goes for the
switcheroo. That kind of makes sense
considering the mindset is out and
currently coaster driver's only unit.
You don't want that switcheroo being
targeting that mind spplitter. And so
now it's going to be Ebon repeat's turn
though. The he's still only on three
victory points right now. Goes to driver
does have more but with no units on the
board except that mind spplitter. Ebon
repeat feels like they somewhat have a
bit of the tempo except for the runes.
>> That's it. Being a big dragon of seven
might interestingly scared of this
little cat that mutated Mousa with that
shield two and tank as you said Ricey.
Sona does come out to play on targets
peak and you were talking about Sona
earlier about how she's coming into play
and the benefits that Sona has.
>> Yeah, Sona brings a lot of benefit when
you are a whole deck which this Vex
absolutely is. While I'm at a
battlefield ready four friendly runes at
the end of your turn there. So, he's
going to have a full hand of runes ready
to I keep saying full hand. He's going
to have all of his runes ready to go
>> to be able to respond to ghost drive.
That is true. It is still only two runes
on the side of eight bonk repeat, but it
doesn't feel like this deck is falling
behind on tempo anyway.
>> Eat bunk repeat has quite a lot of low
uh p low cost spells. You can see some
of them in hand at the moment. I think I
saw discipline flashed by. But Driver is
of course going to go and contest
Starring. Try and get that extra conquer
point on the board.
Not sure if anything else is going to
happen. Looks like that may be happy and
it for go driver has all the runes up.
He wants to hold.
>> Yep, happy to hold here. Channels the
two runes goes to four. But eat bonk
repeat. If we do take a quick look, the
most expensive card that he has in his
deck is four energy. So he's really
happy to be playing low to the ground.
He only needs these four to be able to
play the game. How do you compete
against that though, Rice? Obviously
goes to driver. Even the Aurelia
immediately is five. The mindsplitter is
7 and two. So you can't afford to throw
your runes around as much as Ebon repeat
can. Looking to one of the units on the
board and actually going to be choosing
Evelyn, his own unit, which means of
course if you play Evelyn from hidden,
you can bring that mindset over to
target speak which looks incredibly
scary, incredibly mighty. And there is
that hidden cut. I wonder what that is.
Well, that one was the Teemo and we know
what the other hidden one is. That will
be Evelyn. So, he is bulking up that
battlefield. He is ready to drag any big
unit that Ghostaster presents onto that
battlefield and wipe it out. Currently
only having that mind splitter on that
Starring does go to Driver. But we take
a look at his runes. He has those seven
runes ready. And he bunk he's playing
even more.
>> He plays that pike, but don't forget
that Sonic gets ready those three runes
back up for this next round. So he has
three marines ready for go to driver if
he's going to try and contest targets
peak. I'm I'm trying to count how many
units are on that board. That is I
believe the edge of knight. So that
isn't a unit. So 1 2 3 four units. I
mean Evelyn potentially could be
something else.
>> I mean we all know it's an Evelyn.
>> I think we all know it's an E. I'm going
to call it right now that that is an
Evelyn. But that Pike returned is also
unleashed card here. hidden backline
once each turn. When an enemy unit dies
while I'm at a battlefield, play a gold
gear token exhaust. So, I really love
this play because we know that Evelyn is
going to be flipped. It's going to drag
the mind spplitter or potentially a
second Aelia fervent into that
battlefield here. Icy is ghost driver on
the play.
>> Going to be playing that Stellorn
hoarder and of course using that legend
blade dancer to ready that unit to
potentially go in. I don't know where
this teleon unit holder is going to go
and head is going to go in. It's just
going to go into Starring
instead of of course that really scary
targets peak.
>> Yeah, we also did see that discipline
played by Ghost of Driver as well
targeting that Stellicorn Herd with that
plus two might and that extra card draw.
So really valuing that card draw really
digging to find these answers into this
monstrous battlefield that Ebon repeat
has developed down here on Targon's
Peak. Critically though, by developing
this battlefield, he is denying Targon's
pick from Ghost to Driver. He's unable
to conquer and ready those two runes at
the end of his turn. And it's Ghostaster
Driver's turn to play a hidden card onto
Starring right now. You do love to see
that double hidden tricks. And Ebon
Pete, it's going to start his turn. Six
victory points for Ghost to Driver right
now. He is closer to winning. However,
Ebon Repeat holds to six. It's now six
apiece. Ricey, this is a close game.
>> Able to use gloomers to get that extra
card draw. So, Ebon Repeat has lots of
options. T-Mo is going to be pulled
back. And now we get the reveal. Whoa,
it's an Evelyn. We're so surprised by
this. But I'm curious to see what unit
is going to target to pull to entice to
entrance over to Target's Peak. Yeah, we
do see Ghost Driver has those three
runes up, so he might have some
responses to this. I almost feel like
now is the time to play them if he has
them. However, Eon repeat a lot more
cards in hand and Edge of Knight is
flipped on that Starring equipping to
the Mind Splitter before it is dragged
down to that Targon's peak and forced
into a fight here. Edge of Nine does
make that mice build a little bit
mighty, but is it going to be mighty
enough? It's sitting at nine versus the
14. Oh, it's not the best, but I mean,
go a driver is going to be able to I
lie. I was going to say it's going to be
able to do a lot of damage, but that
existential dread of course exists. It
is a Vex and Vex loves stunning.
>> Yeah, immediately stunning that
mindsplitter obviously it means no
combat damage can be dealt. Bonk repeat.
currently as it stands will win this
one. We're seeing options here from
Ghost of Driver though.
>> Flash being considered. I wasn't sure if
Ghost of Driver wanted to use a defy. He
does have three, but maybe not in hand.
And it's going to be of course that
Flash has to say that Mindsplitter, you
don't want to lose your units. You only
have two right now.
>> And Mindsplitter being the most powerful
mighty unit is actually able to contest
these battlefields. So, it feels like
it's worth it to save it with this flash
even if it is only targeting that one.
But he could actually use the flash to
also target that Celicorn Herder move it
and get that card draw here.
>> I wonder if Ebon Pete was considering
the defy. Unsure if he has it in hand
right now, but decided to let that flash
through. Let that mind spplitter live
and go to driver I'm sure is very happy
to keep that unit alive.
>> Yeah, leaving that Stacorn Herder to
contest that Starring does not want to
give Eat Bonk Repeat an easy conquer on
that northernmost battlefield here.
We do see Eon repeat looking at his
options and again only four runes but is
very capably very competently able to
play this deck again the most expensive
unit only being four energy he's loving
the use of all of these hidden cards
he's forcing Ghost to Driver to have to
play around them
>> Empress Divide will get played and that
card is pretty good at well look at that
taking all of the units away into base.
Move any number of friendly units at a
battlefield to their base, which means
that doesn't exhaust them.
>> Yeah, they are all ready. So, he could
be recalling back to base here to go for
that double conquer play next turn.
Still has two runes up. Ghost to Driver
though on six victory points. Does have
that mind splitter sitting in his base.
>> Yeah, which means go to driver on his
turn will go to that seven hoe and could
go and conquer targets peak. Ebonerfeed
has to try and wants to try and do
something. Going in with lots and lots
of units to try and get rid of this
herder. Evelyn being considered. Mouser
being considered. So is Pike as well.
And of course we have to decide.
Currently looking at potentially 10
might as feet is still thinking and
calculating himself.
>> Yeah, he's got to make this work, right?
He has to consider the options. If ghost
driver does have a defined dance that
could swing this one around. So epunk
repeat is sending in enough might that
if and there's the discipline too ricey.
>> Yeah, I did see that discipline in hand.
Discipline is such a good card
especially in calm to be able to make
your units even more mighty. And I
believe he pointed at that mouser which
is of course a tank as well. He's going
to be taking a lot of the damage.
>> Yeah, has the edge of knight equipped to
him. There is that defiant dance
>> going to be plus two onto that telecon
herder and of course going to be also
targeting one of Ebon repeats. So that
discipline does mostly get canceled out.
>> We do see this combat resolve. It takes
out a couple of units there though.
>> Backline tag on both Pike and Evelyn. So
Ga Driver finally had a choice of who to
target. Going to be taking down Evelyn
and that Mouser. Sona does go in.
Remember when Sona holds does get
benefits. Yeah, Sona, when she's on a
battlefield, you are able to ready up to
four friendly units. And sorry, I say up
to, it's ready four friendly units
straight up, which is critical to what
Eong Repeat is doing. He's playing with
four runes the entire game. He's happy
to be hiding units. He's happy to be
recycling runes to expend them for that
power to hide on these battlefields.
Right now, Epon repeat on seven victory
points holding Starring. Ghost driver on
six. Moves in. moves in onto Starring
with that pretty mighty mind spplitter.
7 + 2 n maths is great. Out comes though
of course the Kha'Zix. It has ambush
which is at reaction speed.
>> Yeah, we do love a good ambush and when
a unit is alone gets that extra two
might and two XP
has a lot of might on that star spring.
It is 13 might into the nine that this
mind spplitter is putting forward. Ghost
driver. All of his runes are up and
available,
>> but doesn't have the answers. I don't
know if he has any of those calm
spells, that pump spells that of course
Ireelia does like, but looks like he
doesn't have anything. Down goes that
mind spplitter and bunk repeat. It's his
turn.
>> I find it difficult for ghost driver to
come back into this one. He doesn't have
any units at the moment. It looks like
that's another Stellacicorn herder
though. He does exhaust those four
runes. He has to develop some kind of
response here Ricey because if he's not
able to prevent Ebon repeat from holding
here, he's going to lose this game one.
>> Of course, going to be using that legend
ability of blade dancer. When you choose
a friendly unit, you may pay you may
exhaust me and pay a power to ready it.
It is a bit costly, but being able to
ready a unit and go straight in into a
fight is very important. So, let's see
what happens now as Ghost Driver is
forced to start the showdown. Ghost
Rider goes in onto that star spring as
you call there.
>> 5 to seven right now, but go driver is
playing. Ireelia does potentially have
those pump spells. We didn't see it with
my spa, but maybe further on.
>> Yeah, with that Stella heard it. There
it is. There's the fist bump. E bonk
repeat takes game one of our best of
three match here in this top eight
series. And my goodness, what an
excellent game it was.
What an amazing game it was indeed. We
do see of course such a wonderful play
coming out from Ebon Repeat.
Fortunately, we can't show game two, but
the final result is going to be a two in
favor of Ebon Repeat the Vex.
>> Yeah, on that Vex the Gloomist, it was
just able to hold and dominate and
prevent Aurelia from ever able to being
building up to that massive might total
we know that she can do. And this is how
we saw Ghostster driver lose the first
game that he lost. He just wasn't able
to pick the fights that Aurelia wanted
to win. He wasn't able to protect that
queen because these Evelyn kept dragging
them in. These pikes kept forcing the
fight like the getting the gold as well
and just presented overwhelming might
the coaster driver was unable to
overcome.
>> Yeah, amazing play coming out from that
veg. And being one of our new unleashed
legends, it's fantastic fantastic to see
Vegs in play. I'm sure my I myself I
want to play bags. So I'm very much
studying how Ebon Pets our New Zealander
friend has been playing bags. Now we of
course have more riftbound to show you
guys. Let's go to a short break and
prepare for you for it.
We are here at the Riftbound regional
qualifiers in Sydney 2026 and I have
attack on cardboard with me here.
Content creator. How do you feel about
the regional so far?
>> It's freaking awesome. I I can't believe
how massive the space is and so many
awesome people are here today.
>> It's going great.
>> Oh, sorry. I also think it's going
great. We've seen so many events and
there's a lot of vendors here. But
what's an event that you're looking
forward to playing this coming weekend?
>> Super excited for the what is it? The
Nexus event tonight. The night super
Nexus night. hopefully meet some riders,
play some play some good games of
Riftbound. Looking forward to that. And
if I can ask you one more question, what
is your favorite legend from Unleashed?
>> Definitely Vex. Vex is awesome. I I
really enjoy the uh the game plan.
Really enjoy the artwork of the
signature which I opened. So yeah, Vex,
very nice. Congratulations on that
signature. It is a beautiful card and
I'm very jealous. That was attack on
cardboard.
I'm here at the Riftbound regional
qualifier Sydney 2026 with Dwali who
actually won the Houston regional
qualifier on Annie which is pretty good.
Yeah. You've been having fun so far this
weekend.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um I think this new set's
like super powerful. Probably the most
powerful that they've printed and
there's a lot of like stuff to explore.
I uh main Jin and then my second
favorite champion in League is Pike. So
it's it's a big set for me. Yeah. Yeah.
So it's fun. also plays League of
Legends, which we love to see. Now,
doubtlessly, you're here for the main
event. That's what you're most excited
for. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Main event for sure. Uh I
decided to come to try to win. Um even
though I was tempted to go for best of
Jin or best of Pike. Uh I think the
first set um sorry, the first regional
of the uh the new set is somewhere where
you can like come with things are
unexpected and do really well and maybe
win the whole thing.
>> Yeah. less known sort of answers into
certain archetypes and builds, stuff
like that. So, yeah, take advantage of
it. Really, really nice. And, um, do you
have a favorite set three legend from
Unleash without hopefully giving away
your champion or legend?
>> I'm playing Diana.
>> I love that.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I'm playing Dana. Uh, my
favorite one, like I said, is Jyn, but
like power-wise, I like Diana. Um, she's
really good. Uh, obviously Allen's also
on Diana, so I'm contesting him, which
isn't all, you know, it's not the
greatest thing ever, but you know what?
Maybe I'll parent to him and we'll fight
for the best of Diana and that'll be
sick.
>> You mean you'll beat him again like you
did at Houston.
>> It's possible. Exactly. Yeah, it's
possible. He's strong. He's a strong
opponent. But yeah,
>> exactly. Thank you so much for your
time, Dwali, and good luck here at the
Ripbound Regional Qualifiers in Sydney
2026.
>> I'm here at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifier Sydney 2026 and I'm joined by
Draghu. How are you, mate?
>> I'm good, bro. Happy to be here.
>> Hell yeah. That's it. So, ex uh pro LOL
player turned hopefully riffbound pro.
>> Um yeah, I think so. Um it's definitely
I think a lot of the skills that I've
learned from League have actually came
back here. Um I think practice has been
going pretty good, but there's a lot of
strong set players here. So, you know,
I'm just trying to do my best actually.
>> That's the one. And have you been having
fun here today on the first day of the
regional qualifiers?
>> Uh yes. I think the burger was actually
really nice at the cafeteria. Um so,
yeah, that was a big highlight. Sounds
good. Burger comes strongly recommended.
Now you're here to play the main event.
Are you willing to reveal what legend
you're playing? Yep. I'm playing set. Um
I'm also a big fan of Colin. So if
you're listening to this interview, hi.
Um please don't play set so I can have a
chance. Um or you can just rate my deck
list. Maybe it's the same thing. But
yeah. Um no, I'm very excited. I want to
play set. Um everyone in Sydney knows me
as the set guy. Probably cuz I'm
probably the only one. But I've been
playing since the start of Origins with
set. So yeah,
>> very nice. Very committed. And yeah,
Colin did win that best of set at
Atlanta in that RQ there. Very
inspirational. And now if I can ask you,
do you have a favorite legend from
Unleashed?
>> Oo,
honestly, my favorite legend. Okay, this
is going to be like kind of funny, but I
actually really like Ivan.
>> That's funny. Yeah. Oh, and Pike,
actually. Pike.
>> Yep.
>> I really like the Pike mechanics, being
able to return those units back to hand
with that legend ability. Well, thank
you very much for your time here today,
Draku. Have a fantastic regional
qualifier and hope to see you on the
feature tables.
>> Hello, Rift Bonders. Are you wondering
how the game developed with Unleashed?
Let me give you a little introduction.
The calm domain has reinvented its
defensive capabilities. With powerful
pump spells and counter spells, calm
decks were already good at contesting
their battlefields. But with unleashed,
holding the fields becomes a whole lot
stronger. A standout example for this is
back off. Three energy, no power. This
card on action speed stuns a unit and
draws a card if played from hand.
Incredible. But leaving three runes open
isn't always an option. Luckily, you can
also hide this card if your runes are
exhausted or you want to keep them open
for another card. Fury, on the other
hand, brings plenty of new ways to
assert pressure onto your opponent.
Every jungler's dream is coming true
with smite. Finding a new way to remove
units. It simply deals three damage to a
unit at a battlefield for two energy and
one power. While those stats are not too
impressive, the unit will also be
banished when it would die. This takes
powerful death nail effects out of the
equation and can also remove follow-up
if your opponent relies on resources
from their trash like Fiora worthy that
can't be played through spectral matron
anymore. Order has been known for its
hard removal and kill spells. Now, what
if I told you that you can remove your
opponent's hand as well? Ash Pocus gives
you full information about your
opponent's hand and lets you banish a
card of choice for five energy and one
power. They will get it back as soon as
they hold a battlefield. But with full
information and one card less in the
opponent's hand, it's now on you to not
let that happen. Chaos has been
chaotically bouncing cards left and
right, pushing them front and center.
And now you will also be able to reach
the opponent's units in base. Starcross
reaction speed removal is revolutionary,
especially when it hits the base as
well. For three energy and one power,
you can return a friendly and an
opposing unit back to the owner's hand.
While this can give you an incredible
advantage with play effects, it also
disturbs your opponent. It slows them
down massively and can sometimes deny
powerful effects like Elder Drank's
passive kill ability. While this domain
has already been good at controlling the
opponent's units, the mind is now
finally greater than the sword. The mind
domain receives a fantastic gear removal
card. Turn to dust will turn any gear
into a temporary problem for two energy
and no power cost. While it does not
immediately help you remove units that
are boosted by equipment gear, you can
easily take care of seals, dazzling
aurora, or other great gear that stands
in your way. Now, what's scarier than
body units that are standing on your
opponent's side of the field, just
waiting to overwhelm you with their
physical prowess? The ones you didn't
see coming.
>> Renga trophy hunter has to be on your
opponent's mind at all times. Every time
your opponent feels secure about the
board states, the Apex Predator could be
played on a battlefield where they have
units for five energy and one power,
either as an ambush or reaction speed to
support your other attacking or
defending units, or as a lonely attacker
straight from hand with its powerful six
might. What cards do you think are going
to see the most play? And which domain
do you like the most after unleashed?
Show us at your next tournament.
Hello and welcome back to coverage of
regional qualifier Sydney. We are in top
four right now. Our semifinals trying to
figure out who's going to make it all
the way to top two.
>> It is a very very interesting few
matches that we have had so far in this
top eight. And my goodness, this one
coming up. I am very intrigued.
>> Yeah, Dexter, we haven't seen too much
of recently, although I guess we have
seen at least one of them on stream. But
I suppose two legends that were quite
popular coming into this weekend
>> very much so. I believe actually we do
have the best ofs for both of these
legends. So we are going to see arguably
what would be described as the best of
the best for these two. So we have ahead
of us we have Diana verselia.
>> Diana verselia kind of uh it's
interesting to me cuz these decks do
feel somewhat similar. Obviously not in
the same domains but do want to do a lot
of things in showdown. do want to try
and uh twist the tides of combat uh kind
of on the chain and uh we know what
Aurelia does. We've seen a lot of
Aurelia in general throughout Spirit
Forge, but Diana kind of a whole new
beast.
>> I do feel like it is going to come down
to tempo a little bit on this one,
especially because Aurelia does take
that little bit longer to develop and
build up that hold.
>> All right, so here we are in terms of
bracket. I can see a bunch of 2's
actually in our quarterfinal. So, kind
of a swift affair in some cases. We'll
be following the bottom side of the
bracket for our first feature match. EDG
Rico at 1997 up against nice boy Aurelia
versus Diana. But on the other side of
the bracket, which we will likely get to
some of, I believe in our top four. It
is sold out obviously through versus
Allen on Aurora Civer versus E Punk
Repeat. The only thing close to a
hometown hero.
>> Close, close, close. Good to see the Vex
make it that far as well for that one,
too.
>> Yeah, definitely cool to see Unleashed
Legends still fighting out. Two
different ones. obviously sporting some
chaos uh which has been kind of a
consistent thing across RQ's uh in
recent memory.
>> Yeah, there's a lot of purple happening
around.
>> Yeah, it's a nice color. My favorite
color, so it makes sense to see a bunch
of it. Kind of glad to see that, I
suppose. But yeah, we'll bring you a
bunch of different We'll bring you at
least some of both of these. I can
certainly guarantee that. Unless I don't
know, something catastrophic would have
to happen for uh that not to happen. But
don't worry about that. Pretend I even
said that. Don't even think that for a
minute I suggested that isn't going to
be the case. But Diana,
>> we Thank you. Aurelia versus Diana are
very curious matchup and I think one
we're going to learn a lot about in the
three games we get between these two.
I'm going to say it now. I think we're
going to get three games.
>> Oh, look. I I think given that all of
the other ones have gone to, it would be
nice to see three. And also, I mean,
just from a personal perspective, I
mean, my prediction was Diana. So, we
shall see if I turn out to be right. I
also did say that one of the MVPs of the
set is Hay and I imagine we will
probably see a little bit of Hay through
this as well. Yeah, actually interesting
because Nice, who did play an Aurelia in
on on camera in the Swiss actually did
win that match up, but said in his
interview was kind of a tough one. Like
there's a lot to think about. Uh just
has a lot of different powerful things,
but he was an Aelia player before the
set and then saw Diana and said, "I
don't know how good this is. I'm playing
it." And uh so far so good. Best of
Diana, the first best of Diana ever in
Unleasbound
history. So, uh, he's going to have some
reps, but up against a fearsome opponent
all the way from China, EDT Rico 1997
making the way not only as the best
Aurelia in the room, but all the way to
top four
and it is going to be a very interesting
top four. But yes, absolutely being the
best of Diana means beating people like
Allan, which is a huge feat in and of
itself, who obviously he's just knocked
out before, but wow.
>> Would have been more fun if they played
each other for you. instead we simply
just have to win your match up as you
are going to have a look at the necklace
here in the mains here. Nice boy. Uh
this is Diana and I think for the most
part things are kind of as you expect.
Things that jump out to me in this
matchup are the single hard bargain.
That is the only kind of chain
interaction, spell interaction, counter
spell really at anyway in the list. I
have looked at the sideboard, but three
frigid jewel is definitely a piece of
technology I didn't expect to see, which
is funny because Rico came prepared for
Aurora and has a main deck adapter,
which I wouldn't expect to do anything
in this matchup generally except for the
fact that his opponent has three frrigid
jewels.
>> That would do it. Yeah, it's just luck
of the drawer at that point, honestly.
But it's good to see those scuttle crabs
in there, too.
>> Yeah, Seymour may be one of the breakout
stars of this set. Certainly a card that
I did not think would see nearly as much
play. Uh it's fun to imagine a Zeromite
unit having so much impact on the metag
game and yet here we are. It's still a
two drop that is pretty good. Turns out
two drops to draw cards are things that
players are welcome. So we spin on down
to our feature match area to kick things
off. Now highest seed I believe actually
that is a question I wish I had the
answer to.
>> I do not know who the highest seat is
but I can tell you whoever it is is
going to be the player that starts first
in this game in this match.
>> Shake hands.
>> There we go.
>> All right. All right, off we go. Aurelia
versus Diana. The uh
>> kind of the Mrs. Consistent of the last
metag game and maybe of this metag game,
too. Versus the new hotness, we can say
Diana.
>> I mean, a lot of people came into this
really, really excited by Diana. I spoke
to a lot of people who were adamant that
Diana was going to be one of the best
decks in the set, but also across the
board. And goes to show that is at least
partly correct because it has made it
all the way here to top four.
>> Yeah. Also great to see just a lot of
different people from around the world
traveling to Sydney and still battling.
It is our Texas versus China,
>> which is not something I'd expect to see
all the way down here in Australia, but
>> anything can happen down under is all
I'm saying.
>> Certainly can maybe can win something in
China as a result. Perhaps Rico will be
the first as Frigid Jewel gets deployed
on turn one. That means my assumption
that Diana is the highest seed is I
think correct
>> with three runes channeled already and
we'll see what happens here on turn
number one.
>> We have an abandoned hall here and a
sunken temple which will be interesting
as we have established in previous
games. Abandoned hall pretty good for
Aurelia if she can get it too.
>> Yeah, the battlefield matchups actually
fascinating in this one. Both players
have both Amandon Hall and Tigon's Peak.
>> Battlefield obviously happy to play on.
The differences are Sunken Temple on the
Aurelia side and Ravenloom Conservatory
for the Diana side. So going to be a lot
of kind of uh splash damage if you will.
Battlefields are of course symmetrical.
So uh bringing ones that they each like
which to me kind of indicates that they
do want to do somewhat similar things as
Diana going to be the play on turn two
following up that frigid jewel which if
we didn't give it a read just yet we
maybe should. Whenever you draw your
second card each turn give a unit you
control plus two. Mhm. And we also see
that guardian angel out there very very
early. You obviously want to protect the
queen as much as possible.
Seeing how this will go.
>> So pretty straightforward stuff here.
Did have an extra rune thanks to going
second. So GA into the five runes
available for Aelia and she immediately
gets equipped up. There isn't very many
ways. Oh, that's one of them.
>> Fading memories I believe targeting the
Aurelia instead of the gear.
Rico trying to get confirmation.
>> Oh, I think realized that. No, it
doesn't hit the G. Okay.
>> Not sure if there's something else
happening there, but obviously the G
would have protected the Aurelia from uh
going down. So, makes sense to take out
the piece of gear. One of the few like
removal spells
>> that nice boy can use. There aren't that
many in Diana. It's usually a lot of
things like bounce, like starrust, but
uh that is one of the ways to get rid of
some of the permanence on EDG Rico's
side. unfortunately does leave the queen
herself alive for now.
>> That also brings up the point that we
did see in Rico's main deck. There were
three guardian angels there. So, managed
to get one out there. We shall see how
the other two come up.
>> Yeah, pretty common opener for Aurelia
here. And this is the only Aurelia in
this deck. We've seen I feel like
through Spirit Forge, especially with
Aurelia becoming such a powerful unit,
we did see more decks across the
different uh calm chaos combinations
utilizing multiple Aurelas, even Aurelia
herself, just saying, you know what, I
kind of need a backup of this unit
sometime cuz sometimes the best thing
you can do when your opponent is
struggling to deal with your first
Aelia, is to simply play another one.
>> But, uh, this is the only one available
to EDG Rico, which has been kind of a
common thing in Aurelia's lifespan in
Riftbound. So, the princess must be
protected cuz if she ever goes away,
your powers in combat get reduced
significantly. It certainly doesn't mean
you can't win the game from there. But
your ability to do the really silly
stuff goes down a lot.
>> Absolutely. It is kind of ironic that
over the course of this weekend, we have
seen a Vex deck with more Aurelas than
this Aurelia deck.
>> Yep. Certainly have. All three in uh in
that vex deck we had on stream a couple
times. was a Dwight as as has been all
of the weekend. Really
>> playing a monumental amount of rift
bounders. First big think here comes out
from nice boy.
>> Maybe actually we must go on Rico's turn
cuz all those runes are awakened. Aelli
is ready. She has been pumped. So just
trying to make a decision. Where do we
want to go? Sunken Temple looking
attractive.
>> Mhm.
>> Given that there's a card draw lying in
wait for that conquer.
>> We'll see if uh Rico wants to go there.
Just having a having a think about other
options here. Getting a quick peek at
the hand. Discipline at the front of
that one.
>> I do believe that I saw a starross in
there before.
>> Yep. Starcross Gust.
>> Mhm.
>> Adaptron is actually in the hand. And
there's a charm, I have to imagine. Or
defy.
>> Sorry, those the costs for those two
cards are the same. I got tripped up
earlier by that one.
>> So, I wonder if that frigid jewel is
kind of getting eyed here. It would be
pretty nice to have your one Adaptron in
this spot given that it doesn't do all
that much in all the other matchups. And
of course, Aurelia is very good at
readying units. So Adaptron could be
ready to go as soon as right now. Adapt
>> and pass. Interestingly, Aurelia going
to stay at home.
>> Didn't want to take didn't want to risk
the card draw and she couldn't get home.
>> Sometimes a little bit of caution and
it's understandable.
>> I think this is something you see in
general from a lot of top players. They
know when to hold back.
>> Absolutely.
>> When to leave units at home, when the
when they really want to start scoring,
when that actually matters. Uh I saw
this actually in Atlanta. Prismaticis
has been holding back units a lot when
the point tempo wasn't in evens and even
nice boy kind of developing a bit before
moving on.
>> And obviously because Diana is so
showdown focused, you really don't want
to just leave them out there lingering
before. You have had the opportunity to
build her up just a little bit more.
Maybe if the guardian angel was still
around, possibly a little bit of a
different choice there, but obviously
given that it is in the trash, little
more cautious understandably so.
>> Yeah. So, a frigid jewel, I believe,
going off there on Diana after the card
draw from the predicted find a spell.
Uh, using that scorn of the moon legend
text to activate Diana's when I defend
or attack ability, which is extremely
good.
>> And now, Moonfall going to try and get
Aelia involved. This is one of the
things we certainly expected. Sometimes
you get your unit charmed at an
inopportune time. I have a feeling that
card I saw earlier was indeed defy. And
it will indeed cut off the moon with the
one hard bargain here again. But nice
boy.
>> This happened the last time we played
Aurelia.
>> Also trying to think I think
I think there is a abandoned hall
trigger.
>> It did not happen.
>> Yeah, you draw the spell when you reveal
the top card of your deck if it's a
spell.
>> Mhm.
>> So that's where the plus two from that
jewel is coming from. But there should
be one more thanks to Hall. Looks like
we're now correcting for the first one.
Raven Bloom student also going to get a
bit bigger, but oh no, never mind. It
wasn't draw. You just draw the card.
That's how it works. He didn't play
anything. All right, we're back. I
recalibrated my brain.
>> Understandably, the players are better
than me. And Aelia is in a precarious
situation. I may have mentioned it
already, but this is the only Aurelia in
this Aurelia deck.
>> Raven Bloom shooting going to go in for
point number two. And all of a sudden,
it feels like the swing in tempo has
happened in one direction. Yeah, look,
as I said at the top of this, if Diana
can get off much faster here, it's going
to make it a lot harder for Aurelia to
have the time to build, make sure that
she's defensible and actually go in and
make that hold.
>> Yeah, kind of reasonable to think that
>> Aurelia was going to be safe there.
Moonfall, the obvious thing you're
worried about, but
>> you have the Defy that covers it. And
there's only one hard bargain in the
list. And now you know that because deck
lists have been noted by each player.
That's certainly not something that a
player would miss looking through the
deck this especially for game one.
>> So an unfortunate mishap perhaps for the
princess, but Adaptron's going to roll
on in and keep it going as Stupify going
to turn the tide there. Raven Bloom
student going to get bigger. Oh, Frigid
Duel is only when you draw your second
card each turn. So on your turn that
usually means just one
>> because you already drew for your turn.
But Stupid Fire has to do a little bit
of extra work to get the Frigid Duel
trigger.
>> But Ravenom Student is still going to
get bigger. So, it's going to be three
might versus four. Sorry, two might
versus three effectively.
>> Yeah.
>> So, a two might swing was what I was
trying to get at.
>> Mhm.
>> Discipline. I would like to get a little
bit bigger. Up we go to one more now.
Four plays three and no spells left. So,
Raven Loom student going to lose the
battle. Sunken Temple going to happen.
Not going to be mighty enough to get
that sunken temple draw. unfortunately
is going to be a five at the end of
this, but you must be a five when you
get there. One of the changes that
happened relatively recently is you must
meet the condition uh before you when
the trigger would happen. Uh even if you
meet it after from conquering and
getting a buff, but that buff does mean
a frigid jewel does get eaten away and
Adaptron gets a point for EG. Rico still
fighting back despite losing that
Aurelia early on.
All righty. So considering the rest of
the options I see
>> is that
>> is that there's boots of swiftness
there. We've got
>> one second. Let me just look through
this deck again.
>> Let's have a quick look.
Yeah, I I
do not know. Boots of swiftness is what
I saw. I saw a full art card that looked
very expensive
>> in terms of energy cost. I don't know
what it is, but that's okay. We'll find
out in a moment.
>> Looks like uh some runes being corrected
here.
>> Oh, so I can't do this.
>> Play two for the discipline.
>> Oh, trying to pay for temple, but uh I
believe you cannot pay for temple. Yeah,
I think that's what's being explained.
>> Mhm. So, uh again, it's relatively
recent rules change, but you cannot
cannot you cannot fulfill the condition
for a temple when you conquer it by
conquering uh by killing a gear.
>> Uh it's kind of the same change that
made set slightly worse at the monastery
because you can no longer move in, get
the buff, and then spend it because you
didn't have the buff when that condition
was uh checking. And if you don't meet
the condition, you don't get to draw the
card. I'm pretty confident this is what
the players are talking about uh at the
table, but from my current understanding
>> that makes sense.
>> Should not draw the card here. The unit
is not mighty at the time it needed to
be mighty.
>> You know what? Let's have a read a
second temple while the players
deliberate
because uh it's been a minute. I suppose
when you conquer here with one or more
mighty units, that means five might or
more, you may pay one to draw one. So
even though the unit has fulfilled the
uh is the sufficient size, it was the
sufficient size at the insufficient time
as boots of swiftness going to get
played equipped. Now that unit's going
to be mighty for sure next time and
Aurelia even going to ready it up. So it
is time to gank on over to the abandoned
hall and Diana certainly going to lose
that fight. Two points now to Aurelia
and a very swift clean up of the
battlefield despite not having the
signature unit. Yeah, look, if you had
told me at the start of this that
instead of Aurelia being the one to be
rocking those boots of swiftness and
being almighty that it would be the
adapter,
I would not have believed you for a
single moment that we have coming out as
well. That's my boy.
>> This is the thing about Aurelia. Uh does
it matter sometimes what the unit is?
Every now and then Lonely Porro gets to
be the hero of the story.
>> Uh units just big enough usually when
Aelia has enough time and resources to
pump them up. But Hay certainly the
Stellorn of this deck. I even asked
Nice, he was a previous Aelia player,
what he thought of the of Hay. It's
basically like, yeah, I feel like it's
Stilicorn times 100 or something like
that.
>> There is so much versatility to it. For
anybody who hasn't had a closer look, I
will give you a little read of Hay. It
reads, "When I move, draw one, then
discard one, then do the following based
on the discarded cards type. If it's a
spell, draw one. If it's gear, ready up
to two runes. And if it's a unit, give
it three might this turn." Yeah, it kind
of makes sense why Frigid Jewel is such
a a key card for this Diana build.
>> Absolutely.
>> Obviously, Huay triggers that uh very
easily on your own turn just with a
single move. And it might not seem like
there's that much movement in this deck
versus something like I don't know,
Aurelia for example, but seen a couple
flashes and all three Ride the Winds are
actually in this Diana list as well. So
clearly valuing that mobility uh for
lots of different reasons, but likely to
power up Hay is one of the big ones as a
little starcross action happen. Bounce
Huay back to hand. So, not going to be
hu time just yet, but a little
additional action of returning the
scuttle crab. They already drew a card
to your hand cuz you do have to return
one of your friendly units as well.
>> Little double dip of old Seymour.
>> Good way back in.
>> And Tide Turner just a little unit.
Going to pass it on back and kind of
give the
tempo back to Aelia who's certainly
retaken despite losing her key unit
earlier. Dabstrong going to score up to
five. Boots of swiftness going to make
it six. Going to end up with the
abandoned hall, which tends to be the
place you want to be at uh for both of
these decks.
And uh six points to two is going to be
the lead that EDG Rico finds himself
with.
Counting out the runes.
>> We've discussed that abandoned hall
quite a few times over the course of the
weekend. When a player plays a spell,
they may give a unit they control here
plus one might this turn. very very good
for Aurelia for a lot of reasons.
>> Oh yes, for Sally we won't get to talk
about the other thing that we like to
talk about the other time because
there's no more Aurelius in this game.
>> Perhaps next game though is abandoned
hall is going to get visited by
Adapatron
the old Robo Fries just rolling on in.
Point number six now for ED Rico
recycles a rune
got something to play. Yeah, let's charm
this way. M
>> we'll get a quay trigger though.
>> Five,
>> three, four, five, six, seven is how big
adapt currently is including the buff of
abandoned hall but can get to eight
>> very easily as long as you discard a
unit from your hand and there is an
extra copy of the question is is it
worth the potential risk and it is nice
boy wants to save his brooding painter
now an eight might unit as uh the
expected pump's going to come through on
the other side. discipline going to make
it bigger and uh that's going to be
enough for Adaptron to win this fight.
Going to be plus three thanks to the
hall effectively. And now the giant
adaptron is going to beat the very giant
Haye but there's a bit more to come from
Stupify
>> going to shrink it. 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
shrunk to 9 and Hi's at 8 going to go to
9 himself. So it's going to be a trade
at the end of the day by the looks of
things. Although there are more spells
for Aurelia if she wants to keep
committing here and typically once
you're in you stay in. Here's Defy going
to counter that Superfy. And there's Hay
going down
>> after you've already lost that Aurelia.
You really don't want to lose this
adapter at this point. Obviously, there
would still be maybe some other options.
I know that we do have the Stellacicorns
in there as well, but for now, we've
already started building it up. You
don't want to lose it.
>> Yeah, I think just uh keeping the tempo
when you can. Kind of Aurelia's credo.
Not the not bad at holding. is much
better at conquering, but every now and
then you get in this spot where you're
holding up a bunch of runes. Your
opponent doesn't really have any units
you can contain with your uh Robo Fryer
Giant. And Diana seems to be out of
tricks here. Woefully behind on points
and uh the win is on board for Aurelia.
Score one for holding and score the
other battlefield by ganking. Don't even
need the scuttle crab to do the dirty
work for you.
>> Very meticulous uh graveyard layout here
>> on the right hand side of our screen.
Tieturner rolls in. Switcheroo.
Moonfall. See one of those in hand. Not
a fight that it feels like Titoner can
win all that easily. Going to activate
Diana for a resource and stack some
decks.
>> A deck. See what comes through.
>> Stack deck. Of course, an action can be
played in showdown. Can be played on
your turn as well. But if you want the
resource out of your Dana, you must find
a showdown
whether it's open or closed. But now
that we're going to the battlefield that
has something at it,
does seem
like there's a plan here for nice boy
cuz could have done this at the sunken
temple if you wanted to. So here's
Moonfall.
>> I love the art on Moonfall. It is one of
the coolest cards I think from this set.
It reads, "Choose a battlefield where
you have units. You may move up to one
enemy unit to that battlefield, then
give enemy units there minus two this
turn." A nice bit of uh extra value here
as the scuttle crab is going to get
involved. Notably, the scuttle crab does
actually have to take a damage to go
down. So, if you don't have uh you'll
need like N plus1 where N is the adapter
might to kill all the units at the
battlefield even though the crab can't
hurt you. Uh it certainly can stay
conquering if you don't have enough
damage to get it done. So, shrinkage
there on the Adapatron. Minus two means
it's base one.
>> That's stupid.
>> Minus one again makes it effectively
zero. So we'll add up the rest of it.
One from the buff and two from the
boots. Only three might right now versus
the four of the tide turner. About to be
five thanks to abandoned hall. But as we
know,
>> Aurelia's always got something up her
sleeve.
>> Absolutely. And there are still runes
open there over on that side.
>> Already spied the defiant dance that I
think is going to be the blowout in this
situation.
>> And again, EDG Rico can play knowing
that there's no more hard bargains to
interfere with the potential pump. So
just tapping the table doing the math.
>> Can see not so fast. Another star
crossed.
>> Looks like only one card you can
reasonably pump with.
>> It's very difficult to tell.
>> Deep in thought there.
Very, very, very important to make sure
you're thinking through all of your
choices. you often will see at this
stage of the day quite decisive play but
is also equally important to make sure
that you are thinking everything
through. We are all here after a very
long weekend and sometimes that mental
acuity your endurance maybe doesn't
linger quite so much. So here we go.
>> So Gust the crab makes the bigger
actually wins the fight against the
adapatron. Uh I believe I think Rico
might have missed an abandoned hall
trigger after not so fast but I don't
think it mattered. The tie turner wins
the combat, kills the adaptron, and
stops the bleeding
>> as the scutter crab gets gusted. Not
ideal because that does draw a card
every time you play it.
>> That being said, I don't think I saw any
other units in hand there for Rico. So,
you're going to want to figure out
something to be able to build up.
>> All right. Cutter crab goes again.
There was another card.
>> Oh,
>> there's Aurelia.
>> There's Aurelia.
>> Did I misunderstand what happened with
that Moonfall?
I'm trying to remember.
Moonfall.
Guess we'll just pack it up.
>> Nothing else a nice bit to do. I am so
confused.
So, Moonfall
moved her into the battlefield,
played a pump, and then got it countered
by hard bargain,
>> huh? Okay. Well, game one goes to Rico.
I must have missed something,
>> but uh kind of a tough position for Denn
again. You kind of saw that hooks into a
battlefield. It was uh very tough to get
anything done after that.
and we'll shuffle up for game number
two.
>> Comes the difficult task of
sideboarding.
>> Yeah, sideboarding is a fun one.
>> And we'll have a quick look. We actually
do have the sideboards not fully on our
screens. We have them on our paper here.
So, we can read them through. Which one
shall we read first?
>> Uh, well, let's go with the Diana
sideboard first, shall we? So here we
have one angller beast, one downwell,
one moonfall, one rebuke, one
singularity, a turn to dust, unchecked
power, and believe it or not, Yasuo Wind
Rider.
>> Little Chaos Yasawo.
>> Little bit of extra mobility. Clearly
valuing the movement in kind of Chaos's
suite of tools.
>> Mhm.
>> On the other side here, for Rico
Adaptron, another one.
>> I don't know if we'll need it for this
matchup, but probably for the Auroras
moving around. Angler Beast as well,
which again must be for I think decks
with smaller units. That one uh when you
play it does return units with two M or
less to their owner's hands and it eats
them all up. Very fun little card.
>> Big fan of the art. I love the team.
>> It's terrifying. Uh disarming rake.
Another kind of anti-geear card likely
for Aurora. Two Gust, one Starrust uh to
make the third in the deck. One Vex
Apathetic of course
>> naturally.
>> And one Za's hourglass.
It's nice to see the consistency that in
almost every single matchup we have seen
a Vex show up at some point.
>> Certainly have.
>> We do know as well that in the Diana
main deck there is a Vex apathetic and a
Vex cheerless as well.
>> And uh I can let you all know what I did
actually miss.
>> Oh, you did?
>> I did. And uh I would like to thank uh
John Rift down Dave Guskin himself who
personally dared me to answer my
question. I did miss there was a gust
return in the hand. See, this is what
happen. They move so quickly at this
level and it is very, very tricky
sometimes to keep up.
>> I'm sorry, chat. That is that's on me. I
can't I cannot believe I missed that.
Cuz as soon as I saw the card, I was
like, "That's Aelia." I saw the grave. I
was like, "Where'd you go?" And then I
was like, "I missed something clearly."
Uh, turns out when Moonfall shrinks the
unit under three. You can actually gust
your own to save it, which doesn't come
up very often. But uh Moonfall's
advantage of giving minus two actually
being an advantage in that very specific
situation to keep the turns out didn't
really need it. Adaptron did all of the
beat down.
>> Goodness me. Yeah, you
>> but thank you Dave Guskin for saving the
stream.
>> That one to the the way that it goes.
I'll refocus my eyes for the next one
here cuz uh again, these are decks uh if
we didn't say it already, they both want
to interact in showdowns on the chain a
lot.
>> Mhm.
>> And uh certainly got to keep your senses
and your wits about you as players will
fist bump for game number two. And very
very well managed here by Rico as we
move on to game number two. Vanna is
going to be on the play here as well as
we go to the Raven Bloom Conservatory up
against the other abandoned hall. M.
>> All right, having a look here at what is
in hand. Obviously, we can see that
scuttle crab again for Rico.
>> Yeah, stack deck. Not so fast. And one
more card.
>> Mhm.
>> And we'll get a little peek in just a
moment. Tide turner going to be the
first play though as nice boy passes on
back. Energy Rico channels three runes
and has something in store here on turn
number one. Maybe start with a stack
deck. See if there's a two drop you
maybe like nestled among them. Defiant
Dance. That last card in hand after the
draw for turn was Starcross. But of
course, we already have the perfect two
drop. So, don't even need anything else.
Scuttle crab back down on turn number
one.
Perhaps an aggressive August is coming
here cuz did leave a rune open. Didn't
want to use the stack that can use it
now in showdown, but instead, no, it is
a Gust. Back to hand is keeping that
tempo despite going second as Diana
Lunar going to hit the field.
>> That was a gust that we definitely saw.
I'm I'm keeping my eyes on every single
one. I will say both these players have
a lot of gusts in their attack.
>> They really do. In the Diana side, we
have three
>> and it is up to three after side
possible for Rico. One in the main,
which was very good in game number one,
it turned out, but two in the board if
he wants for this match up. I don't know
how often you're expecting to have Gus
do something. And obviously, Diana has
the ability to shrink units with things
like Stupify, things like Moonfall, so
can be a little bit easier for Diana to
use Gusts offensively. But uh if it is
something that saves your units and I
already have an answer has at least one
more because I just a one-off stack deck
clearly valuing it here in the match up.
I think especially going second that
makes a lot of sense to me trying to
again kind of push your opponent off the
early point so you can be the one to get
on kind of on the battlefield first
because this is a match up where the
race kind of breaks out in a way where
the player that kind of can start the
point lead can try and put pressure on
their opponent to make plays when
they're not maybe ready or set up to and
try and snowball off from there.
>> Absolutely. As I said once again comes
down to tempo. There is that Vex.
>> Another one out of the board. Makes a
decent amount of sense. There's plenty
of Ride the Wind and Ride the Wind
adjacent things happening in this Diana
list. So, Vax Apathetic sitting on the
battlefield. Seems like a pretty good
card to have. Also, just a very nicely
sized unit we can say for energy for
four. Feels like pretty good value.
Diana going to do the thing. If you
haven't seen this one before, Diana
Lunari, whenever a showdown begins, you
may pay one. If you do, predict and
reveal the top card of your uh of your
deck. If it's a spell, draw it.
Otherwise, recycle it.
And we have my boy once more way.
>> Sad they didn't make Vex uh a mind unit,
right? Cuz then Vex and I guess they can
be in the same deck. There's a bunch of
purple Vexes, but uh
>> absolutely.
>> You know, you can you can you can have
an apathetic Vex and a brooding painter
in the same deck. I suppose
>> really collecting the uh the early
2000s.
>> There's a lot of
>> scene kits.
>> Yeah, a lot of lot of brooding on this
board state right now. I'm here for it,
honestly.
>> Kind of makes sense, I suppose, given
Diana's
>> kind of nighttime thematic as Vex
apathetic
>> feeling maybe not too indifferent about
this incoming showdown.
>> Raven Bloom Conservatory going to
trigger. Goes for that one first. Gets
the hit. Finds a flash and now going to
pay for the predict perhaps draw more
cards. Wouldn't be bad given that unit's
probably going away here. No Diana to
use for the resource, but good enough to
pay one here when Diana's likely going
out anyway.
Not sure what it is.
>> Having a quick peek. Back to the hand we
go.
>> X again there.
>> That one's certainly good in this
matchup. Again, this is something that
got played a lot in the Aelia mirror.
So, uh, when you're against actual
Aurelia as Diana and these two decks do
have some similarities as far as what
they want to do in showdowns, makes
sense that if players have access to
this, they would play it. There is no
access to this card in Rico's deck.
There's actually some just hanging out
in the main one in fact here for Nice
Boy. Ride the wind going to be found
>> after that little predictor. Recycled
one. So Dana getting a lot of value
despite perishing here, but is one point
a piece now as a scuttle crab does what
Scott crab does. Off to the abandoned
hall for point number two.
>> All right, recycle
star cross
>> and that just never gets to play.
>> Consistently kind of slow speed if you
will despite it being a very powerful
reaction. just bouncing way back to hand
to prevent any advantage from kind of
mounting rolling on for Diana.
>> We have seen so many star cross over the
past couple of days. It has been one of
the most popular spells at the Riftbound
regional qualifiers here in Sydney.
>> Yeah, might miss Gus. Don't miss that
one.
as uh
thinking thinking once again the value
of the scuttle crab being returned to
hand is not lost on me cuz I do love
drawing cards
>> are just going to be boots of swiftness
and go by the looks of things. Yep. Go
ahead. And with Vexpathetic on the
board, there is really not a lot you
have to worry about.
>> A lot of units,
>> lot of ride the winding. In fact, you
saw a ride the wind off of the reveal
from Raven Bloom. So, you know there's
one around there and you know
Beexpathetic is going to put a stop to
any shenanigans that may be in play as
nice boy gives a little chuckle and just
redeploy it way once again hoping this
time it's going to stay on the
battlefield.
>> Brooding ever more.
>> All right, so awaken point number three
and Vex is going to I assume park
herself on one of these battlefields for
a decent amount of time. But boots are
there so I guess you could go park at
the other one. Get Vex a little ganking.
>> Looks like there was a not so fast in
there. Obviously the Defying Dance
Scutter Crab
>> and Charm as well, which seems like a
pretty
>> That seems like bad news for
>> There's a lot of cards though in Diana's
hand. I mean, look, that's like a what
10 or so just at a glance.
>> 6 7 8 9 10. Okay,
>> that was that was a complete guess.
just was a nice round number that seemed
close and you know that Dana has tricks
not as many as you as Zerelia player but
we'll start with scholar crab draw an
extra card get a little look get
information before we decide to commit
to a line here cuz I think again qu is a
problem you do want to deal with pretty
consistently but going to start with the
boots is going to suit on up and walk on
over to the abandoned hall
and uh perhaps pick off fight with Hay
although Hay does trigger on move
and uh it is often eight smite in spots
like this. So perhaps the charm would be
a little misplaced unless more resources
want to get committed. So the question I
guess becomes how much do you dislike
this way? How important do you think it
is to Diana's game plan? I would say
pretty important.
>> I I would agree with you on that one
just purely for that level of
versatility. And I mean you've got a a
hand size that big. Discarding doesn't
feel quite so painful. Oh, here's the
charm. Where's going to move on in
>> to the abandoned hall where Vex does get
a bonus buff to kick things off thanks
to the charm. Of course, Square is going
to trigger. Draw a card. Now, discard
one. You get one of three effects. If
it's a unit plus two, if it's a spell,
draw a card. If it's a gear, ready two
runes. And we are going to Ready to
runes.
>> Not the choice I thought I was going to
see when we kick things off, but it's
time for a flash.
>> There we go.
>> No nonsense. I don't want to deal with
any of your pumps at this showdown. I
just want to get on out of here, get my
trigger, and save my precious, precious
boy.
>> All right,
>> there we go.
>> Rico says, "You got it."
>> Mhm.
>> Not so fast does not stop that one cuz
it's not targeting your units or gear.
It's targeting their units. So, defy
would work. Not so fast does not. And
Quay triggers once again thanks to
flashing back to base. flashing back to
safety
up against this Vex.
>> Can still see that hard bargain in
there. You want to hold on to that until
exactly the right moment given that you
do only have the one in there.
>> All right. Well, Vexal is going to hit
the bin. That pump is probably not doing
something this turn. I think that's more
just a I like the rest of the cards in
my hand and I want to keep them. But it
could be a potential move for Ride the
Wind. But I think if you were willing to
flash out of there, you're probably not
willing to pick a fight.
>> No,
>> but again,
>> getting that move trigger though.
>> Yeah, this unit does present a problem
is kind of the other thing.
>> Every unit I really get to keep a hold
of, especially when she has a point lead
is just
frustrating.
>> Yes, very much so.
>> I mean, look, I know the scarc's not
like particularly scary, but it's not
nothing as guardian angel. You'll go a
little something something.
>> It's Look, the day I see uh a Defiant
Dance Scott crab win a game, I I'll be
I'll be something. I guess I'll be
excited for the most part.
>> Guardian going to be equipped to Vex.
Apathetic. Just hunkering on down and
passing it on back. Not even bothering
to try and take another point.
>> I guess I already did it cuz I did
realize that those moves happened on
Rico's turn thanks to that charm. It's a
little confusing sometimes where we are
on the turn as he's going to go back in
for seconds. But with all the runes
awaken, feels like a bit of an easier
time here to try and beat up this Vex.
And there's Hay discarded to give this
one plus three. Eight might plays four,
five, six, seven for Vex right now.
>> Having those runes open though does make
it a little bit more of a risk.
>> Oh yeah, we're at abandoned hole. This
uh this is going to be something.
>> There's always something coming around.
And again, we did already clock the
defiant dance. So that is plus five at
abandon hall effectively.
Plus two minus two and one more for fun
gives you effectively five. It's kind of
the easy heristic to use with the fire
dance. Works the same way with Aurelia
thanks to choosing her making her a
little bit bigger. There is also a
discipline
>> that could be deployed if we want to
save our precious pump for later. But
again, an unbelievable number of cards
you have to consider here in this
exchange. I think you would also think
at four points you're probably going to
continue trying to just hold on with
this Vex. I don't know necessarily that
you'd want to pump up another unit.
>> Yeah, just kind of I mean you still have
your chosen champion and you're kind of
running a little low on runes just from
the the natural power cost that that
Karm as a domain has to pay that Aurelia
as a deck often utilizes in order to use
her legend ability. It hasn't been that
much of that, but
cuz Hi's been replayed so many times and
rided a couple runes, I feel like the
resource game right now is in favor of
Diana. You can see it's five runes to
whatever that number is. Eight, I think.
We're just going to let it go. There's
the G. There is the G there as well.
>> Feeling that when it comes to just flash
counting those.
>> I missed one thing and now I'm locked in
as Guardian Angel going to be stripped
off that Vex. Of course, makes the fight
feel a little bit easier
>> to tank. Rico just going to be bounced
back off the abandoned hall as well. He
does get a point. Second point now on
the board for nice boy. But
>> quite the mountain to climb at this
stage.
>> But if there's a unit that's going to
make some magic happen in Diana, it is
going to be a unit like Quay.
>> I mean, one of the MVPs for sure.
>> Yeah, there was a ton of chatter about
this unit. You kind of see why. Curious
if there's any other shells that might
fancy this card. M
>> but certainly in Diana seems to be at
its best as we pass on back seven runes
now as Rico considers what the next
course of action is. Has been pretty uh
pretty aggressive about
dealing trying to uh trying to fight Hay
whenever possible or at least keep it
off the board with something like
Starcross. So can't win without scoring
the points as it turns out at least for
the most part. M
>> so likely wants to look to conquer twice
here and put that pressure on. Stacol
though going to maybe signal a turn off.
Indeed it does.
>> Passing it on back. Feeling like the
point parody is fine. And that's even if
Diana can get on the other side to the
Raven Bloom Conservatory once the draw
power kind of bank a couple resources
and build up for a bigger turn. I kind
of like this. I feel like you're putting
yourself in a position to navigate to a
really powerful endame. And again, there
are just so many cards in Diana's hand.
You can only fight through so many at a
time. So, looks like we're building up a
little bit of an arms race here. Is Quay
going to move on back thanks to Tide
Turner. Switch on back. Get a Quay
trigger. And of course, Quay stays
ready. So, Ravenloom Conservatory, yet
another option with all those moves. So,
you filter through so much of your deck.
Frigid Juel going to ready two runes.
Way going to move again, draw a card,
discard one more. What's it going to be?
>> You really do feel spoiled for choice,
not only with that many cards in hand,
but that many runes available. will ride
the wind goes to the bin which is a
pretty clear signal that there's more
than one in nice boy's hand and Rico has
already seen one off of an earlier
reveal from conservatory. So pass it
back as the points are equal for a piece
but the first to awaken and look to
score the next two as we are moving
ourselves towards the final stages of
this game. Not quite the end game just
yet but we're like
>> right near the end of the mid game.
Yeah.
>> All right. Dance, boots, not so fast.
And charm. Is that the last? No, it's
discipline that we saw already in hand.
But Stellorn can uh make some moves. We
can say draw a ton of cards for Aurelia.
It really is kind of the the standout
card. I know they're Aurelia players
that say despite how powerful Fervent
is, that they would happily play
Stellicorn as their chosen champion if
they were allowed to.
>> Mhm. And uh given the games I've seen
with that card from Aelia, I do not
blame them as Ride the Wind going to try
and interfere
with Vax Apathetic walting into the
abandoned hall. So Ride the Wind ready
my way. Move it on over. Trigger units
ready because Yep. Turn that one this
way. Doesn't really matter.
>> No uh meditation to speak of. That's a
calm card. That would be one of the few
reasons that you would care about this.
Aurelia Fervin does care about it. Uh
cuz when she ready she gets a little bit
bigger. But uh mostly just for the move
here is fading memories. Going to go to
the bin draw another card and abandon
hall going to trigger.
>> So we got eight to six there now. Is it?
>> Oh that's fascinating. I think cuz you
choose on resolution. You can choose. I
did not know that.
So now six might for this up against the
six of vex. So I imagine nice is going
to want to make this unit a little bit
bigger. And this Moonfall looking real
nice.
>> Not so fast though.
Still available.
Pretty sure that one can counter Moon
for Should be able to.
>> Don't think it's like a Repulse. There's
that new uh body spell that cares about
a single unit. This one is just uh that
chooses a friendly unit or gear.
Certainly one of those is being chosen
here. So, not so fast. It's going to
come out. Counter that moonfall. pretty
much all of the counters work
in that situation whether it was to
fight or not so fast. So the hard
bargain is uh not enough with how many
runes are available for either side. So
despite it being in the hand for nice
point once again looks like we are going
to have to keep on trucking here if we
want to do something else. So tapping
Diana and paying for a stupify going to
look to shrink this Vex a little bit
more. get the abandoned hall buff as
effectively that one might die that was
on there just goes away to represent
where Vex is currently at. But there's
more where that came from. Time for
discipline. Pumping up that Vex going to
be for plus three effectively here at
Abandon Hall.
So currently 5 6 7 9 plays
>> 99.
>> It is 99.
>> Don't think where either player wants it
to be. So we'll go again. Here's smoke
screen.
has to pay deflect of course. It's the
other brutal thing about effects.
>> Yeah.
>> So minus four plus one for Quay
effective plus five in the exchange.
So just uh one right now. Oh, all the
hall buffs gone. Sorry. Still the base
might count. So 3 4 5
plays 8 + 2 is 10.
>> Yeah, look ordinarily I think if you
were facing down having to add on that
deflect cost, it would be a little bit
of a bother. I feel like the best person
positioned for this is Diana though
obviously because of her little extra
help on those showdowns.
>> Yep, there's uh a little energy
discount. So even though it can't help
you unlike Kaisa with deflect can
certainly make the take the sting out of
it if you will.
>> So Rico, considering what else is going
on here, how much do I want to save this
Vex? Or maybe more accurately, how much
do I want to deal with this way?
>> Yeah, that's very fair. I feel like if
it was just a question of saving the Vex
and not necessarily thinking so much
about the Hay, you would feel reasonably
okay still having that Stellorn there as
well, but Hay can make some moves, you
know.
>> Yeah, I mean clearly the key unit in
this deck and uh in again in the same
way that Stellorn and I guess Aurelia
are the key units for
>> the Aurelia deck does kind of make sense
to me that this is the fight you want to
pick. But I do think that if there's a
turn that's going to potentially
determine the outcome of this game, it
does feel like this one.
>> Mhm.
A 10 to five there.
>> Yeah. Defiant dance time.
>> Oh yeah. Don't think there's really any
other alternative.
>> Oh god. Actually,
>> Rico. Oh, was there?
>> I thought there was one, but I may may
have already passed us by. We'll do a
quick check. Not in the graveyard. Not
in the trash.
And Rico currently leaning very far over
his cards. And I think they're also on
the table. So I really can't see them
right now. So we'll just wait with Beta
Breath to see what do you want to do
here. Need to find yourself five. Might
get a little help with the abandoned
hall.
>> Just a little.
>> Every spell gives a little bump up. So
you don't need quite as much as you
might expect, but still an unbelievable
number of cards fanning out across the
battlefield back and forth as Rico
decides to commit even more to this
showdown on guard. Going to be plus
three effectively. That's going to be up
to eight. Still not quite enough there.
>> Is enough to kill the Hay though
>> cuz that two extra might making 10 is
coming from the tide turner. So feels
like nice boy is going to go again.
Stack deck. Very cute
>> getting the pump off abandoned hall for
a little bit of an extra bump as
starrust Raven Bloom suit and I believe
another stack deck of the three cards
quickly seen and sent to the bottom. And
now up one more big enough to survive
against Vex. And I Rico has doesn't want
to do anything with that. Defant Dance
finally going to be committed on the
chain.
Oh yeah, a little random recycle.
Everyone's got to choose.
>> And here it comes. Yep, there we go.
>> All right, so eight plays 11. And again,
you can basically shortcut this to plus
five. So that is going to be more at the
end of it all. Shrink by two, down to
nine, up by three, up to 14.
M
>> 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
5 9 11 It is 11 total.
11 plays less. Enough flash at the end
of it all. He's getting out of dodge.
>> Oh, look at this point. You've done your
best to maintain those the units there.
I can understand why you want to hold on
even though it does mean you've
technically had to make that move there.
But Quay did move.
>> If I recall correctly,
did this start
from a charm? Is that how we got here?
Cellon going to move on over. Get point
number five and uh sorry, point number
six, excuse me. Because of course the
point for holding, I believe, was
already gotten or at least Vax
conquering one or the other is good
enough to get it. Draw a card. Play some
boots. Equip them up to our Celicorn and
uh use Aelia to retreat Stelicon back
for an extra card draw. Well worth the
power you have to pay.
Draw another card. Refuel for next turn.
And now we're in the end game at least
for EDG Rico.
>> Yep. Got to hope that for this wonderful
Diana player, you can think of something
to figure out how to address these
growing issues over here. will turn to
dust on a bad draw, but that
unfortunately deals with the gear next
turn. Doesn't help you with the boots
that Vex is wearing right now. And you
do need to keep these units at bay off
these battlefields. Moonfall would have
been a great way to do that. But the
last one did get foiled.
There is another one though lurking in
the hand. You can see that beautiful
full art just peeking out between the
middle of those cards.
>> Yeah, mindsplitter.
Feels like it's not quite time for mind
splitter. Hay draws a card. Looking to
discard. Rolling on in. It is six might
at the battlefield for Vex. Discard the
mind splitter. Make it eight. And
Epathetic says, "I'm good. You got me."
>> Going to get point number five now for
nice boy. Ed Rico has a different plan
as Ty Turner claims point number six. So
Diana poised to win next turn
potentially,
>> but obviously has to deal with whatever
torrent is just about to come out of
this Aurelia deck. Not having seen that
mind spplitter in the hand before. I
love that as a way to turn things around
just a little bit.
>> Yeah, if you have the time, have the
resources, really good to get a look at
Aelia's hand cuz uh if you know what
you're up against and take a key part
away, can be easier to play around all
of the tricks which she can potentially
have.
>> And that hand is not all that hot right
now for EDG. Ricoorn can make it
different in an instant though. It was
looking pretty good before, but yes,
having that draw would come in handy.
>> Yeah, it's a scuttle crab, I believe.
Scuttle crab stack deck. Ride the wind.
>> Not the cards you're looking for
when you go and make a big play with
something like, I don't know, Aurelia.
In fact, there's apart from boots, not
that many ways to choose her. Is Scutter
Crab going to roll on in, get the
information? And this is the other thing
that makes this card so powerful. When
you run it in, you get to look at the
hand. And finally, we're going to see 10
cards written down. I think
>> one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10.
>> Goodness.
>> Get a good look here.
>> Okay. So, we do have quite a lot here on
that side of the board to have a perusal
of.
>> It's funny. I was talking about how this
is one of the things that mine splitter
lets you do
>> m
>> on uh on the other side and uh turns out
you can just do it for two. Didn't even
need to pay the full seven and two chaos
power. Little old crab just rolls on in
there which again it's one of the more
understated things about the car but I
think one of the reasons it's been such
a mainstay
>> of our calm decks and uh kind of a
staple from unleash that at least for me
was a little bit unexpected. Does a lot
of little things but all the little
things add up to some pretty powerful
packages at times. All for the low low
price of too little energy.
>> I do believe as well it was the third
most popular unit of the weekend. Lot of
decks running this little crab.
>> Yep. Makes sense given the uh quality of
the local seafood here in Sydney.
>> Crabs everywhere
as Rico says, "You got it. Pick them
up." Celicorn's going to go over here,
draw a card, pick a fight. Five might to
two against this tide turner. And again,
if Rico can find a way to score both
battlefields this turn, that will be a
win. and moving on to the finals in a
clean sweep. But this game has been a
little bit more
>> little bit more not bogged down, but a
little bit more deliberate than the
first. Lot of back and forth, a lot of
jostling for position here.
>> As I said earlier, you really do have to
make sure you have considered every
single option at this juncture of the
competition here.
>> Here comes way
>> rolling in again. Get to move is ready
technically again. Yep. going to be
turned right side up here by EG Rico. I
you know I appreciate keeping the game
nice and clean.
>> Unit going to get discarded I have to
imagine cuz looking to win a fight needs
might to do that now at eight thanks to
that Raven Bloom being discarded and
>> Rico packs it up. We got a game three.
>> A there we go. Well, that was your hope
at the start of the game that we would
see three here now given that the other
matches over the course of this top
eight have gone 2 and 0
>> despite the Stellorn. Nothing left in
the tank to get it done there as Nice
picks up a game here and is poised to
make the finals himself. Diana Versel,
what a fascinating matchup. I mean, I
think if you wanted the log line of what
happened in that game,
>> uh, one player had 10 cards in their
hand for most of the game and the other
player didn't.
>> Yep, that pretty much sums it up. Not to
mention all of those runes and the
additional support of having Diana,
those showdowns giving you that extra.
>> Yeah, just at at certain point, I felt
like, okay, Aurelia used a bunch of her
stuff to try and uh win a combat, which
is kind of something she does a lot, but
couldn't find a way to refill. And uh
when it wasn't enough to tip the game
back in your favor, Quay Value Train
just kept on going. I can see why Nice
Boy in his interview after his Swiss
round feature mate said that he thought
this card was better than Stella.
>> Mhm. Absolutely. And it's interesting to
see both of these players seeming
reasonably unshaken by the turn of
events here. Very poised, very focused.
I appreciate that as a Diana player, in
fact, our best Diana player, winning the
best of here in our top four, uh, is
kind of embracing the nighttime vibes,
despite it being inside quite lateish
now in Sydney, 9:00 p.m.
>> We're in those shades.
>> Just got to keep it, you know, just got
to keep the vibes nice and immaculate.
>> Absolutely. Well, it kind of goes with
the energy of having, you know, the Vex
apathetic. And it's it's a more, you
know,
a solemn vibe sometimes.
>> Looking cozy. I have to say see both
players looking very comfortable.
>> And a little fist bump to kick off our
final game of this semiinal.
>> We're going to have one more and the top
four will conclude on this side of the
bracket, but we have more to come, I
have to imagine. Don't know how the
other one's doing. We'll check in when
we get there, shall we? But now, game
three between Aelia and Diana is off to
the races. And it's two peaks.
>> Wow.
>> It's peak.
>> It's peak time.
>> Well, should be in for a good game then
if this is already peak. Looks like
Aurelia going. Nope.
Diana. Nope. Are they going first? Did
lose the other game.
>> Yep.
>> Scutter crab already on the board.
Looking good so far as Rico passes it on
back. Three runes channel. Diana played.
Must be nice to have a champion that
only costs three energy.
Lucian players everywhere start to
rejoice.
All right, Scott Krab going to do some
conquering. Here we go to the peak.
>> Oh, not yet.
Rico was a little bit at a rune deficit
after casting all of those spells
earlier in the last match there. So
maybe Targon's Peak will come in handy
giving that little bit of replenishment
of readying those two runes at the end
of the turn. you kind of saw how
valuable uh both players having access
to runes to play spells in showdown was.
>> So, Ton's Peak makes a lot of sense for
both these decks. Again, the
battlefields are eerily similar. There's
only uh one different one between them.
So, inevitably, we're maybe going to get
a mirror match as far as battlefields
go, and that apparently is this game as
Vex Apathetic going to get deployed as
Rico passes on back. Respecting the rule
of twos in Riftbound.
>> No reason to take a stray point when I
have to win in twos anyway. Leave the
scuttle crab at home. And there I get
the first point. Get that predict and
perhaps get a card draw out of the deal.
Oh my goodness, that's a hit.
>> Got to be happy with a moonfall there.
>> Well, it feels good to predict and not
have to put it on the bottom. Just know
straight up that you're drawing quite
the card.
>> We're moonfalling already.
>> Really?
>> Yeah, that's what it looks like.
>> Here we go.
>> Pays the deflect.
>> Well, as
>> and the Vex is already in the bin.
>> It's gone. Yeah, already anticipating
there. No ghost this time with no runes
up as Raven Bloom's student going to get
played and peak of course readies two
runes. So it looks like that unit didn't
cost anything.
>> They just got a little rebate at the end
of the turn as Rico awakening six runes
now available and a wealth of options in
the hand I imagine
Aelia is a possibility. Scuttlegr can
get involved and is not that big a unit.
>> Both players really making a concerted
effort to get out there quite early this
time around. really really quick on the
uptake.
>> I think you can consider like Charm and
Moonfall as as pretty similar cards uh
in this match up. Obviously, there's
differences. Uh Moonfall is quite a bit
more powerful but cost a bit more
energy.
>> Uh scout crab is going to walk to the
peak again. If you conquer, you do
manage to you do get the opportunity to
reset two runes and that is pretty
valuable alongside the point you're
going to get. Looks like Aurelia going
to be deployed here right now and uh the
gauntlet has been laid if you will.
doesn't have to pay a power cuz that's
how Aurelia works and does ready two
runes so maybe keep her safe because
there is no guardian angel right now.
Usually some usually you see Aurelia
deployed with some level of protection
but uh Rico deciding that whatever cards
are in my hand that's good enough
>> for a protect the princess deck. She's
looking a little less protected than I
would have normally expected to see her
on the field.
>> All right, here comes Scollet crab XP
gained hand scene. One of those things
is significantly more relevant than the
other. Moonfall, Ride the Wind, Flash,
Fading Memories, Turn to Dust, and
Stacked Deck. Rico asked to see the
cards a little closer. Going to write
them down. And uh
>> having to lean over the deck once again
>> and read them upside down. Makes sense.
Despite being in Australia can be tough
when the cards are not the right way up.
Looks like Fading Memory is the card
that kind of jumps out to me. would be a
way to actually take out Aurelia by
giving her temporary but lot of
resources to commit for something that
may not work. Can't be defied for what
it's worth, but can be hit by not so
fast. I have bad news for Nice if that's
the line he takes.
>> I know that's not so fast in Rico's
hand. In fact, in the deck there's two
total.
>> A little bit more likely than not versus
that singular copy, but might be the
play you want to make. Stack deck going
to kick off the festivities though. See
what we get off the deck. There
>> is Jewel. Jewel. Take the jewel seems to
be a pretty key card for this deck. At
least this build of Diana. Certainly
something that Nice Boy values very
highly.
>> Running three.
>> Other deck has contracted. Yeah,
exactly.
>> You'd absolutely think so.
>> I don't know how many fridgels have been
run in other Diana decks, but certainly
the best finishing one is running the
maximum number of copies of that card as
it is going to be frigid jewel played.
Turn pass back and target peak once
again makes the gear look free. It is
not, but the refund you get certainly
can make it seem that way sometimes. As
Aurelia Fervent going to ready, get
herself a might and perhaps be ready to
fight at these battlefields. That's
usually her thing.
>> Seeing a couple of things in hand, that
defiant dance again because it is such
striking art. Very, very difficult not
to see as they're shuffling through
there. All
>> right, starting at this battlefield,
flash time. You can move up to two units
here. Going to move both.
>> So, respecting that Aurelia is likely
having a turn where she's going to want
to be pretty aggressive and take these
battlefields. Nice bones to protect both
his units.
Feel like that somewhat foils the plans
that Rico might have had here despite
Aurelia having free reign of these
locations.
Probably wanted to take out a unit or
two in the process.
>> Ideally,
you'd expect at the very least to get
the Raven Bloom student there. I feel
like if
tanking this long,
>> especially if he passes, get a little
bit of a tell that you don't have defy.
Could be a bluff. Could be sure. Could
be a double buff if he does have it.
That is the only card that would have
worked in that spot. So, not necessarily
a card he wants to counter, but he
considered it and passed it. I guess
either way, you could read it either
way.
>> There's that scuttle crab again.
>> Oh, and guess what? He drew
the card he may or may not have tried to
bluff just a moment ago. Defy off the
top thanks to scuttle crab joining this
very big grip of cards.
>> Seen a lot of trying to bait that one
out over the course of the weekend.
Sometimes successfully, sometimes not so
much. In this case, obviously having the
draw the very next turn and having it
come up. That's just very good fortune.
>> All right. Well, two points to three. No
way to get to the other battlefield. No
boots of swiftness. They've made their
way into Rico's hand just yet. So Aelia
going to be parked at the peak. Does
reset the runes as Diana once again
going to do the thing.
>> Mhm.
>> Use her resource predict and find a
spell. One on bottom. Flip one up. There
it is. Singularity
in from the sideboard. Deal six damage
to two units. Get a point for holding.
>> Oh, sorry. Get a point for conquering. T
of cross flash back to base.
And again, four points is fine. Don't
have to necessarily five for five.
Interesting to see Singularity here. It
can be tough
to pop Aurelia. Six damage might seem
like a lot for a four might unit, but
Aurelia gets above six very swiftly.
>> Absolutely. Although much more
unprotected than usual, as we said
before, without having a guardian angel,
given that I believe there are three in
that deck.
>> Yep. So, uh, going to go for it here.
Oh, have to play deflect as well.
>> Three runes recycled. Hits the crab.
Hits the Aelia. Going to try and make a
point of it here,
but all this going to be stopped by a
number of different things.
>> I think the most simple is going to be
Rico's answer. Not so fast.
>> Not so fast indeed.
>> So, your six energy and three runes for
my two and one rune. Seems like a good
trade for the Aelia player.
Passing on back. Carellia Fervent lives,
readies for a might, holds for a point.
Up to three we go,
but the not so fast baited out might
leave some room for that fading memories
on the following turn.
Tide Turner
>> Turner coming in
>> really been has been chosen. So she
moves on back and that does leave her
free to explore the other Targon's Peak
in the north.
>> All right, Dana is going to have a
showdown. Oh, never mind. We're out of
there. Ride the wind. Bullseye.
I would like to go over the other side.
The south peak seems much prettier than
the north peak.
>> Is he going to fall over there?
>> Oh gosh. All right.
>> Yeah, keep it simple.
>> Did not opt for the Diana
showdown trigger.
>> I'm pretty confident that works both
ways. Have a quick read of Diana Lunari
once again. When a showdown begins here,
you may pay one. If you do predict, then
reveal a top card. Yes. So, uh had the
option but wanted to save the room
perhaps
and on on awaken we are
>> with only five there and a decent sized
hand. We'll see.
>> Yeah, I think that time is going to be
part of the problem here.
>> A lot of lot of decisions you could make
even so even if you deal with Aelia
which you can do as your hand stance.
>> Mhm.
>> Assuming your opponent doesn't have an
answer for it.
Yeah,
>> stupify going to be the first thing.
Looking looking for a redraw here. So it
does not like the texture of the hand as
it is will make student better as well.
Frigid jewel also triggering. That's a
very big student and all of a sudden
five might feel like a lot to play with
this tie turner has been shrunk by one.
>> That student has definitely grown
significantly bigger there.
>> Awful lot of books being read. This tie
turner going to be assaulted
>> at the south by Raven Bloom students.
Big brain energy.
>> Big brain energy. So, not wanting to
tangle with the Aelia just yet. Star
cross here.
>> Starross coming in clutch there. We've
seen it a number of times.
>> Every time they point at the scar, the
star crust, I'm like, "God, that's so
smart. Why didn't I think of that?"
I mean, there's uh three Starrust in the
in the in the 48 and three scuttles in
the main for this earlier deck. And it's
looking real good.
>> Any opportunity to get that draw
trigger? taken it.
>> All right, so Ty Turner currently
holding on to this battlefield only four
points a piece. But again, at at this
juncture, RKU is going to be the player
to have the next opportunity to grab
points. So I think the question becomes,
do you want to just play this fading
memories and try and get rid of the
Aurelia because I think Aurelia is going
to be a problem for you all game long.
And when you give a unit temporary, it
deals with it pretty straight up. can't
be defied, can be not so fast, but it's
really tough to save Aelia from this
point if she's temporary because
everything else you try is like kind of
going to get foiled by a pump. You kind
of saw with Singularity that yes, it got
countered, but there are other ways for
that singularity to be dodged by Aelia.
>> It is a little less, you know,
comfortable to make those sort of moves
though when there are five runes up over
on Rico's side there. Whether or not you
want to try and bait something out
again, get them to use the runes up
before you try it, who's to say? Just
start cross Aelia and he's going to be
fading memories kind of narrowing them
down to not that many answers has to pay
deflect. So this is very costly and
again I don't even know how good this is
because there's still pressure as defy
does cost three. Wait that doesn't work
right.
Did I misread something?
Oh no it's number four. Wow. Defy is a
real good spell. Holy.
>> I thought defy was three or less. I know
it is four or less. and fading memories.
Unfortunately, very defiable, which cuts
the number of appropriate outs down by a
lot. And all of a sudden, that was a
very comfortable spot for EDG Rico.
And I feel like that is going to spell
the beginning of the end. Six points now
for Rico. Huge board, huge rune
advantage, huge amount of cards in hand.
>> And kind of had to go for it. Little bit
of a Hail Mary, but just one little
counter spell undid all that hard work.
It's what you have to contend with
dealing with Aurelia a lot of the time
here.
>> All right. Well, everything goes back
and that's going to be game. Nice knows
has nothing to do. Rico is going to be
in our finals. It'll be Aurelia versus
someone.
>> Someone. Well, if nothing else, I can
very humbly admit that my prediction
this time around was wrong. But it was
really cool to see Diana this far in to
the day. Not just this time, but also
having seen two in the top eight. I I
say that's pretty good still at
prediction. It may not be number one on
the day, but it's still making a
presence.
>> I think it was funny to consider that we
maybe on the weekend we didn't have
Aurelia predicted, but it might just be
Aurelia's time.
>> Look, I not in China. I'm still very
much feeling a little bit of regret
there because it was my gut instinct. I
even had it written down, crossed it
out, and decided, no, I think Diana. So,
look, if this is the time that I have
been proven wrong and I should have gone
with my gut instinct, look, Sydney
changes things up.
>> Look, almost all the legends we had
predicted as potential winners did make
the top eight and the one that missed
did not miss by much.
>> Exactly right. It was very good to see
so many different legends in the top
eight. Obviously, we did see quite a lot
of purple, but a lot of variety with the
legends themselves.
>> All right. Well, big smile there for
Rico 1997 and a winner's interview on
the way, I have to imagine. But, uh, you
know what? We can wax poetic about the
match up before we get there, I suppose.
>> It feels very Diana, actually. Waxing
moon, waxing poetic. You know, it kind
of works. I feel like I watched pretty
highle version of this matchup on stream
and I feel like I still don't understand
exactly what's supposed to happen.
>> Clearly Quay is a very key unit. Clearly
Aelia's tricks are I think better on
average
>> than Diana and she has more of them. So
even though both of them want to win in
showdowns, Aurelia is just kind of the
queen of that and kind of always has
been. There are definitely moments where
you can uh, you know, moonfall in, beat
Trixie, use all the different tools
available as Diana to try and win some
combats, but kind of as is often the
case in these games when you start
losing traction in showdowns, you tend
not to get it back.
>> It is tricky to turn that tight around.
And also, I know that I keep yapping
about it, but seeing Vex Apathetic do
some really solid work there. Every
single time we've seen it come up on
stream, it has made a presence whether
or not it's in addition to those scuttle
crabs or otherwise.
>> Yeah. funny in this match up cuz it kind
of just felt like it was just a full
might unit that was like
>> that was it.
>> That turned out to be kind of enough in
a lot of cases because again like a
really it just needs unit. We are going
to go on down to the lounge cuz this is
going to be waiting with our winner.
>> Thank you so much Pastry. We are here of
course with the winner Edg Rico 1997.
Congratulations firstly. You are making
it to the grand finals.
>> Thanks. Thanks everyone.
>> Now you are playing we were playing
Ireelia of course. Uh this is not your
first time playing Ireelia. As we all
know in China, you do get uh the you did
get the unleashed a bit earlier than the
rest of the world. How have you been
finding Ireelia in this unleashed meta?
>> Um I think Aurelia is a bit weak into
Aurora, but like uh very good against
every other decks cuz um the Aelia
champion is very strong. The deflect is
annoying and uh like no one is bigger
than her. And uh yeah.
>> Yeah. No, I can definitely see how that
deflect was annoying and how big Ireelia
was getting in those games. And uh
another question I have considering you
are coming over, you flew over from
China to play in this regional
qualifier, Sydney. How do you feel the
difference between the matters in China
versus in the Western world?
>> Okay. Um I think uh China has more
bougie placeman. The uh Master E. Yeah.
>> And uh well there's many around here
too. Um
yeah I yeah I think the top four legends
is almost the same but some small
difference of the order. So almost the
same I I guess. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So not too many differences
between the matter in China versus
Australia so far. Basically the same
except for just a bit of change.
>> Yeah. Just the order. Yeah. almost the
same.
>> Another question I have for you
concerning your Ireelia deck is your
cards you're running in your main deck
at the very least. I noticed you're only
running Starcross and Scuttle in that
main deck from Unleashed. Is there other
Ireelia decks have been running a few
more of those new Unleashed cards. Is
there a reason why you only chose those
two cards from Unleashed?
>> Oh, I mean I have to have some weapons
against Aurora and the Star Cross is the
best weapon. Yeah. So, I have to put put
this card into my deck. Yeah, that's the
reason.
>> Yeah, that makes complete sense. I mean,
Star Quest is one of the most commonly
used spells across this entire weekend,
so no surprises on that scuttle crab.
Now, your match in the grand final, you
will be versing an Aurora Civer. How do
you feel about that?
>> Well, I just hate that matchup. Also,
I'm on the job, I guess, because he has
the first seat. So, should be very
tough, but I'll fight for it.
>> Yeah. Um, do you think you'll be able to
win out the entire day today?
>> Well, one match left, and I think I'm
confident.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Well, I'm not surprised you're
confident. You have made it here all the
way to the grand finals. And if you
aren't lucky, you you definitely want to
be confident in in of yourself because
this is the final match of the day.
you've been grinding through these last
two days, of course, you know, 8 hours
each, sorry, 12 hours each day and it's
a very long day. You said earlier in our
um chat before your your brain's a
little bit um mush after the day is
coming through, is there anything you're
going to do before you go into your
grand finals to revive yourself?
>> Well, maybe eat some snacks, drink some
water.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Keep keep me in a good shape and
uh go to the finals.
>> Yeah. Well, that sounds great. We won't
have to wait long because we will be
seeing of course Rico in the grand
finals shortly. We'll head over back to
the castle to break more the g break the
game down more.
Well, thank you so much. That concludes
our top four coverage for now cuz the
finals are actually ready relatively
shortly after this. And we can reveal to
the people what it is going to be. We
already know one side of the match up is
of course going to be Aelia. But the
other side it was Vex versus Civer and
who triumphed but Civer.
>> Yep. 2-1 on that one. Very, very
interesting to see that sold out's
confidence clearly has still continuing
there. Wonder how that will go coming
into the grand final there.
>> There is a long running phase phrase in
card games that many people live by. And
it is better to be lucky than good.
>> But the thing they don't tell you is in
order to win a tournament, you must be
both lucky and good.
>> That is true. And they've had favorable
draws on that Aurora all tournament. So
when does that run out? The question is,
will it last through to the end of the
grand final or not? Or will Aurelia
actually make it to number one in
Sydney?
>> We'll see how much work that main deck
adapt can do cuz we're going to a break
and when we return, it is time for
AUSI's grand finals.
>> We are here at the Sydney RQ. I am
joined by the wonderful base deck
department. Now, you are known for being
very good at deck building. How are you
taking that into Riftbound? I'm trying
really hard and failing really badly
because the deck building is quite
different. Uh, but I'm learning a lot.
So, it's good. It's helping me in other
things that I do because I'm learning a
lot and I haven't learned a lot in a
whole long time. So, it's good.
>> So, the deck that you're currently
running, how are you feeling about your
your chances for the weekend?
>> Uh, it's the only deck I've played. So,
I've only played Azir. Uh, I built him
cuz I saw he did quite well in China.
I'm feeling okay, but I'm still pretty
new to Riftbound, so I'm expecting to
maybe get like middling results,
probably crash out and burn and then
quit early, but I'm hoping I do well.
>> Okay, so obviously the unleash set only
just released. Did that change how you
approached this weekend?
>> Uh, yeah, a lot. Some decks got a lot
stronger. Aurora,
uh, I there's a lot of cards for my
deck, a lot more card draw that Unleash
brings to Azia, which is really cool cuz
that was a big weakness. So, I'm I'm I'm
really happy with what Unleash brought
to the meta as a whole.
>> So, basically what I'm hearing is that
even if you crash and burn, you're
feeling pretty good about it anyway and
you're having a good time.
>> Yeah, that's that's exactly what I'm
saying.
>> Awesome. Well, best of luck for the
weekend. We'll see how it goes.
>> We are down here at the Sydney ARU. I am
joined by Briefcase. You have flown here
for the event. How are you feeling about
your chances? Uh, I'm playing against a
friend, uh, Zach, and I think it's
really good so far because I'm not
competing in the main event. However, I
think I can beat him.
>> Well, I I have some insider knowledge
that he is very new, so I feel like you
maybe are taking advantage a little bit.
>> Quite possibly. Quite possibly. I did
also try to rope him into the the draft
itself. So, I did have ulterior motives
here.
>> So, obviously, the unleash set only just
came out. How are you feeling about the
new champions? Um, three of my favorite
champions in League of Legends actually
came out this set. Um, Jin, Lilia, and
Pike. I actually really love them in the
game itself. So great so far. I just
haven't been able to play them that much
yet. I'm like looking to do some more in
their decks.
>> Which one do you reckon you'll build
first?
>> Uh, I've already made Lilia. That's what
Jess is playing. Uh, I want to put my
hands on it a bit more, but I think I
really like the tokens.
>> Well, we'll see how the rest of the
weekend goes.
We are here down at the Sydney RQ. I am
joined by Fasby and we are currently in
the midst of a draft. Is that correct?
It absolutely is. You were playing
draft. And how is that going for you so
far? Is this the first time you've
drafted?
>> Um, it's not the first time I've
drafted, but it is we're just playing a
very special trios version. So, it's
something that's never really been
played before. Um, but so, but we're
still in the draft phase.
>> Okay. So, what are you kind of
gravitating towards at the moment? I'm
playing uh a predominantly yellow deck
at the moment with a lot of soldiers.
I've got Azir and um yeah, I'm looking
forward to just getting a lot of units
out.
>> So, do you like your chances so far
given the rest of the people at the
table?
>> Absolutely not. No, I'm definitely one
of the beginners, but uh I every game
that I get to play, I learn something
new and it's just actually really really
fun.
>> So, maybe next time we're in Sydney,
you'll be in the main event then.
>> I I mean, I'd love to have that
experience at least once. Yeah. Let's
see what see what I can take.
>> Fingers crossed. So, we'll see how you
go. Thank you so much.
>> Have you been feeling moody lately? Are
you all so tired of conquering for your
points all the time? Do you not want to
play a normie deck like the others? Then
we got the deck just for you. Vex
Gloomist appears in Unleashed, a legend
that massively profits from holding
battlefields. Stop your opponent from
ambushing or accelerating consistently
as early as turn two with Vex apathetic
as your chosen champion unit. Tell your
opponents to back off by stunning their
units when they try to conquer. Play
your shadow ready into battlefields to
immediately use its ability on the
opposing turn. Vex can rely on so many
different defensive tools that the calm
and chaos domain already have. Use
guardian angel and zona's hourglass to
protect your units from dying. Not so
fast and defy to counter opposing spells
and deny their tempo. But also new
defensive cards can be found in unleash
like existential dread or the mutated
Mouser. But in the Shadow Isles, a
monster lurks supporting Vex, giving her
near unlimited defensive and offensive
possibilities. Enter Vimmore. The spider
god has ambush, meaning it can be played
offensive and defensively. with this
powerful eight mighty jumps into a
battlefield that you are attacking and
crushes any unit smaller than it without
taking a single hit. If your opponents
doesn't manage to push it out of a
battlefield, an additional draw for
holding is a free bonus. With these
cards in your deck, you're going to be
able to keep all the others away from
your battlefields. Keep holding, riff
bounders.
We're here at the Sydney Rift and
Regional Qualifier. I'm Patri. I'm here
with Randy, one of the members of the
legendary team of traveling plays that
seems to keep doing pretty well at RQs,
but although haven't had maybe the best
luck lately.
>> Hey, it's okay. Uh my friend won last
week. I mean last week, 3 weeks ago. So
that's pretty good already. Happy about
that.
>> So when did you get in?
>> Uh got in yesterday morning. Flew in
from Shanghai, so not too jet lag.
That's a good thing.
>> So you're not playing in the preq. You
already have a buy. You've been farming
tickets with your friends. How you
feeling about tomorrow?
>> Uh I'm feeling pretty good. Pretty
solid. Uh bring a spicy deck for
tomorrow. So, we'll see.
>> Said this last time, bring a spicy deck
and uh it maybe worked out not how you
intended. Is this uh better than your
last spicy brew?
>> Uh yeah, it is. It is. It is. It is. It
is.
>> What are you playing domains you've
never registered before at an RQ?
>> Um I think I registered every single
domain except green so far like calm.
So, no, I'm not. I I can be, but um I
haven't
topped with either in EU or NA. So, I'll
say that. Is it a legend you've played
before?
>> I have not played that legend before
either.
>> Is it a new legend?
>> Um, it's not a new legend. It's not a
new legend. It's a set to one. So,
>> how are you feeling about Unleashed in
general, especially given how close it's
been since the release of the set?
>> Uh, I'm feeling pretty good. Been
testing Unleash since before Atlanta
with like uh since it's released in uh I
mean since the spoiler got out. So, I'm
feeling pretty good about that. Um,
we'll see how it goes, but I'm feeling
pretty this weekend is looking pretty
good for for us.
>> And of course, you have lots of
different teammates. You guys usually
register different decks. Is that
happening again?
>> Um, so I have two other friends are who
are on the same deck as I am, but Alan
and Priest are also registering
different decks. So, all three of us are
going to be on different decks. Yeah.
>> What a surprise. All right. Well, good
luck. Hope you have a good tournament.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Have a good
weekend as well.
>> I'm here at the Sydney RQ with the one
and only
Sydney on Wednesday. How's your trip to
Australia been so far?
>> I'm loving it so far. It's my first time
in Sydney. Um, been having good food.
Uh, I like the weather and uh, yeah,
everything's upside down, but that
that's kind of weird, I guess.
>> Did you do anything fun?
>> Uh, yeah, we went to the zoo. Uh, we met
up with Ali Drazzi, too. So, that was
fun. He was just randomly there. Uh, but
yeah, so all the team went to the zoo
and the Tanga, I think. I think that's
how you say it. Yeah, that one that was
really cool. One of the best zoos I've
ever been to. So, that was sweet. And
other than that, just jamming.
>> So, Challenger TCD has done pretty well
at the regional qualify level, I would
say. How many of you traveled here for
this event?
>> Uh, it's just three of us this time.
Australia is very far obviously. Um, so
we've got uh Colin, me and Daniel.
Obviously Colin and Daniel uh some of
our best performers and then me, you
know, the best of guy. So or the Aurora
guy. Yeah.
>> All right. So what's the plan this
event? Are we going back for best of or
are we playing something else?
>> Uh I will be playing Volar tomorrow in
the main again. I think he got a lot of
really good tools in set three, not just
Elder Dragon. I actually think Rengar 5
is insane for that deck. So yeah,
>> obviously you played a lot of Aurora.
There's a lot of chatter about Aurora.
How are you feeling about its position
in this metag game?
>> Uh, I think it's positioned pretty well.
I do think purple Aurora is a little bit
too allin still. I think you you have
some really bad matchups because of
that, but obviously when the deck does
what it's supposed to do, can still be
really oppressive. Can still crush uh
almost any deck. But I do think like
some of the other decks that play a
little bit better without Aurora, like
Poppy, uh, Master Yi, and Volibar are
actually really well positioned.
>> We've had a pretty good tournament so
far, winning some best offs. How have
you met your chances this weekend?
>> Uh, I feel like I'm going to take it
home again.
>> Best of luck. Have a good tournament.
Thanks brother.
>> The regional qualifier Sydney grand
finals is finally upon us. It is the
moment. The final match of the day. The
final match of this qualifier. Whoever
wins this match will become the
champions. After two grueling days of
the main event, we are finally here with
the best of the best at the first
regional qualifier in the Southern
Hemisphere. Ricey, I'm excited for this
one.
>> I'm super excited as well, Logan,
because this is a matchup that I'm sure
many people will be talking about once
it's concluded. It's going to be Civa
Aurora in the hands of sold out versus
an Ireelia in the hands of Rico. Yeah,
both very capable, very competent pilots
of both of these decks here. And no
matter which legend wins here tonight,
they will be a first time winner for
that legend in an RQ.
>> That's actually pretty exciting. I also
love, as we've been talking about it
multiple times already, the versatility,
the variety that Rift has in the meta.
We saw six different legends in the top
eight. And now, as you mentioned, Gelia
and Ca potentially could be taking it
all out. But let's have a look at the
players. They are coming out on stage,
showing up here in the grand finals.
>> Here we see sold out making his way to
the stage. The Civer Aurora player,
Ricey, fighting his way through a very
contested field coming into this top
eight as the number one seed.
>> Number one seed. Wasn't undefeated
though. Did drop one game. So 12 and
one, but as you said, he leaped the
number one seed.
>> Yeah, he did beat a Vex in that
semifinal to earn that position here in
the grand final.
>> Now, of course, we have EDG Rico coming
all the way from China. So, we get to
see this East versus West sort of
situation in the grand finals here in
Sydney.
>> Yeah, the different metas will be
playing out here. Sold out USA and then
as you said, Rico from China. So it will
be those east verse west meta vibes here
tonight as well in this grand final
matchup.
>> Now of course coming in on the first
seed sold out will get to choose whether
he wants to go first or second. Now
remember key point of course this is an
Aurora Civer.
>> Yeah we do love a good Aurora Civer
proving to be the better Aurora deck
here at the RQ in Sydney. Obviously we
did see Misfortune. We saw some Fiora.
You saw some Poppy, but they did not go
the distance. And this is the best
Aurelia at the Sydney RQ here on your
screen right now with EDG, Rico, Ry. I
mean, yeah, these are the best of the
best of their legends right now. Aelia,
of course, bettering out from the other
Ireelia that did make that top eight.
But let's have a look at their deck.
This is sold out deckless running that
Civer and of course Keely, we got to
note those three dazzling auroras.
always the three set of those dazzling
auroras. But the tech that Sold Out has
worked with here, it's all of that card
draw, that filtering, getting him that
advantage, getting him that consistency,
able to find those answers into that
early tempo that opposing decks want to
bring, able to gust away and preventing
those conquers, sabotage to remove those
critical components into his Aurora and
the Luna Boon to draw even more. One
thing he was mentioning in that
interview is he says he's gotten pretty
decent card draws, which is one reason
why he's gotten here, but also just I
think the tech as you mentioned really
help get into that card draw as well.
Most of his lots of his spells here do
help with that card draw. Of course, you
got stacked deck and you mentioned so
many others as well. Luna Boom, it
really helps bring this civer the the
cards that they need.
>> Yeah, that synergy is there for that
consistency. And as our fellow caster
said, pastry time goes, you need to be
lucky. You need to be good. But this guy
is also confident. He has mentioned so
many times that his confidence is very,
very high. And he has every reason to
be. He's obviously found himself in this
grand final matchup against EDG Rico
to use his full handle.
>> Full handle that it is. And when we were
talking to Rico just before, he was also
talking about his confidence levels. He
is confident. He thinks he could win,
but he is actually not as confident
versus an Aurora. And unfortunately in
this grand finals, he is versing an
Aurora. So this may be a matchup where
it might be difficult for the Civer.
Yeah, but here's something you pointed
out as well that Adapatron in the main
board. When I conquer, you may kill a
gear if you do buff me. So, he is ready
for these Aurora matchups. And I have to
imagine that there's some sideboard
tech, those not so fast, able to answer
that playability from the Elder Dragon
when it inevitably arrives. He did
mention as well in that interview that
that starrust is needed with all the
Aurora decks. So, as he said, it might
be really good against that Elder Dragon
and preventing the Elder Dragon from
wrecking too much havoc on the Aurelas.
>> Yeah, wreaking havoc is exactly what an
Elder Dragon wants to do, both here in
Riftbound and on the rift. But that not
so fast fantastic answer that star
crossed even better able to bounce it
back to hand and you really don't want
to have to pay that 12 energy for power
for an elder dragon being hard cast from
hand ricey you don't want to do it but
we did see sodal do it in both games we
saw earlier in the quarterfinals so it
can be done especially in the late game
but as you said it's not the most
desired player you want to rely on the
Aurora of course and getting the best
card draw possible Yeah, we did get a
look obviously at their battlefields
here too. That traditional aspirin's
climb being featured with sold out.
Every Aurora player worth their salt
runs that one. It buys them that extra
victory point condition a little bit
more time in the game. It removes the
importance of even numbered victory
points and places it instead on those
odds. As Ricey, we are in to game one of
our grand final best of three match here
to decide who will take the regional
qualifier. Sydney 2026.
>> It's going to be a good match. It's
going to be a big match between these
two absolute legends. Of course, looking
at those battlefields, Abandon Hole is
the battlefield of choice for Rico. No
surprises there with how strong this
battlefield is for an Ireelia. Sigil of
the Storm. I'm not too surprised about
either being the first uh one picked
because Sigil of the Storm will be great
against the Sireellia.
>> Yeah, it definitely is a fantastic
deterrent. It reads when you conquer
here, recycle one of your runes. So,
it's not something you want to be doing.
And Sold out off to a great start here,
playing that mobilize, getting that
extra ramp, really putting the pressure
onto Rico early.
>> I really want to see what's in Sold
Out's hands because then we can see how
well he drew so far in that first draw.
But Rico, it's his turn. Out comes that
scuttle crab. He was talking about how
important this scuttle crab is. It feels
really meta and maybe even a must-h have
card in K.
>> Yeah, for all of our meta predictions. I
don't think any of us actually put down
the scuttle crab, but it has proven an
allstar. It's in almost every single
calm deck, able to give you so much
intel here.
>> Out comes the stack deck. Rico able to
look at those top three cards. Can't see
them ourselves, but he has picked one
considering actually no, he hasn't. He
has a lot to think about.
>> Yeah, he's keeping his cards close to
his chest, literally. Discipline on
guard. Not so fast there. I just picked
up a tide turner as well appears to be
the pick from that stack deck. Ricey, I
do like this pick.
>> I do like the tide turner. You can play
it a couple of different ways. You can
play it hidden. You can play it from
hand as well. But when you play it, that
tie turner will allow you to switch
places with another unit.
>> Yeah. Offers the shuffle over to sold
out. Sold out does decline. Seeing Rico
there do that shuffle. That is his right
in these high OPL events. We do see that
last rights and stack deck in the hand
of sold out though.
>> I mean yes out now doing that stacked
deck as well as of course everyone knows
you want that Aurora by turn three or
four otherwise things start getting a
little bit too difficult for that Aurora
to climb up.
>> Yeah, Aurora being a really late game
deck. You obviously oh the catalyst of
AON here getting some serious ramp
online.
>> Serious ramp indeed. How many do you
need for Aurora? And how much further
does Soda need to go right now though?
Scuttle crab is going in onto Abandoned
Hull. Able to get that conquer point
quite easily.
>> Yeah, Aurora is that 9 and2 power there.
So, we'll have to recycle a two-way.
Currently sitting on seven is sold out.
EDG Rico though currently on those five
runes considering his options after
conquering that battlefield as you so
rightly called there.
>> Up goes the rain bringing him now to
seven as you called out. Does he have
the aurora? I do see a gust in hand. I
see a scrier's bloom. I also see a
treasure as well. There lots of options,
but it is going to be of course the
treasure being played.
>> Yeah, the treasure trove there being
paid. You are able to bounce that one
back to your hand. When it leaves the
battlefield, you're actually able to
draw one and channel one rune exhausted
two. You can recycle the rune, exhaust
it, and kill this, which is exactly what
appears to have happened. There is that
exhausted gold token from that Civer
legend.
I'm pretty sure that's either the prize
or even the best of civer.
I mean, sold out is really good at this
civer right now in this tournament as
well. But that is a fantastic of course
civer on the board and using that using
that legend to get that extra gold means
that treasure trove didn't feel that
painful at all.
>> I really do like the scribes bloom. This
is a card that sold out called out as
potentially even more valuable than that
stacked deck. It does enter exhausted,
but you're able to predict to and draw
off the back of it, which is fantastic
filtering. It's excellent control. And
this is how Sold Out is able to have
more answers often than not into all of
his opponents. It's how he's found
himself here at 14 and one.
>> He didn't play the Aurora, which in my
mind means maybe he doesn't have it in
hand. He's still trying to search for
it, find it. And for Aurora players,
they need to find that Aurora as soon as
they can. Now it's Io's turn. Ireelia is
ready. Has that plus one could go in for
another conquer onto Sigil of the Storm,
but remember when you conquer. Yeah,
when you conquer on that Sigil of the
Storm, you do recycle one rune. So, it
is a little bit punishing. Aurelia, as
you say, on that five M. And we're
taking a quick look as that stack deck
comes down. I have to imagine Rico
though has some protection pieces
available.
>> Very very important unit just got picked
up. That was the adaptorron you were
talking about earlier. Not sure how many
Rico was running in their sideboard. I
do see a second one. So he might have
two in this deck right now. There's also
a disarming rake in that sideboard too.
So lots of options to deal with the AOA
which isn't even out yet.
>> I really do like though the indexing
heavily into the units that kill gear
because there are less answers available
for units than there are spells.
countering
rake.
Now that safety net does Rico, so this
is an excellent response. We do see the
discipline. We also have the adapter.
Rico does have a full hand. He's
doubtlessly going to be trying to double
conquer here with this Aurelia. So
probably looking for those boots of
swiftness to get that ganking online.
Ganking online is going to be great for
the Ireelia of course to be able to try
and get the other other battlefield, the
Sigil of the Storm, but you got to be
careful. Remember, you will damp
yourself slightly, but it might be worth
it. You want to get those uh the victory
points because otherwise you're not
going to be able to win.
>> Yeah, absolutely. You need to get those
victory points to take these games. We
do have the Aurora style as we've
mentioned. It's a late game deck. Rico
needs to be scoring points hard and fast
and early here to put the pressure onto
sold out. We see the discipline that
could be that might pump that he'll need
with the card draw to find the answers.
But like you so rightly called Ricey. I
have to think Sold Out just doesn't have
that Aurora right now. He does have a
total of nine runes. Maybe he's waiting
to play it next turn when he'll have
some extra runes up to maybe sabotage,
draw something out of the hand and play
it a little bit safer.
>> I like that you pointed out the sabotage
because Sold Out does love running a lot
of sabotage. Just three. In fact, we
still haven't seen that either.
Sabotage, you get to choose your
opponent, reveal all the cards, and
remove a nonunit card from. And when
you're versing an Ireelia, they're going
to have a lot of non-unit cards, but
Keely, we talked about the Adapatron.
That adapaton is a unit.
>> Yeah, absolutely. It lands on that base
and that threat is on the board. We get
a quick little peak there. We do see
some mobilizers for sold out too, which
right now I don't think he really wants
to be ramping. I think he wants to be
drawing cards. He wants to be digging
for that Aurora. The longer it takes for
him to find this Aurora, the longer it
takes for him to play it, the better
chance Rico stands to win this game one
here. I think Rico is taking a gamble
here as well. Playing it now so that he
can maybe conquer on the next turn
because he's thinking if there was an
Aurora in the hand. I didn't see it. Did
you see it?
>> I did not see an Aurora there. This
could be a potential disaster for Sold
Out. We do know through his main deck
that he runs that triple Elder and that
mind spplitter does have some
sideboarding options here. He may have
needed to get some more mind splits to
get that kind of mid-range gameplay
going in case he misses the Aurora, but
he has been so consistent so far.
>> 1 2 3 recycling one bringing out the
Civer. Still no Aurora, but gets another
gold from recycling that room.
>> Yeah, that Civer legend ability so so
valuable here to prevent any D ramp,
which is why she is the preferred legend
for Aurora over that misfortune. We do
see several runes up in the hand of sold
out. I keep saying hand on the board of
sold out. Rico readies up. The play is
on him. Draws his card. He does have a
healthy hand and a ride the wind here
too. Ricey definitely has that mobility
to be able to save his units to be able
to save Aurelia Fervent.
>> Defy in hand as well. I'm pretty sure I
saw which means if the sabotage does get
played, I mean Defy is available.
>> Yeah, Defy is such a strong counter
spell here. at that ride the wind two
and one move a friendly unit and ready
it it gives two might over to Aurelia
further
>> in goes that scuttle crab going in for
that conquer point on the abandoned hoe
I don't know if soda has anything to
answer this right now and does move back
as well so into safety in case something
else happens such as that civ
>> right now though this is not looking
good for sold out isn't opting to gust
so doesn't have that in hand either does
have those six runes
potentially trying to bluff out of these
players here though. Rice,
>> I don't know what those buffs could be.
I thought he was potentially going to be
using Ride the Wind, but those look like
more runes than than one would expect.
He's still considering his options. He
has so many options and so many runes.
>> Yeah, that appears to be eight runes up
and available for Rico as he just passed
now. Eight runes up. He has confidence
here. That speaks to me of the actions
on you sold out. You need to make me
play into you right now because I have
all of the advantage.
>> I think as well Rico leaving that
scuttle crab on the board on the
battlefield. He doesn't care if the poor
little scuttle crab dies. He gets to see
what sold out has ensur
there. Am I screwed yet?
>> That public information is so so
important. And that is what Scuttle Cap
does here. Sold out. There it is.
Finally,
>> out comes that Aurora. Going to be using
those two gold of course, which makes
things a little bit less demand before
this Civer seven runes exhausted to pay
for it, of course. But finally, Sold out
has found that Aurora, but we always
hear from the Aurora players. They want
it on turn three or four. Is this too
late? Well, right now, Rico currently on
those five victory points. Sold out yet
to even get to the one. And we know Rico
even has an answer on board here with
that adapter. Sold out. has to know that
Rico's got even more answers available
to him. Needs to play the slow game.
>> In goes the server to contest abandon
hoe where that scuttle crab is trying to
get rid of it. We'll have to know that
he will reveal his hand in response of
course, but Rico actually wants to
respond to this. Thinking about using
two runes.
>> Definitely considering it here. Doing
the math how many runes he has available
with all the options in hand. We know he
has so many answers. He even has his own
ride the winds. We think he has that
discipline. We think he has a defy in
hand. Obviously, Defy not able to do
anything into the likes of Super, but a
good discipline here could force a
response maybe just for that card draw.
But dare I say, he'd almost be happy for
this scuttle crab to die to get the info
on what is in Sold Out's hand.
>> We can see in Rico's hand, a lot of
those spells are in fact only just one
or two cost really, really cheap. So
Rego could pump as much as he wants into
the sky, but as you as you said, is that
what he wants? He's thinking about it
quite a lot.
>> What I am seeing here though, Ricey, is
a not so fast. So I almost feel like
Sold Out could actually be happy to let
this elder dragon come out and land and
just counter that ability, saving his
units here.
>> Oh, I thought he was about to do it.
He's still thinking. Oh, okay.
He's counting. That's a good way of
counting. I like this.
>> He's calculating his options. He's
making sure he holds up enough runes for
everything that he wants to do. He's
mapping out the plays in his head. And
doing this, he's helping visualize the
maths with the runes up and available.
And as you said, this is very low to the
ground hand. Nothing in here costs more
than two energy right now. Ricey,
>> he may be considering how can I get rid
of the civer right now. I mean, he has
that right there when he could bring in
maybe that I rally. Is that going to be
enough might to be able to take down
that civer?
>> Well, I mean, if you just ride the wind
that Aurelia in, it gets that plus two
might from choosing her and readying
her. So, that might will overcome that
civer as it stands on that battlefield.
Oh,
it is the wind.
But wait,
>> wait. I missed I misunderstood. He's not
going after the server. He's riding the
wind. The Adaptron honored to siege of
the storm. He wants to get that conquer
point because remember when Adapatron
conquers it can kill a gear.
>> Yeah, he is certainly doing his absolute
best here to prevent that Aurora from
even being able to get one single
trigger. So really heads up play here.
This is why he was taking so much time
to think about what he wanted to do.
wanted to gust it, but unfortunately the
discipline stops it because Gust is only
usable against smaller might units.
>> Yeah, three might or less. The Gust is
going to repel that adapter, which is
why that discipline was forced out. That
scuttle crab dying, giving that
information over to Rico here. And the
Aurora in the trash. It never got to
fire off.
>> Never got to fire off. And those two
goats that he used to pay for the are
out of the game as well. He does have a
lot of runes though, so if he manages to
fight another one, it will be great. He
does run three oras, but I mean, six
points. EDG Rico is so close to taking
this game.
>> Yeah, it looks like that's going to be
it. He's conceded. He just wanted to see
the top of his deck. Didn't draw the
answer. And EDG Rico takes this game one
of this grand final best of three here
at the regional qualified Sydney 2026.
EDG Rico on that Ielia who wasn't the
most confident going into a COA does win
game one that is key and now that he's
won game one he does have that
sideboard. Yeah, absolutely. There will
be some sideboarding going on here.
Obviously, Rico though, he had the read,
he had the play, he knew that he could
potentially go into this Aurora matchup.
He brought plenty of gear kill that
disarming rake, that adaptatron as you
so rightly called out. I mean, sold out.
He waited or he drew that Aurora a
little late and he thought, "Ah, maybe I
can get a trigger here. Maybe I can get
an elder down." But Rico so heads up
riding the wind there to get the
adapatron conquer and just kill it
before it gets the trigger.
>> It was absolutely fantastic play. And of
course that is what makes ride the wind
is so strong. Being able to move a unit
and playing on action means you can play
it in your enemy unit enemy players turn
as well during a showdown. So once that
showdown started he was like this is my
chance. This is my chance to bring
Adapatron onto that battlefield to
conquer.
>> And that's exactly it. The silver moved
in, began that showdown, allowed the
opportunity for that ride, the wind to
be played and take out that Aurora. You
love to see the strategy going on here.
I mean, I was looking at it and I was
seeing, oh, the civer, the scuttle crab,
maybe move the ride the wind with the
Aurelia onto that one. I didn't even see
the Adaptatron to that top side
battlefield.
>> That's why we're here and not there. Um
but and also it's been a 12-hour day. We
are missing of course some of those
amazing players. But that's why these
guys, these talented legends are here.
They have been grinding nearly 24 hours
across this weekend. If they had to buy
in round one, less but
>> 22 and 1/2.
>> 22 and 1/2. But that's still a lot of
hours. Reminding of course us about sold
out main deck. We do see those three
elder dragons, that one mind spplitter,
but Healey, that Aurora, the three
Auroras did not get seen until quite
later to the game.
>> Yeah, from what's gone to a really
consistent Aurora deck, I want to say
unfortunately this game one, it just
took a little too long to come online.
It took a little too long to find that
Aurora up into this Aurelia of Rico. And
he had the tools, he had that scrier's
bloom, he had the mobiliz, the catalyst
of aons to ramp himself into it. So he
was forced to sort of play that civer
mercenary out and uh it will be
interesting to see what sort of
sideboard tech we see as you said that
fading memories as well able to remove
a unit of battlefield or a gear. Yeah, I
was having a look at sold out sideboard
has some uh some gear in as in that
sideboard to deal with other gear but
I'm not sure how useful that's going to
be against this. I mean I really does
run a lot of gear. It is possible. Um,
on top of that though, he has two more
mind spplitters in that sideboard. I
think that might be potentially what he
wants to use as well because he will be
able to reduce Rico's hand,
>> but he also needs to bring some more
mid-range. He needs to be able to
actually play some units to get some
board presence. So, those minds
spplitters could be very good for that.
They're seven energy to power. So, you
get to shred the hand and have some
presence on the battlefield. Axon is
fantastic tech into gear. You are able
to steal your opponent's gear and equip
it to your own if you do pay that
additional cost here. But it wasn't the
gear from Aurelia that won that game. It
was that ride the wind that got him over
the line after holding these uncontested
battlefields for so long here.
>> And indeed it it was also feeling like
sold out just kind of didn't get the
right draw. But also Rico played that
extremely well with that adapron with
that ride the wind. That is exactly how
you want to deal with the Aurora when it
comes out and that Aurora just
completely nullified.
>> Yeah, it's not often you see an Aurora
played and it doesn't get a single
trigger, but that was the case here as
we do see sunken temple locked in as the
battlefield for Rico. We have seen
sunken temple a couple of times here
this weekend and it's the one where when
you conquer it with one or more mighty
units, you may pay one energy to draw
one. So really indexing into that card
advantage that Aurelia is already so
good at especially with those Stellicorn
Herders
>> and it's there is a lot in an Aurelia de
Aelia deck to be able to make units
mighty and so of course being able to
conquer with mighty is going to be quite
easy to get those card draws.
>> Yeah, and especially when it's going to
be so uncontested in that early game too
Ry with that Aurora being that late game
deck that we all know it to be before it
comes online. Aurelia will be able to
take advantage of the absence of these
units on the opposing battlefields and
conquer up. So it will be a race to the
victory here, but I really favor the
Aurelia to get off the mark first.
>> Of course, Sold Out has two battlefields
to choose from. He is going to be
choosing Aspirants Climb. A very, as we
say, typical
battlefield that Aurorex love to play.
He is going to be going uh first still
but has of course used that mobilize
immediately.
>> Yeah, mobilize helping ramp up. So goes
first, mobilizes up to that three. Rico
second with the three runes ready there
too.
Can you already feel the tension, Ricey?
>> Yes, I can. I can definitely feel it.
These two players mean Rico is one up.
All he needs to do is just close out
this next game and he is the champion of
Sydney regional finals.
>> That's it. Rico plays that scuttle crab,
draws the one card, getting more card
advantage, able to have more options,
more answers into whatever it is that
TSS sold out wants to do.
>> I saw it. Is that That's definitely an
Aurora. Did I see two Auroras in his
hand? Sold out. Managed to draw into an
Aurora quite quickly. Now all he needs
to do is just get the runes for it. Rico
though that's got to grab going in going
to go for that Asparus climb.
>> Yep. Aspirin's climb conquers getting
one victory point here. Sold out though.
Sitting with that dazzling Aurora in
hand. Must be feeling a little bit more
confident. He did pass the turn straight
back to Rico.
>> And before he did, of course, he does
play that Stellorn Herder. Such an
important unit for Anelia. But of
course, sold out is going to be playing
that scrier's bloom.
>> Yeah. So, we hit the Luna Boon there
onto that Elder Dragon. Elder Dragon is
actually a fantastic target for Lunaboon
in these Aurora decks, especially if you
draw into it early because you don't
want it in hand. You don't want to have
to hard cast that. So, an excellent
target draws two off the back of that.
Hopefully, he's going to be able to find
that last rights to get it back into his
deck and hit it with that Aurora stack
deck. getting some extra filtering going
on, some more information, and that
ideal cards that he wants here. But sold
out in a much better position already
than he was in game one.
>> There's the Scrier and the Mobilize
being used as well. Going to be able to
keep sold out even ramping up further.
Sky Bloom enters exhausted, but when you
kill it in the next turn potentially,
you get to predict two and draw one and
gain experience, but I don't know how
important that is for this deck, which
is he mentioned, as he said earlier,
it's really, really good. Potentially
more than a stack deck.
>> Yeah, but being able to use a stack deck
into a scrib's bloom just speaks of so
much control, so much consistency, which
he's built into this deck. Sold out
currently on those eight runes. Next
turn, he will be able to drop that
Aurora. Rico though starting to pull
ahead on victory points.
>> Three points right now brings in that
Selkon Herder of course gets also that
point from the hold. And don't forget
when Celon Herder moves they can draw
one card.
>> Yeah, increasing the card advantage.
That is a healthy size hand. And I think
I spy that adapt one more time here.
Ricey. So he must be considering the
timing of the play on this one. Does he
want to play it out now? But if that
Aurora comes down and an elder lands and
he doesn't have a ride the wind, he may
not be able to answer it. Timing is
everything here.
>> See, not so fast. That can counter the
elder dragon. I did see a defy, but that
does only of course counter spells that
are a little bit less costly.
>> Yeah, we also see that tide turner able
to switch places with units sold out.
Patiently waiting for Rico to decide on
what actions he wants to take here. A
four exhaust, four cost potentially. Is
that that Adapatron? It is indeed. Now
remember when this Adapatron conquers it
can kill a gear. An absolute nightmare
for an Aurora deck.
>> Yeah, frankly Rico probably doesn't even
worry about the buff. me obviously it's
a nice little side poke but putting that
pressure on to sold out making him think
do I want to play this Aurora now or do
I have a way to remove that adapter
before the Aurora lands because we don't
have full intel on every card in Rico's
but we saw it before if there's a ride
the wind he can just action speed it
onto a battlefield conquer and
annihilate it
>> the tension is two is two
>> there's at least one
>> I feel Like that might be too. I I can't
tell from this angle easily, but one of
them is going to go out. It might have
to get sacrificed without Adapatron. I
don't remember seeing ride the winds
though on Rico, but either way, there is
no combat happening just yet. So, no
ride the wind just yet. So, potentially
we'll be able to get at least one of
those units out.
>> Yeah, sold out. Like we learned from his
mistake in game one. Just go straight to
the endstep. Gets his trigger here. Does
not want to let that adapter conquer in.
We see the stacks, the mobiliz, the
flurries sabotage.
>> Another Aurora. My splitter though is
the one that is going to be played,
which means Rico gets to see Well, okay.
He's going to be able to see what got
>> passed on, what got revealed, but sold
out. We'll also get to see Rico's hand.
>> Yeah, exactly. This is exactly what Alan
was doing as well. He was taking all of
that publicly available information from
that reveal off of the Aurora and make
notes because that stuff that's going to
go down to toward the bottom of the
deck. But he does know this information
and he maths it out. He works out the
percentage chances here of sold out
hitting those elders hitting those mind
spplitters from here on out as well.
>> Also hitting that other Aurora. I swear
I see that second row in hand. So now we
know as viewers exactly where those
three Auroras that sold out has one of
them in hand, the other somewhere at the
bottom of the deck.
>> Interestingly, the mindslitter trigger
now needs to resolve. Rico here does
have his hand up considering his options
before revealing it. He can respond. And
here is the reveal. Tide Turner. Scuttle
crab. Not so fast as you called.
>> Putting ourselves in sold out position
right now. Which one of these would be
the best to get rid of? Maybe the not so
fast potentially later on, but the
adapage one is already in play. Can't
get rid of that one.
>> Yeah, the silicon herder as well, but he
goes for the defy, valuing the ability
to play his own spells here. Completely
safe
>> potentially then considering he remember
he does run a lot of sabotages and the
defy can cancel out that sabotage.
Meaning now Soda could play a sabotage
and remove another card. Yeah, it does
have that one rune up ready and
available to him. Mindsplitter getting a
little bit of work done here. This is a
better game from Sold Out right now. Has
some board presence.
>> Board presence, but still no victory
points. Teleon Hoto moves back, gives
Rick that draw. But I'm very curious to
see where this Adaptron is going to go
because once he goes in, bye-bye Aurora.
Unless
>> Unless there's an Oh, no. No answer.
Disaster for sold out. That's another
Aurora killed by this Adapatron Holstar.
>> Only a four cost unit, but it is
extremely mighty. Not in the traditional
sense, but in the ability to remove to
kill a gear completely. And now Rico
able to get that conquer point as well.
Now on five points.
>> So here's where it gets interesting.
>> Yes,
>> we know Sold out has another dazzling
aurora.
>> We do.
>> But Rico
doesn't.
>> No. So Rico now having removed one has
to play with the knowledge she's killed
one but does sold out have another one
and currently sitting on 5 6 7 eight
runes. We'll go to 10 next turn. Can
play it again but that adaptron is still
alive
>> for Rico. Could be able to recall it
before conquering again and removing the
second dazzling aurora.
>> Does he want to try and protect it? I do
see the Titan is going to be played. He
is going to be protecting it. He has red
ahead. There is potentially another
Aurora. You got to keep that Adapatron
alive because you want to conquer with
that adapter to kill more gears. So out
comes the Titan switching that location,
keeping the Adaptron safe. You thought
the queen was Amelia. No, it's the it's
the adapter.
>> You are two too right. That buffed
Adapatron is absolutely the MVP here for
Rico. He needs to keep this thing alive.
And frankly, sold out. Doesn't actually
have too much targeted removal, so it
should be a relatively easy thing to do
here. Rico, though, five victory points.
>> In goes that mind spplitter. Of course,
it's a very mighty unit. It's a little
bit more mighty than that Titano whose
only use was to keep the adaptoron
alive. And there is that second Aurora.
We know it was in his hand. Is going to
be played immediately here. But how are
you going to be able to protect this
Aurora this time?
We haven't actually had a good look at
Sold Out's hand in a while. He's not
going to be able to leave up enough
runes for Ride the Wind. He could have
potentially
Aurorid,
but he's going to put that one to base
all on that Aspirin's climb.
>> Aurora is a word now.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Get Aurorid. The double
gust. The last rights. There's the
Elder.
>> That could be the answer that Sold Out
needs potentially to be able to get rid
of that adapter. Did we see that not so
fast though in Rico's hand?
>> We did. And he didn't pick it out. He
instead went for that defy. So he could
not so fast the elder play ability. When
you play me, choose up to one enemy unit
at each location. Deal one to them. But
critically any amount of your damage is
enough to kill enemy units.
>> Of course, Sodat is going to be
targeting that adaptoron. And of course,
Rico is responding with not so fast,
meaning that Adaptron is still alive and
can still kill that Aurora gear if he
decides to conquer. And it is now Rico's
turn.
>> Yeah, look, that sunken temple is wide
open. That Adaptatron moves in,
conquers, kills off that Aurora, but he
also has other units. He has the
Stellacicorn to get more card draw. He
has Aurelia Fervent to fight it out if
and where needs be. and a scuttle crab.
He could just send that into the
mindsplitter and get free intel on sold
out's hand and know how to deal with the
rest of this game plan. He knows the
second Aurora is here. The chances of
the third one astronomically low right
now.
>> I mean, we could see it.
>> True, true. Rico though on five victory
points, sold out on the one victory
point. He has a long way ahead of him.
He has to climb like the aspirants.
>> Has to climb indeed. Adaptron is going
in. But there is an answer. It's the
flurry of blades. Absolutely fantastic.
And with that, I think
>> he won. He won. He flurry of blades. It
was counted. He conceded. Rico is our
Sydney Ripbound Regional Championship
winner on Aurelia.
>> Absolutely happy to win that. He is very
proud of that Ireelia signature. The
counter on that Columbia blades was
absolutely important. It was pivotal
here. the plays that were coming out
from Rico here was completely able to
shut down the Aurora deck of sold out.
>> Yeah, Rico, our champion here on
Championship Sunday day two as they're
having a bit of a game debrief here, but
that Adaptatron from Rico
MVP able to take out all of these
Auroras and sold out left with nothing
to do. Christy
>> second MVP I would also say goes to that
not so fast able to keep the units alive
importantly keep that adapter John alive
the MVP we can see the amazing award
ceremony happening
congratulations you are officially the
winner of the Sydney regional qualifiers
how are you feeling after such a matchup
there
>> um well Um I thought I definitely will
lose game one because I'm on the jaw and
uh that's the worst matchup for me maybe
but like the right the win get it. Yeah.
And in game two like I have the perfect
hand and uh also
opponent have two Aurora but I have the
Titan and uh yeah
>> absolutely right and you did not only
claim the victory here. You got the best
of Aurelia but also you get to claim the
fact that this is the first Aurelia win
in the West. She's made an attempt in a
lot of the top eights recently but here
in Sydney Aurelia is on top. How does it
feel to have that claim?
>> I love her. just beautiful.
>> Understandable. Look, it has been a
really, really wonderful weekend here. I
will let you have a wonderful
celebration. I'm sure that you have a
few people here that will celebrate with
you for sure. To everybody who has
joined us, whether it is here in Sydney
or online, thank you so much for coming
here. It has been a huge weekend of
wristbound and honestly it is all the
more exciting for the fact that there is
still going to be more in 2 weeks in
Vancouver. So thank you all. It has been
such a wonderful time. Congratulations
once more to you for your victory and
have a good night. Thanks.
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
Hey, heat. Hey, heat.